hey everyone welcome to this new and
amazing video on digital marketing tools
to shine in the world of digital
marketing you should be a master in
digital marketing tools and here in this
video we bring you the top digital
marketing tools for 2023 with in-depth
explanation of digital marketing tools
to give an overview of tools keyword
research plays a crucial role in digital
marketing so we will begin with keyword
research tool that is Google Keyword
Planner followed by Google analytics and
Google search console these will help
you in website analysis to take growth
decisions and optimization of website
for the search engines we will also
cover other tools like Google ads Google
tag manager and Google data Studio
moving ahead we will also cover Facebook
ads YouTube ads Pinterest MailChimp or
email marketing and much more having
Hands-On these tools will make you grab
the best job opportunities as skill
digital marketing manager salary in
India ranges between 3 lakhs to 18 lakh
rupees per annum however in U.S the
salary ranges from 104 000 to 130 000
dollars per annum on that note if you
are looking to become a digital
marketing expert then here we have
postgraduate program in digital
marketing so are you ready to boost your
career in digital marketing then unlock
your pathway to the success and digital
marketing realm with simply learns job
as his Program stand out from the crowd
and catch the attention of top hiring
companies through a joint Purdue simply
learn digital marketer certificate as a
certificate holder you will become
eligible to join the SDM Purdue
University Alumni Association expanding
your network and opportunities benefit
from master classes delivered by Purdue
faculty offering invaluable insights and
strategies analyze real world business
cases us from Harvard Business
publishing and refine your skills with
hands-on experience in building websites
and executing digital marketing
techniques exclusive Master sessions by
meta blueprint trainers will provide
expert guidance while up to six credits
can be transferred towards the Purdue
online Ms in communication program
giving you an edge in further academic
Pursuits Unleash Your Potential and
embark on the rewarding digital
marketing career with this you gain all
the necessary skills and digital
marketing like website creation
behavioral marketing keyword research
search engine optimization search engine
marketing campaign management social
media marketing and more with knowledge
of tools like SC ranking HootSuite chat
GPT Google ads Google Keyword Planner
Google Trends and there is much more on
the list don't miss out on this
incredible opportunity take action today
and enroll in our course to unlock the
secrets of digital marketing us
accelerate your career and gain the
skills you need to thrive in the
industry ready to get started click the
link in the description box and embark
on your journey to the professional
growth and achievement hurry up sports
are filling up fast listen to what our
Learners say about our courses in their
own words change is inevitable but
growth is optional
for me both came hand in hand
I successfully changed my career from
software development to digital
marketing and simply learned present at
the perfect route hi I'm rimajraf from
Dubai and I have completed the pgp in
digital marketing from Simply learn with
Purdue University when I shifted to
Dubai from Sri Lanka in 2015 I joined a
group of company as a software engineer
but my interest in content creation
attracted me towards the marketing
industry intrigued by the marketing
functions I decided to take up a
challenge that would change my life
forever I aim for a career change as
risky as it was the rewards were truly
overwhelming even though the journey
wasn't easy the pgp in digital marketing
with Purdue University acted as not only
a catalyst but a game changer for my
career change with no profiting
certification in marketing domain it was
difficult for me to transition and
change my career towards completely
so I decided to upskill with the
professional certification program
I just simply learn because of its
tremendously High weighting to be rated
as one of the best Education portal
online worldwide is surely promising not
only were the ratings I but also the
courses were economically charged the
modules were very informative and
amazing I still refer to those while in
the final stage of my course I told my
Superior about the certification program
I was doing and they offered me a
digital marketing role in the marketing
department as a digital marketing
executive is that's how smooth it was
after working for a few years in the
same company as a digital marketing
executive I switched to a new role as a
digital marketing manager with this my
skill upgraded my salary increase and my
self-confident Boost alongside numerous
other positive outcomes I had a chance
to take a challenge and change my career
domain all together
and I took it So currently I am pursuing
masters of Masters program from Simply
learn how I would complete eight Masters
program including artificial intelligent
cloud computing and devops and many more
growing requires moving out of our
comfort zones
keep learning keep growing so without
any further Ado let's get started to
understand Google Keyword Planner over
to our experts so before we go into
Google Keyword Planner let's talk about
keywords yeah keywords we use them
everywhere and they save as the
foundation of nearly every marketing
campaign that we launch online whether
you're deploying Google ads cleaning up
content for SEO helping your products to
be found on Amazon
keywords are at the heart of how you
connect with your customers or your
ideal prospects so they are used for
pay-per-click and for SEO purposes
in the context of an SEO campaign a
keyword is a phrase a query that a
Searcher types into the browser to prove
to get a list of results examples of SEO
keywords could include words like
accounting software QuickBooks for
self-employed and workers or online
bookkeeping Solutions
now PPC keywords are used for your
advertising like Google ads your ad you
add a keywords to your Google ads setup
to help determine when and where your ad
should appear
yep so somebody types in a query Google
matches that query with ads that contain
that query yep and then with various
calculations it will show the ads that
best answers the query so a great
keyword list can help improve the
performance of your ads and help you to
avoid a high price to pay for your ads
poor keywords can ultimately cause you
to have higher price to pay for your ads
and lower at positions
so at the beginning of any SEO or PPC
campaign you should plan to invest time
to do your keyword research much of this
process can be automated and Google
Keyword Planner is a fantastic tool that
can help you with that but remember in
the end it's still humans who need to
look over the list to properly determine
the keyword relevance
so let's have a look at some of the
features of Google Keyword Planner and
what Google Keyword Planner actually is
so Google Keyword Planner is a tool that
helps advertisers find the right
keywords to Target for their Google ad
campaigns
yeah it helps you research the keywords
for your search campaigns and you can
also discover new keywords related to
your business you could identify your
competitors keywords and get ideas
around the keywords that your
competitors are using additionally
Google Keyword Planner will give you
volumes estimates of the searches that
those keywords receive and the cost you
would potentially pay when you use those
keywords in your advertising campaign
yeah so Google Keyword Planner allows
you to see how often certain keywords
are searched for on Google and it
provides data of the cost of running the
ads for those keywords so you get also
suggestions for related keywords is
great if you don't really know where to
start as far as finding keywords for
your ad so very important to know that
Google also provides the average cost
for your ads to show on searches for a
keyword so it's easier to pick and chose
choose which keywords best suit your
strategy and your budget
so Google keywords planner is a useful
tool for identifying the most effective
keywords to use in your ad campaign and
as I said before as well for estimating
the potential cost and reach of a
campaign
so knowing how frequently keywords in
your industry are searched for is
extremely important for your campaign
because you wouldn't want to Target
keywords that no one is using but you
also want to Target keywords that have a
ridiculously high search volume because
they tend to be more competitive and
when they are more competitive you will
have to pay a higher price to Target
those keywords so to summarize Google
Keyword Planner helps you discover new
Search keywords
it shows you average monthly search
numbers for those keywords it helps you
to determine the cost and it helps you
to create new search ad campaigns so all
in all a very powerful tool that you can
use for your Google ad campaigns which
is also completely integrated with
Google ads so the keyword list that you
create in Google Keyword Planner you can
then bring directly into your Google ads
campaign setup
so here are some important terms related
to Google Keyword Planner
so there is keywords of course keywords
now what is a keyword a keyword is a
word or a phrase that users type into a
search engine to find information on a
particular topic from an end user
perspective you could say it's a query
yeah and advertisers use those keywords
to Target their ads to users who are
searching for specific products or
services or have questions around
problems that they have now search
volume is the number of times a
particular keyword is search for on
Google over a certain period of time so
Keyword Planner provides you data on
search volume to help you understand how
popular certain keywords are match type
refers to the way in which a keyword
will trigger an ad Google offers several
different match types like broad match
phrase match and exact match it goes
from a exact match where Google will
actually only look at the exact word or
phrase that you specified as a keyword
compared to Broad match where it will
look at a much broader sort of range of
keywords in relation to the search term
that you defined in your Google ads
setup
an ad group is the container for your
keywords yeah it's a set of keywords
that are related to a specific theme or
topic so ad groups are used to organize
and structure your ad campaign and each
ad group can have its own sets of ads
and targeting options in relation to the
keywords that you specified keywords can
be negative as we say yeah so negative
keywords is a word or phrase that Google
will not show an ad for in when it comes
to certain search queries yes so it have
helped you to avoid wasting Impressions
on irrelevant surges and thereby it
improves the relevance of your ads so if
your keyword is accounting because
you're selling accounting software you
don't want people who search for
accounting jobs yet to see your ad
because they will not be interested in
buying your accounting software so you
can specify jobs as a negative keyword
as I said earlier Google Keyword Planner
will also give you traffic estimate
traffic estimates are estimates of the
potential reach and cost of an ad
campaign based on the selected keywords
and Keyword Planner provides those
traffic estimates to help you with your
budget setting and targeting options for
your campaigns there are important
metrics as well that are related to
Google Keyword Planner and therefore of
course also related to Google ads a cost
per click is the amount that you will
pay each time a user clicks on your ads
yeah that's why we call Google ads
pay-per-click advertising you're not
paying paying Yeah by default you're not
paying on when people see your ads you
will pay when people click on your ads
and of course what you want to know for
your campaign what is the average cost
per click
you also want to know what the
click-through rate for your campaign is
there is a ratio of the number of times
an ad was clicked in comparison to the
number of times it was shown and that
expressed as a percentage so two
important indicators cost per click and
click-through rate
finally there is a very important term
is what we call long tail keywords
yeah they are more specific keyword
phrases that visitors are more likely to
use when they're closer to a point of
purchase
yeah so a normal keyword can be dog food
and you see it has a very high search
volume which means the higher the search
volume the more likely you will pay a
higher cost per click because the
competition is very high for those
keywords yes so what branch do what what
do companies do is actually they step
away from the intense competition on the
long-term keyword or the the short-term
keywords like dog food and they move to
longer term keywords like how to make
dog food at home
it gives you a lower search volume but
the chance that people will engage with
you on your ads is bigger because they
are closer to that point of purchase
okay so those are long tail keywords
right so let's have a look at some of
the Keyword Planner features
so to summarize yeah Google Keyword
Planner gives you search volume data for
keywords once you put a keyword in you
get that volume data but it will also
give you ideas for keyword yep and it
will actually automatically group those
ideas for you in potential ad groups
that you can use it will then give you
traffic estimates and you can say use
filters as well to make your keyword
list more specific right
so let's have a look at how Google
Keyword Planner works yeah and it's
important to understand that before you
can use Google Keyword Planner you will
need to have a Google ad account web and
unique can create that by going to
Google ad you will have to put in your
credit card or debit cards yeah but as
long as you're not publishing any
campaigns you won't get charged by
Google so there's no risk for you to
when you enter your credit card details
okay and then when you're in a house and
I'll show you in a minute where you can
find it then you just start entering
your keywords and then Google Keyword
Planner will do the rest for you
so let's have a look at how Google
Keyword Planner works first of all we
need to go to Google ads so let's type
in Google ads and I assume yeah or the
fact is you will need a um a Google ads
account to be able to access Google
Keyword Planner so when I sign into my
Google ads account I click here on the
account that I want to use for this demo
and this takes me to the Google ads
interface
so this is of course a different topic
to talk about Google ads which we will
do in other videos for now it is
important to find out where do I find
Google a Keyword Planner and how do I
access it so when you click here in the
top on tools and settings
you will hear see all the tools that you
have available for planning for your
shared library for bulk actions for
measurements setting up your Google ads
billing for your Google ads but here
under the planning you see Keyword
Planner and that takes you straight to
the Google Keyword Planner so here's the
interface so here you see
plans that you've created for keywords
yes so you can save your keywords into
ad groups you can save those ad groups
into plans
and what you can then do is import those
plans as it were in your Google ads
campaign but what we're particularly
interested in for now is how do I
discover new keywords and how do I get
search volumes and forecasts those are
the two areas where you can get data
about your keywords so let's start with
looking at Discover the keywords so here
you go and there's two ways to find
keywords you can start with keywords you
can also start with a website so what
you do here you put in the keywords that
you want to look for so I can here put
for instance SEO
I can put in link building
and I can put in a keyword research
and click on that
yep so I can unfiltered unrelated
keywords I can put it in and entering a
site so I can make it as specific as
possible but let's go for these three
keywords
get the results
yeah and here you see my three keywords
and here you see a whole range of
keyword ideas
yeah and that is very of course Very
powerful very useful information these
are all words in relation to my three
words that I specified SEO link building
and keyword research
now what is the data it will give you
the average monthly searches you see
that here in bands from 10K to 100k from
1K to 10K it will give you the
competition level for the keywords now
bear in mind this is competition level
for Google pay-per-click advertising it
is not a competition level for the
actual keyword so
um yep and then here you see the top of
page bit the low range and here you see
the top of bit high range
yes so that is kind of the interface
here you have your keyword view you can
specify your columns you can exclude
ideas in this case add all suggestions
and here you can add filters and here
you can refine your keywords and we're
going to have a look at that in a minute
up here you can specify the country
yep so we've got United Kingdom you can
say where do you want to search for and
here you put in the period and that is
in this case January to December 2022.
so that is sort of the high level
interface when it comes to getting ideas
for keywords so let's go back and do a
bit more
details on this yes so let me take a
word like t-shirt t-shirt and what are
the ideas that I'm getting and I click
here get results so here now I'm getting
a whole range of ideas
yeah on keywords
so now there may be keywords that I
don't want in here yeah so this is where
I can specify and refine my keywords so
here I can say do Branch or non-branded
so I don't want any keywords in relation
to specific Brands so I can take those
out yes so your Nike keywords are gone
yes so your Adidas keywords are gone so
it is a lot more specific now
yeah so you can also say for instance I
don't want t-shirts with no I don't want
Playboy t-shirts yeah so what I can do I
can go to filters I can add a filter and
here I can say exclude
in this case keyword text does not
contain white for instance yep so that
will means it will take all the t-shirts
out where the word white comes in
yep so that is how you can get your
speed more specific with your keywords
and filter them to be more specific and
more relevant for you all right so what
you can then do you can actually select
a few of the keywords
that you say hey these are relevant for
me and you can say okay I am going to
put them in a plan I can put them in an
existing plan or I can put them in a new
plan I can put them into an ad group yep
or I can also look at the match type for
those keywords yeah so I can put them as
broad match phrase match and exact match
and then I can add keywords to create my
plan okay I can copy the keywords
there's more that I can do I can add
them as negative keywords yeah so those
are kind of the functionalities that you
have when you search for your keywords
so let's have a look now at do a bit
more on your keywords when it comes to
competition and when it comes to long
tail so let's close this let's do a
search on keywords for the term e-bike
yep so I'm going to get my results
and what I want to do I want to look for
the keyword with a low competition
yeah so here you see the high
competition and the low competition I
can sort them going up and going down
yes I'm going to so it's a low and now
remember this competition is for ads
yeah so this is not competition for your
search engine optimization
yeah so here when you look at low
competition keywords look at this one
you have stealth bomber e-bike here you
see that is a very popular keyword with
low competition which has a year on year
change of 900 percent
yeah so that is how you can find your
trending keywords yeah so this could be
a very relevant keyword for you yep so
there is also your three months change
so you can look at seasonal keywords
so I can also search for the term for
instance holiday sweater
get results
yeah and if I now look at my three
months change I can look at seasonal
keywords here so look at this Pull and
Bear Christmas sweater holiday sweater
ugly Christmas sweater yeah funny so
here you see the shredders specifically
when it comes to to seasonal patterns so
important that you identify those as
well
yeah now how do you find lucrative
keywords you're going to look at the top
of page bit Yeah and see if they have a
commercial value so what you do is
you're going to look at the top of page
bit high range yeah and from low so here
you see we go back to high range
yep so here you see that these terms
like the Bowden Christmas sweater has a
fairly high top of page price yeah so a
bit price which means there is a good
commercial value for this sweater which
also means that you could then use that
for your SEO because a lot of people
will be searching for that keyword so
there's a high commercial value and then
it's good for your
organic ranking so lots of features that
you can get here out of your Google
Keyword Planner
okay so now that you've understand the
basics of Google Keyword Planner let's
have a look at some tips that will give
you more functionality in the Google
Keyword Planner so one of the big issues
that I have with Google Keyword Planner
is the fact that my average monthly
searches are in a range between here for
example
ebook I didn't want ebook I wanted
e-bike
yeah so that this is range so between 10
and 100
000 average monthly searches now that
range is so wide that doesn't do
anything for me so how can I bring exact
average monthly searches into my Google
Keyword Planner now there's two ways of
doing that the first way of doing that
is go to the forecast section for the
with the word e-bike for instance yep
and I'm going to add a keyword and I'm
going to type ebike
yep I'm going to add the keyword to the
ad Group which is test I'm clicking
create and I'm going to save my keyword
now here you see what the details is
that you get here so I can get based on
this data uh here you see the average
cost per acquisition number of clicks
but what I want to do here I want to
look at not the maximize conversions but
I want to look at the maximize clicks
and I'm going to apply that
yeah I'm going to put it into a slightly
bigger
um let's have a look here yeah so here I
have the data so here you see I can get
two conversions
440 pounds with a five per pound average
daily budget now what I'm gonna do here
I'm going to click on the highest price
the highest budget that I would spend of
this of let's say 520 and let's see how
that changes my data so then here you
see that with this highest price
for the term e-bike yeah I can get about
000 impressions
and because I took the highest price
that would be giving me the highest
number impressions of Impressions so I
could say that on average the e-bike for
this period the monthly number of
Impressions that you would get would be
thirty thousand yeah so that is a way to
get more exact search volumes for your
keywords
another way of getting average monthly
search details is by using an external
tool called keyword everywhere keyword
everywhere is basically for Google
search so if I type in e-bike here in
Google search it will give me
search volumes here in under the Search
terms and I can see additional keywords
as well
but once I've activated it
yeah so I'm gonna switch it on yeah so
to get these details I can now go back
to my keyword ideas if I do a refresh
and because I've activated the Google
Chrome plugin I go back to discover new
keywords I type in e-bike I'm getting
the results and see what I'm getting now
I'm getting exact volumes I'm getting
cost per click I'm getting competition
and I get trends for that keyword or
those keywords as well so this all of a
sudden adds a lot of value to your
Google Keyword Planner when it comes to
the monthly search volumes so a very
powerful tool now it basically works on
the basis of credits that you buy each
keywords that it shows you the search
volumes is costing you one credit
yeah and you buy hundred thousand
credits for ten dollars that basically
gives you one hundred thousand keywords
as part of your research so it is a good
deal I think to get the credits for your
keyword everywhere too
okay so that is how to unlock search
volumes in Google Keyword Planner let's
look at the let me switch it off to go
back to the core functionality switching
off keywords everywhere let's do a
refresh yeah so we're going to discover
new ideas we're going back to the e-bike
and we're gonna see that I can make my
search results local yeah with a local
Dimension so here I can type United
Kingdom but I can make my locations more
specific so I can also say for instance
let's do London yes so I now have United
Kingdom and London so I'm going to take
United Kingdom out and I now have
london-based search volumes yep so
that's what you can get by changing the
location I'm going to look at the
popularity of search locations so I'm
going to look at forecasts I'm going to
let's say ADD test is the keyword the ad
group here I'm going to type in Super
Bowl okay I'm going to click save and
I'm going to change the location to the
United States okay and don't need the
United Kingdom so I'm going to click
save
yeah so here I'm getting my conversion
data but if I scroll down then here you
can see what are the top states when it
comes to using that keywords
yep so that is a really powerful way to
look at
locations you could also be even more
specific I can hear say okay give me zip
codes for instance here so you can
search by ZIP codes as well and you can
see how the popularity is around zip
code
so finally what you can do here as well
is to look at the various devices that
people are using for those Search terms
okay so that is it what I want to share
with you on Google keywords planner
you've seen the basic operation and I
also gave you some ways to get
additional functionality and
particularly ways to get more detailed
search volumes
so now that you've seen all the ins and
outs of Google Keyword Planner its
functionality and how to overcome some
of its shortcomings let's close with
giving you some tips and tricks on using
Google Keyword Planner first of all make
sure you use Broad and specific match
types when you enter your keywords to
get as wider range of keywords possible
in your in your keyword lists also make
sure that you research your competition
just go to enter the website of your
competition and see what keywords come
up with that your competitors may be
using that you have forgotten so you can
then take those keywords and get
additional keyword ideas around those
keywords that your competition is using
make use of negative keywords I
explained negative keywords earlier yeah
keywords like jobs like free like
promotion yeah filter those out in your
in your keyword lists so you have the
best sort of Clicks in your Google ads
Google Keyword Planner is not the only
tool combine your keyword data with
other tools like semrush or HH ah refs
and uh like the keywords everywhere tool
that I explained to you and how that can
enrich the data you have in your Google
Keyword Planner and then finally
experiment with different keywords and
AD groups while you're running your
campaign Google will give you campaign
results it will give you suggestions it
will give you the most popular keywords
that people are using so every time
check your campaign settings and your ad
groups and your keywords and you may
want to fine tune those day to get
started click the link in the
description box and embark on your
journey to the professional growth and
achievement hurry up spots are filling
up fast hello
hello and please learn today we will
understand Google analytics which is the
best analytical tool provided by Google
to check up on our website we will
understand how Google analytics works
how we can use it to measure the
performance of our website we'll also
understand how to set up goals and
create events that will help us keep our
website on track
next we will look at Google tag manager
and towards the end we will unlock the
mystery of how to rank at number one
position on Google it's it's not that
hard as you think it is
we have Rob with us who has more than 15
years of experience in digital marketing
and analytics and he will take us
through these topics over to you rob
welcome everyone this is Rob Sanders
with simply learn and today we're going
to talk about Google analytics I'm very
excited to be with you today because
Google analytics is one of my favorite
Google platforms and my favorite topics
so let's talk about what we're going to
cover today I'm going to start out with
how to set up a Google analytics account
and so we're going to talk about
everything that entails including
creating your Google analytics account
we're going to talk about setting up a
property in your account and what a
property is we're going to talk about
setting up a reporting view in your
property and we're going to talk about
installing the tracking code so those
are the series of steps we're going to
go through today in terms of setting up
a Google analytics account so let's get
right to it and so really the Bruin
prerequisite here when it comes to
setting up a Google analytics account is
to have a Google login and ID so when
you actually go to Google analytics you
need to be able to sign up or sign in
and so once you actually sign in then
you're gonna go walk through a series of
steps but really that's really all you
need to get the account going is a
Google ID and login so if you have a
Gmail account or an other email account
that you use for other Google products
then you're good to go that's all you
need to do so when you actually go to
sign up for Google analytics you're
going to be asked to set up a new
account and these are the series of
steps you're going to walk through or go
through to set up a new Google Analytics
account so you're going to choose an
account name and then you're going to
choose a property name okay so the
account name can be anything you want it
to be to name your company your your
name whatever you want to name it the
property name is really the website name
so what website are we talking about so
here I'm going to set up a fictitious
website name for now it's called demo
simply learn so the URL for this website
demo simply learn is going to be
demo.simplylearn.com so that's the
property when we talk about properties
in analytics we're really talking about
what websites we want to measure and
then you're going to be asked to choose
an industry category and so for simply
learn we're in jobs and education but
you have a number of different
industries that you could choose from
this is important go ahead and choose
the most relevant industry that your
particular business is associated with
okay and I'm going to talk about why
that's important here in a minute and
then you're going to choose your time
zone and the time zone is also important
because that's when the day starts in
analytics and the day ends based on that
time zone so so the data that Google
analytics collects starts and ends with
that time zone so very important to
choose the time zone your business is
located in okay and then you have some
additional options here okay so you have
some settings and so the first setting
is to allow Google products and services
so if you opt into this then basically
what Google's going to do is share some
products and services with you via email
I would go ahead and opt into that
that's of course recommended by Google
it doesn't hurt to hear from Google on
related products and services that may
enhance your business the second is
benchmarking so benchmarking to me is
something you should opt into so going
back to that industry and category we
chose jobs and education so by opting
into benchmarking basically what Google
is going to do is share your data that
it collects on your website in this case
demo.com simplylearn.com it's going to
share that data anonymously with others
in the industry in this case jobs and
education and because you've opted in
it's going to do the same exact thing
for you it's going to share Anonymous
data on other websites in the same
industry and the benefit of that is we
get to see what other websites or how
other websites are performing compared
to ours what's the Benchmark in our
industry and so the benchmarking to me
is important and I'm going to go over
that in a few minutes when we go over
the different reports but to me I would
always opt into benchmarking because
this is the only report Google provides
in analytics about how others in your
industry is performing versus your
website okay so it's a way to compare
your website performance against others
in the same industry the other options
here technical support and account
specialist I would also recommend man
you opt into those because then it
allows you to basically Google allow
Google access to your account and
they'll be able to help you if you occur
or run into any issues so these are the
options in setting up a Google analytics
account it's very simple very easy to do
you're just entering in a few Fields
note that we talking about a website
right now so I'm talking about
demo.simplylearn.com but just know that
if you want to track a mobile app Google
analytics will allow you to do that as
well you just choose the option mobile
app so we're tracking a website we want
to know how users behave when they get
to my website and that's what Google
analytics is going to allow us to
measure and look at we just need to do a
couple more steps in the process so once
we fill out these fields here we're
going to click get tracking ID now I'm
going to accept the terms of service I'm
going to accept another terms and
service and relate relation to data
protection I'm going to click accept
once I accept I'm going to be able to
get some tracking code the tracking ID
is the ID associated with your account
and so this number is going to be
associated with your account so your
account ID starts with UA and it's going
to be this number here now the dash one
is the property you set up so in this
case I set up
demo.simplylearn.com if I wanted to
track multiple websites under that same
account then I can certainly set up
multiple properties just know that every
property I set up in that account is
going to have a dash 1-2-3-4
Etc depending on how many properties I
set up so by default I set up one
property so my first property ID is dash
one if I set up a second property the
same account number is just gonna have a
dash too and that's important because
that ID that account and property ID is
going to be associated with that
particular property or website so again
once you finish setting up the account
settings then you're going to be asked
to add some tracking code to your site
and that tracking code is going to be
related to the account and the property
so notice my tracking ID up here notice
the tracking ID and the snippet of code
now this snippet of code needs to go on
every page of your website that you want
to track and you don't have to put it on
every page but if you want to track
website behavior on every page or
website then it needs to go on every
page of your website so if you're using
a you know platform like Drupal or
Joomla or even more popular platform
like WordPress adding the tracking code
site-wide is as easy as maybe adding a
Google analytics plugin to Wordpress for
example and then just simply plug in in
the ID now there's an alternative to
adding the Google analytics tracking
code to your site and that's Google tag
manager so Google tag manager is the way
I would recommend going so if you're not
familiar with Google tag manager I would
recommend watching the YouTube video we
have on Google tag manager you can just
go to YouTube Type in simply learn
Google tag manager and this will give
you a nice overview of you know what
Google tag manager is and how it works
but basically this is the way I would go
and I would recommend that in addition
having Google analytics you set up a
Google tag manager account and then that
way you can put the tracking code in
Google tag manager so if I go to Google
tag manager and I just go into an
account on tag manager I can just simply
put in the Google analytics ID right
into tag manager and so if I have it in
tag manager then tag manager is going to
be the place that holds the code and
fires page view when somebody comes to
my website so that way I don't have to
add the tracking code to my website if I
do it in tag manager so that's the
recommended method for me is to add the
Google analytics ID associated with tag
manager if you can associate it with tag
manager then that's the easier route to
go versus putting code on your website
okay so again take a look at the video
we have on YouTube for Google tag
manager that's the route I would go now
once you do get the tracking code on
your website whether that be through
Google tag manager or through a Plugin
or you know just simply adding the
script to your site to pages on your
site then what's going to happen is
you're going to start collecting data so
that's ideally the way it works you need
to add this code to your website now if
you're not ready to do that and you
simply want to basically understand how
Google analytics works then I would
recommend getting access to Google
analytics demo account and so if you
just type in and search Google analytics
demo account basically what you're going
to do you're going to choose the first
listing there and you're going to go to
demo account so if you have a Google
analytics or Google login then all you
need to do is click on access demo
account and so what Google's going to do
is put this demo account into your
account and so it's going to look
something like this so if I click on
demo account here it's going to add to
my Google analytics account so I'm going
to have then access to the demo account
from Google and Google analytics so I
would recommend going this route here if
you're not familiar you're not sure what
you're getting yourself into so think of
the demo account as kind of a test drive
you're test driving Google analytics
before you even add any code to your
website so again all you need is a
Google account and if you have a Google
account and you add the demo account to
your Google analytics account you're
going to be able to see how analytics
works okay and so that's what I would
also recommend so if you're not ready to
start adding code to your website then
what you can do is just simply add the
demo account and then once you add the
demo account you're free to peruse
around Google analytics to see the
different types of reports it has to
offer now when you do actually set up a
Google analytics account you're going to
have some settings that you're going to
want to pay attention to so when you set
up the account you have the account name
and then you have a property so under
each property you have by default you're
going to have one View and so here you
can see this view here so if we look at
the account we set up we set up a demo
simply learn account property is demos
simply learned so that's associated with
the website we're going to track and
then again by default under each
property you're going to have a view and
so by default the name of the view is
going to be called all website data and
so in that view is where all your
analytics data is going to be stored so
you can see my screen here there's a lot
of different settings you have you have
settings under the account you have
settings under the property and you have
settings under the view so we're going
to talk more about these settings and
future webinars for advanced Google
analytics users but for now know that
there's a bunch of settings that you
have that you can play around with when
it comes to Google analytics anything
from adding users to your Google
analytics account your Google analytics
property or view you can actually set up
goals you can set up filters you can set
up segments you can link up Google ads
you can you know set up remarketing list
there's a lot you can do in terms of the
settings as it relates to Google
analytics but so know those settings are
there they're located right down here in
this little sprocket icon that's the
admin icon so if you need to get to
these settings at any time you could
simply just click on the sprocket or the
admin icon and then you'll be prompted
to choose any one of these settings here
that you want to edit or alter so now
let's take a look at some Google
analytics reports so once you've
actually set up your account you have a
number of different reports that you
have available to you in Google
analytics so we're going to take a look
at you know customized reports we're
going to look at real time audience
reports acquisition behavior and
conversion so these are all the
different reporting buckets if you will
that you have available to you in Google
analytics so if I'm in admin and I'm
looking at the Google demo account let's
start out by looking at real time so if
I click on the real time report and I
just click on overview so basically what
this is going to do is show me at this
point in time how many users I actually
have active on the website okay so
that's why they call it real time
reporting because it allows you to see
the behavior of users who are currently
on your website and so this is the
overview report under real time and you
can see here I can see that 79 percent
of my users are coming from desktop 18
20 are coming from mobile and then
approximately three percent are coming
from tablet here I can see how they
actually came to the website so this is
the referring Source if they came from
say search or social I can see the
source there and I can see what pages
they're active on and then here I can
see what locations where they're located
and so if I want to see a breakdown of
everything in the overview I can
certainly do that if I go to locations
under real time I could see a majority
of my users are coming from the United
States okay where are they coming from
I'll just click on traffic sources and
here I could see the different sources
and mediums medium is the means in which
the traffic was driven so if it's Google
it's either paid search or organic
search so I can see here it's organic
then I can actually see what contents
they're looking at on my website so I
could see currently I have three active
users on the home page two active users
on the Google's women's white t page so
forth and so on now most importantly if
you have a vent tracking set up so if
you taking a look at our Google tag
manager webinar you know that you could
set up event tracking in Google
analytics to measure engagement on your
website whether that be a form
submission or somebody clicking on the
play button of a video so if I click on
events I'll be able to see what events
are firing so here I can see we have
event tracking set up and I can see how
many different events are firing on my
website in real time so here I can see
e-commerce somebody clicking on the
quick view click some a couple of users
clicking on add to cart a couple of
users clicking on the promotion click
and as these events are fired you're
going to be able to see them highlighted
so if something gets fired it's going to
get highlighted and I could see that
these are the current events that I have
currently firing on the website and
that's what's currently fire now if I
want to look at the events that have
happened in the last 30 minutes I could
just click on this link here last 30
minutes and it's going to give me an
overview of the events that have
happened over the past 30 minutes okay
so that's event tracking and then more
importantly we can also look look at
what conversions are happening in real
time just by clicking on conversions and
so now I could see I had one active user
who entered the checkout so that's goal
number four so in analytics you can have
up to 20 goals and so here I can see we
have goal number four has already had
one active user and so if I look at the
last 30 minutes I can see I still have
only one goal over the last 30 minutes
and that was somebody who entered the
checkout so that's real time reporting
in summary it just gives you an idea of
what's currently happening on your
website and so for me ideally if I'm
launching a campaign or let's just say
you do a new website redesign and you
want to see how users performing and
behaving then real time is a good option
for you so you could see how things are
happening in real time now let's jump
down to audience reporting so if I click
on audience this is just right
underneath real time I'm gonna see a
number of different reports available to
me under audience and so let's click on
the audience overview report so audience
reporting basically allows us to get a
sense of who is coming to our website
when I say who is coming to our website
it doesn't necessarily have to be a
specific person in fact Google doesn't
allow personally identifiable
information in Google analytics personal
identifiable information such as a
specific name uh social security number
credit card information
Etc however we can still paint a nice
picture on who is coming to our website
meaning what country city or state did
they come from what language what device
do they get to our website from how old
were they okay were they male or female
or other what interests do they have
what browser do they use so we can paint
a nice picture based on all this
information that Google analytics is
providing us under audience so if I go
to audience overview here I can see I
have all these different options
available to me to get a basic
understanding of who is coming to our
website so for example I could see a
majority of the people coming to our
website speak English and are from the
United States okay in fact that
represents 61 of the users and so Google
analytics does a great job of giving me
an overall percentage so if I have a
hundred percent of the users I could see
61 percent of those users represented
English-speaking users from the United
States seven percent represented English
speaking users from Great Britain and so
when it comes to analytics we have users
and users are broken down into two
categories they're either returning or
they're new so when you add the Google
and Alex tracking script to your website
what's going to happen is if a user or
when a user goes to your website they're
going to get cookied if it's the first
time they've been to your website what
Google analytics is going to do is store
a cookie in the browser so when that
same user comes back another day in the
same browser analytics is going to
recognize that that cookie is in the
browser and so then analytics is going
to categorize that user as a returning
user okay so that's how analytics is
able to differentiate new versus
returning so if that user doesn't have a
cookie in the browser then analytics is
going to recognize that store the cookie
and then count that user as a new user
and so when you're looking at analytics
you're going to be able to see a
breakdown of new versus returning so
here I can see over three quarters of my
traffic over the past week here I can
see April 6 through April 12th three
over three quarters are new users to the
website here I could see about 23 24 are
returning users okay so I can get a good
breakdown of what type of users are
coming am I driving new traffic am I
driving traffic that's been to my
website before what language are they
speaking okay I can also paint a bigger
picture how old are they are they what
gender are they do they come from mobile
so let's take a look at some of these
different reports under audience and so
if I skip down now to demographics I can
click on overview and when that report
loads I can see now under demographics
overview I can see the breakout of age
ranges and so here I can see the
majority of the traffic coming to my
site again over the past week now if I
want to change this date range I could
simply do that I can change the date
range just by clicking on the date range
and then maybe going say the last 30
days and I can even compare it to the
previous pair period or the previous
year I'm going to choose the last 30
days I'm going to click apply now I'm
looking at data over the last 30 days
and again you can change the date range
to any range you want you can only go
back as far as when you actually created
the Google analytics account you can't
go prior to that so here I'm looking at
the last 30 days and I can see almost 47
of my users were in their age range of
25 to 34. now when it comes to gender I
can say 66 percent represent males so I
can get a breakout of gender and age as
well as interest and click on interest
and look at the overview there and see
what the interest is of the users who
are coming to my site based on in-market
segments or Affinity I can also choose
language and location so if I want to
know exactly where my users are located
located when they're coming to my
website I can click on location and here
I can get a breakout 43 percent of the
users of the last 30 days were from the
United States more importantly I can
align my audience with goals and we'll
talk about goals here in a minute but
here I can see if I have an e-commerce
website I can see of those 43 percent
0.29 percent of those converted or
purchased something and that equates to
94 transactions so I can get a good
sense of not only how many users are
coming from a specific country but are
those users converting if I click on
mobile and mobile to me is one of those
reports I tend to spend a bit of time on
because I want to know what devices
users are coming to my website and so
for my website here or this is the
Google demo website I can see mobile
represents approximately 27 percent of
the traffic so desktop still represents
a majority of the traffic so for you you
want to keep an eye on mobile because
mobile is definitely a majority of what
people use nowadays that's how people
start their day that's how they transact
Via Mobile whether that's purchasing
something communicating or searching it
all starts with mobile so you want to
keep an eye on mobile and more
importantly you want to keep an eye on
Behavior so Google analytics is telling
me that yes I have approximately 27 of
my traffic of the last 30 days came from
mobile how are they interacting with my
website so if I look across this report
I'm going to be able to see different
metrics so if I'm measuring specific
metrics against my dimension in this
case the dimension is what we're
measuring and in this example we're
measuring mobile I can see that the
bounce Ray is approximately 48 percent
and bounce rate means that if a user in
this case for mobile landed on a page
they left the site without going any
further so they consider it a bounce if
they don't go to another page if they
leave the site from the page they landed
on and they don't go any further that's
considered a bounce so bounce rate is
the percentage of people who come to the
site and leave the site without going
any further so in this case we have 48
bounce rate that's almost half of our
users who come from mobile leave the
website from the page they landed on so
is that good is that bad well it's open
to interpretation is definitely
subjective but you want to keep the
bounce rate as low as possible you want
to keep people on your site especially
if you have an e-commerce website you
want people who come to your website to
purchase and so here we can see 4 38
mobile and desktop it's a little bit
lower at 41 now if I look a little bit
further at engagement I can see how many
pages on average do mobile users look at
so versus desktop it's a little bit
lower you can see 3.86 on desktop it's
4.5 now if I look a little bit further
in engagement I want to be able to
measure how long somebody from mobile
stays on the website if they're bouncing
at 48 percent but they're also looking
at 3.8 Pages 3.9 almost four pages per
session then that means in this report
analytics is telling me they're spending
about two minutes on the site and
interestingly enough I can see that
mobile of the last 30 days had more
transactions so 51 transactions versus
34 transactions from desktop and
interestingly enough the e-commerce
conversion rate is at 0.29 percent
that's higher than desktop at .07 it's
lower than tablet but it's higher than
desktop and mobile has the most
transactions and since they have the
most transactions they have the most
Revenue at 2 380. so yes the engagement
isn't exactly as great as it is as
desktop but we can see that people are
still purchasing with their mobile
devices so it's something to keep an eye
on and mobile is something I definitely
look at in fact since it's such an
important report one thing you can do in
analytics is if you actually like a
report and you think you're going to
look at that report multiple times then
you can simply just go ahead and click
save at the top here so if I click save
I'm going to enter a name for this
report I'm just going to call it mobile
report and click OK and then what's
going to happen is it's going to be
located under save reports and save
reports is low located under
customization customization is located
above real time okay so if I close that
up you can see audience real time
customization if I click on
customization if I click on Save reports
I should be able to see my save report
here and I do so here I can see mobile
report if I click on it I can simply go
to the report I was looking at before I
saved it so save reports to me is a good
feature in analytics because it allows
you to quickly access a report that
you've saved in the past so let's take a
look at one more report under audience
and let's go to benchmarking so remember
when we're setting up our analytics
account we had the option to opt into
benchmarking and I recommended you do so
and so if you did I actually opt into
benchmarking then you're going to be
able to see how your site compares to
others in the same industry so if I
click on benchmarking and then click on
channels what I'm actually able to do
now is compare my website with others in
the same industry so if I go back to say
jobs and education and I choose
education all education as my industry
vertical I should be able to see
websites that are in the same particular
industry and how I compare with those
websites so I'm choosing all countries I
can narrow that down if I wanted to I
can just search for the United States I
can choose a specific State and then I
can choose a particular site size so
here I'm choosing sites by daily session
so these are sites that have an average
of 5 000 to almost 10 000 sessions a day
and so in this vertical education in the
United States sites that have five
thousand to
9999 sessions per day that means that
they're approximately 310 web property
is contributing to this report okay
based on this criteria I chose now if my
site is similar meaning if I'm in the
United States if I'm in education and
I'm receiving 5 000 to 9 999 sessions
per day then I'm able to compare my site
against 310 other websites now Google
sharing this data anonymously from the
other websites and they're doing the
same with your website to those
particular websites benchmarking reports
okay so it's a shared data anonymously
in particular Industries and verticals
and so now I'm looking at a channel
report so if I want to see how I compare
to others in my industry then I can go
ahead and see by channel for example in
my driving as much traffic as others in
my industry and you can see I'm not in
fact I'm 76 77 worse in terms of the
amount traffic being driven from organic
search so anything in red is going to
show as a negative result a negative
comparison whereas something in green is
a positive comparison so if I look at
engagement I can see that I might not be
driving as much traffic but I can see
that the pages per session are better
than the site average or the industry
average I can see if I go over again
looking just at organic search I can see
the bounce rate is better than the
industry average so the channel report
under benchmarking allows you to measure
how you compare to others in your
industry and you could do so by looking
at location and devices so if you opted
into benchmarking when you set up your
account then you'll be able to compare
your website against others in your
industry in your country region and
based on the size of your website in
terms of how many visitors or sessions
you're getting per day so let's go from
audience to acquisition so if audience
is who is coming to your website
acquisition allows us to see how the
traffic was driven to your website so
how do these users get to our website
and so under acquisition if we click on
overview we'll be able to see an
overview of how users whether they're
returning are new came to our website
and so what analytics does by default is
they have a number of default channels
and when we say channels we mean
analytics is grouping different channels
based on how users got to your website
meaning how did users get to our website
did they come via organic search meaning
do they type something into Google and
find you in the organic listing
analytics also groups users based on
whether they came to your site directly
meaning did they type in the URL
directly into the browser or did they
bookmark your website site and come back
via the bookmark so they're grouping
users under direct they also group users
under referral meaning do they come from
another website they group users by
social do they come from a social media
platform like Twitter or Facebook if
you're running paid search meaning if
you're running paid search on say Google
then do they come from Paid search ads
now if you're running display ads on say
Google's Network Google's Display
Network that's a default channel so
analytics for group users there so if
they don't recognize a channel then
they're going to group it as others so
by default Google analytics groups users
and how they came to your website via
these default channels and so I can see
how many users came to the site from
each Channel now if I want to drill down
on this report I can click on all
traffic and then if I click on all
traffic I can go to channels I can look
specifically at the channels report it's
so so now I can see organic search again
over the last 30 days is the number one
channel driving traffic and they
represent approximately again you can
see this number here in parentheses next
to the raw number of users I can see
that number's about 56 percent so 56
percent of my traffic over the last 30
days came from organic search and so
those are the number of users again as a
metric you're also going to have
sessions and you'll see sessions a lot
as a metric so users are broken down
between new and returning so every time
a new or returning user comes to the
website basically what they're doing is
initiating a session so you can have a
user who can come back multiple times
every time they come back to the website
it's a session so session is simply the
start of somebody coming to your website
and the session ends when they leave the
website and so just like we looked at
with the audience reports when it came
to mobile we can also look at engagement
by channel so just like mobile we looked
at bounce rate pages per session average
session duration we can do the same
thing here with our Channel report more
importantly in addition to behavior we
can see conversions and since we're
running an e-commerce platform we could
see what the conversion rate is by
channel so organic search did drive the
most traffic and they did have the most
transactions over the last 30 days and
the conversion rate in this case is 0.17
okay so how Google determines the
conversion rate they basically take the
number of transactions and divide that
by sessions so that means that over the
last 30 days organic search drove 38 123
sessions and of those 38 000 123 64
actually turned into a transaction which
equates to 0.17 which also equates to 3
000 in Revenue so I'm able to determine
not only how users are getting to my
website by looking at the channel report
I can actually see if they're engaging
and if they are converting and notice
when you look at a report in analytics
you can look at it by Channel you'll
also get a summary so here I can see a
summary or a total based on my date
range so I could see over the last 30
days I've had 54 000 users 49
000 of them were new okay that meant
that out of those four fifty four
thousand users I had 70 000 sessions I
could see my average bounce rate was 43
percent the pages per session were just
over four and the average session
duration how long did somebody stay on
my website on average about 2 minutes
and 50 55 seconds the average conversion
rate was 0.14 and I had a total of 97
transactions totaling 5500 okay and
that's all over the last 30 days so any
report you look at in analytics is going
to have a summary and note that any
to allow you to save it so if it's a
report you think you're going to go back
and look at at a future date then you
simply just have to click on the save
button conversely if you don't want to
save it you can simply just export it so
you can export it as a PDF if I click on
PDF it's going to allow me to export
that as a PDF now you have other options
available to you as well you can do a
Google sheet you can export it as an
Excel or you can export it as a common
delimited file so here you can see I can
save it as a PDF if I want to and if I
click OK it's going to save to my
desktop or location of my channel using
and then I can go back and look at it in
that format at a later time so that's
the export feature available to you in
analytics again if you you could save it
as well or you can export it okay some
other reports under acquisition if
you're running Google ads note that you
can connect Google ads to analytics and
this is key because now I can see how
many people are coming from Google ads
to my website and are they converting
now this is important because with
Google ads I'm actually paying for the
click so you can see here I'm running a
report based on campaign data so I could
see what campaigns are driving traffic
how much a pain per click and you can
see on average I'm paying 34 cents per
click and then more importantly I want
to be able to see if they're converting
so you can see I've spent 810 dollars
over the last 30 days and received 850
58 dollars in Revenue so you want to
make sure that you link up your Google
ads account to your Google analytics
account for this very reason you want to
be able to see how your Google ads
campaigns perform once the users get to
your website and so I want to see if
they're engaging and I want to see if
they're converting so they're all sorts
of reports under Google ads so you can
look at it by keywords by search queries
by hour of the day if you're running
display campaigns you can look at
display targeting says all sorts of
reports under Google ads you just have
to link it up and you link it up under
the admin now there are other reports
that you can look at so if I go to
campaigns I can look at all campaigns so
if you're running all sorts of different
types of campaigns whether that be on
Facebook whether it be email whether
that be you know other types of
advertising let's just say Twitter or
Instagram you're going to be able to see
those campaigns here and that's under
all campaigns and again you'll be able
to see the campaign name and you'll be
able to see metrics associated with
those campaigns and more importantly
you'll be able to see your e-commerce if
you're running e-commerce platform or if
you have goals set up so you'll be able
to look at how your campaigns are not
one not only driving traffic but two are
they converting let's go from
acquisition reporting to behavior so
Behavior reports are going to actually
show you how users behaved once they got
to your website once they landed on a
page on your website how did they behave
so when we looked at audience we got a
sense of who is coming with acquisition
we get a sense of how the traffic got to
our website did they come from organic
direct social Etc the behavior reports
allow us to actually measure how that
traffic behave once they landed on a
page on our website and so if I go to
overview under Behavior now I'm looking
at this graph here it's showing me how
many pages I've had and a page view is
simply once a page is viewed it's
counted as a page view so if a user
comes to my site they're initiating a
session and if they look at a page then
that page is going to have a page view
okay so a user can look at a page
multiple times in a session and every
time they look at that page it's going
to count as a page view so here I can
see in this graph how many pages I've
had again over the last 30 days and if I
look further at my overview report I can
see the specific pages and how many
pages they've had and I can also look at
some other metrics okay the average
bounce rate the average time on page I
can look at the exit rate which means
how many people actually exited or the
percentage of people who exited from
that page so I can dig deeper into my
behavior reporting so if I click on site
content and I click on all pages then
I'm going to look at a report by Page
this is my Dimension this is what I'm
measuring my page and now I can see how
many page views each page had over the
last 30 days now note you also have
something called unique page views so
unique page use is equivalent to one per
session in other words if a user came to
my site and looked at the home page then
the home page is going to have one
unique page view and one page view now
if the user in that same session looks
at other Pages then every page that user
looks at it's going to have one unique
page view however if the user goes back
to another to the same page in the same
session then it's still going to be one
unique page view but in this case the
home page if they look at the home page
a second time then the home page is
going to have two page views if they
look at the home page five times in one
session then the home page is gonna have
five total page views and one unique
page view okay so that's why unique
pages is equivalent to one per session
where pages is an accumulation of how
many times the page was viewed in the
same session so in other words you're
always going to have more page views
than unique pages okay so this gives me
a sense of how my pages performed so
again I can look at total page views and
then engagement so ideally what you want
to do with a report like this is if a
user is not engaging on the page then
that should tell you something about the
page itself if they're not engaging if
the bounce rate's high if the time on
page is low if the exit percentage of
exit rate is high then you probably want
to do something with that page now these
are all pages but if I jump down to
landing pages my landing page report is
showing me how many people people
actually landed on that page and so here
I can see under my landing page report I
can see the home page had 36 000 17
sessions in the last 30 days that's how
many people landed on the home page so
here I can see 71 percent were news
sessions meaning that I had a lot of new
users who landed on the home page in
fact 25
000 or 52 percent of the people who
landed on the home page for new I could
see the bounce rates about 42 percent
but of those who didn't bounce they went
on to look at about 4.5 pages per
session and spent about three minutes on
the site and the one thing I like about
the landing page report is they can also
see whether that particular page in this
case the home page did it help
contribute to a goal or conversion and
in this case I can see of those 36 000
sessions I had 20 22 transactions
totaling 1200 in revenue and that's an
e-commerce conversion rate of 0.06
percent so the home page over the last
30 days contributed to point zero six
percent of the revenue so this gives you
an idea of when somebody lands on your
website and they land on a page is that
page helping to move that person along
meaning are they not bouncing and is
that page helping to move people towards
converting and so that's what the
landing page in effect allows us to
measure is the engagement and in this
case we're measuring transactions okay
so analytics also gives us some other
reports under Behavior including site
speed so site speed to me is an
important report to look at just like
the mobile report to me site speed is
important because with Google analytics
does is they take a sampling of pages
and in this case you can see over the
last 30 days they sampled
2835 page views and of that sample they
came back and said the average page load
time is about four seconds now ideally
you want to keep it as quick as possible
I would say even under three seconds
okay now there are other factors
involved with page load time the browser
you're using the country that you're
actually browsing that page from might
know how to have the best infrastructure
you may not even be on the best internet
Network meaning you're on a cell network
or the Wi-Fi is not that gray or you can
be on a page that just has a lot of
images or a lot of code that may slow it
down so there are other factors involved
and so what Google analytics does is
show you what those factors are so here
I can see by browser what the average
load time is if I want to look at
Country I could see what country is
contributing to the load time now the
great thing about about the site speed
report is if I go to speed suggestions
okay what speed suggestions is going to
do is it's going to show me the page
load Time by Page and then it's actually
going to provide a link where I can
actually click on to get suggestions on
increasing the page load time so for
example I can look at this particular
page here this Google redesign shop by
brand slash YouTube page line number
five if I look at line number five I can
see the average load time of this page
is eight seconds almost nine seconds
okay that's an eternity to some people
now notice this link next to it so
Google's recommending seven total
suggestions so if I click on seven total
what it's actually going to do it's
going to open up a new window and it's
going to open up another Google report
called page speed insights and Page
speed insights is going to give me some
information about what I can do to
create foreign
correct the page load of that particular
page so look at the site speed report
it's important because there is a
correlation between site speed or page
load time and user behavior of that page
and there's also correlation between
page load time and a page ranking
organically on search so page load time
is very important it's so important that
I'm even going to save it so I'm going
to click save and click on speed site
speed suggestions as my name and click
OK and now that report is going to be
saved under customization under save
reports let's jump from Behavior to
conversions now conversion reporting is
arguably the most important section in
in Google analytics because what the
conversions reporting allows us to do is
see how people are converting or if
they're not converting on our website
and so in Google analytics we have the
opportunity to set up goals now you have
the opportunity to set up 20 goals in
your Google analytics View and so to set
up a goal okay so you're going to click
on admin and Under The View you're going
to see goals and so if you don't even
have goals the first step is to create
goals and so you have four different
goal types in analytics so you have
pages per session so how many pages per
session is so if your goal is set to say
three or two if somebody actually looked
at two or three pages per session it's
going to count as a goal okay so if I
look here I can see I have pages per
session set at 10. so that means that if
a user came to the site looked at more
than 10 pages per session then it's
going to count as a goal another goal
type is destination so destination means
that if somebody actually went to a
specific page then it it's going to
count as a goal and in this case I can
see here that the goal is set to this
particular page here and so when
somebody actually lands on that page
it's going to count as a goal now there
are two other goal ties we can look at
one is duration so just like pages per
session in our previous example is
somebody looked at 10 pages per session
it's going to count as a goal with
duration it's based on time so in this
particular case if you set up a duration
goal and the duration is set to say one
minute and 30 seconds then that means if
a user comes to my website and they
spend at least one minute and 30 seconds
then it's going to count as a goal okay
and then the fourth type of goal in
Google analytics is an event based goal
so when you set up event tracking you
could turn that event into a goal so if
somebody clicks on say the submit button
of a form you can turn that event into
to a goal so here you can see the
category equals contact form so you can
always verify if a goal works just by
clicking on verify this goal and in this
case this event is turned into a goal so
anytime somebody fires this event it's
going to count as a goal so you have
four different goal types in Google
analytics you have pages per session
destination event and duration and so
once you've set up a goal then you can
measure goals under conversions so now
if I look at goals overview I can be
able to see how many total goal
completions I've had so if I want to
look at it by goal I can just choose the
goal option here so if I want to look at
for example goal two engaged users this
was the pages per session I can see that
I had a conversion rate at 10 meaning
that I had 7 000 of all the users that
came to the website 7000 in goal
completions meaning
7106 users looked at 10 pages or more on
my website and so that's how you want to
be able to measure whether users
wherever they're coming from whoever
they are whatever Pages they look at you
want to be able to look at the
conversion reports to see if they're
actually converting based on the goals
you've set up whether that's pages per
session duration destination or event
goal conversion tracking reports can
help you measure who is actually
converting and the great thing about
Google analytics here is that I can
actually see by segments so the default
segment in a segment is just looking at
a specific user set so the default
segment is always all users however I
can choose a different segment so if I
want to choose instead of all users if I
want to choose Mobile Traffic I can
select Mobile Traffic hit AI so I'm
actually now looking at a subset of data
I'm looking at mobile traffic so if all
the mobile users have come to my site I
can see 1400 engaged or looked at 10
pages or more okay and that's a seven
percent conversion rate so the great
thing about Google analytics is you have
the opportunity to set up four different
goal types okay based on those goal
types you can go to goals overview and
look at the conversion rates of each
goal but you can also change the
segments of that particular goal to see
who exactly converted okay another
report I like under conversions is the
multi-channel funnel report so if I
click on multi-channel funnel basically
what this allows me to do is see how
different channels work together to
convert so remember the channel
reporting we looked at under acquisition
here I can see now how different
channels work together to drive the
converter version so if I look at three
channels direct organic and referral I
can see all three together drive two
percent of the conversions if I look at
direct and referral twelve and a half
percent if I look at direct and organic
12.24 so I can see how different
channels work together and so if I look
at top conversion paths as an example I
can actually see what channels how
channels work together to drive the
conversion so in this example I can see
over the last 30 days that my top
channel grouping was direct times two
meaning that somebody came to the
website directly meaning they typed in
the URL in the browser or they
bookmarked it and came to the site okay
they came the first time but didn't
convert but then they came back a second
time via direct and then converted so
that combination is my top conversion
combination over the last 30 days my
second best conversion gen grouping is
organic search and direct meaning that a
user came to the website via organic
search first did not convert and then
came back via direct the second time and
converted so basically what analytics
does is give credit to the last referral
meaning if you came to the website via
referral or referring website and
converted then the referring website's
gonna get the credit for the conversion
but analytics does a good job of showing
you how different channels work together
so a channel may drive a lot of traffic
like organic search but that traffic may
not convert the first time around for a
number of different reasons whether it
could be brand recognition Price
shopping reading content whatever the
case analytics is able to measure if
that channel actually did contribute at
a later point and in this case we could
see organic search drove traffic that
didn't convert art but that traffic came
back a second time via direct and did
convert so that's our second best
Channel grouping and so the
multi-channel funneling Report top
conversion pass to me is a good report
to look at so you can actually see not
only have channels work together but you
can see sources and mediums and
campaigns and how all that all those
different campaigns from different
sources work together to convert so
that's just a good report to look at
there are so many different reports
available in analytics there's so many
that we haven't even gotten to yet so my
advice if you look at the demo report
you can get a feel for each of these
reports under each section whether that
be audience acquisition Behavior or
conversions take a look at these reports
see what makes sense to you see what you
can use to improve your website
performance for this particular webinar
we're gonna jump into Google analytics
Direct play and spend all of our time
there because it's about learning
practical applications so goals are
important goals uh let me just say this
goals are in analytics something that
should be aligned with your business and
we call goals that are align with your
business kpis or key performance
indicators so it's very important as a
precursor that you know how to set up
goals in Google analytics because if
you're using Google analytics you want
to measure everything against the goal
so without further Ado let's jump right
into Google analytics so if I go to
Google analytics and I log in okay what
I want to do is go down to admin click
on admin here and admin will take you to
basically a screen that looks like this
where you have an account column you
have your property column and then you
have review column now The View column
is where you're going to go to set up
goals okay so every view in every
property has up to 20 goals okay so by
default in analytics you're going to
have at least one view for your property
so if I have a property I'm gonna have
at least one view but if I happen to set
up multiple views like you see here then
I know for every view I set up I have 20
goals to work with so where are those
goals so Under The View I'm going to
click on goals and now I could see I
have 20 at my disposal now you can see
here by clicking on the recording column
I can see I have in this particular
property this particular view I have
five goals that are active so you can
use up to 20 but you don't have to have
20 active Okay you can have one active
two active my recommendation is at least
have one one goal again when you set up
a goal you're going to measure
everything in analytics against that
goal okay so in this case we have five
particular goals we're measuring so we
have five active out of 20 total so if I
don't know no longer want to use a goal
I could simply just turn it off if I
want to continue using it just turn it
on okay it's that simple you could turn
on and off goals so here I already have
five set up so if you want to set up a
new goal the one thing you need to know
in Google analytics is in order to set
up a new goal okay you need to have edit
access at least the view level I would
say at the property level so you want to
make sure whoever's in charge of Google
analytics for your organization or if
you're in charge okay you simply just
want to go to user management and user
management you want to make sure the
email address you're using to log login
to Google analytics has at least edit
permissions so you're going to need edit
permissions to add new goals so I have
edit permissions I'm going to go to
goals and I want to set up a new goal
but before we jump in and set up a new
goal what is it that we want to achieve
that's really the question we want to
ask ourselves what is the goal of the
website well if it's somebody
downloading something okay are you
measuring that download via an event
okay are they filling out a form
submission before they download so if
they submit that form submission is that
the goal or do you have any Commerce
site is somebody purchasing something so
these are things you want to ask
yourself before you actually set up the
goal what is it that I'm trying to
measure now when you actually do go to
set up a goal you're going to click on
the red CTA button that says new goal so
analytics actually has some templates
that up for you okay you can see them
here okay if you're somebody's
registering online or creating an
account or reading review downloading
something sharing something you could
choose all of these options here what I
normally do is choose custom 99 of the
time I'm just going to choose custom it
doesn't really matter if you use the
template or not it's just a template is
basically some free pre-filled
configurations but my recommendation is
always just go with custom you want
total control over how to set up your
goal so we already have in mind what
type of goal we want to set up so for
example if somebody goes to fill out a
form submission and they go to a thank
you page after that well what's the URL
of that thank you page we want to be
able to track how many people go to that
page because we know if somebody does
type in or fill in a form submission
then goes to that page we know that they
filled out the form and so for example
if I go to continue I'm going to name my
goal first so I'm going to say thank you
page as an example notice analytics is
assigning an ID so notice this is goal
ID 15. that means that that's the next
available goal there are 20 goals
available in analytics and so what
analytics does is they group goals
together so one through five six through
ten eleven through fifteen sixteen
through twenty into goal sets so for
example goal 16 through 20 is part of
goal set for and why does Google
analytics combine these goals into
different goal sets well because it's
easier to measure and look at data by
goal sets so for example if I jump into
any report here if I go to all traffic
channels and I want to measure how many
goals by Channel I can look at it by
goal set so if I have goal set one
selected then I know any goal I have
active in there between goal ID one
through goal id5 I'm gonna be able to
see those goals and goal set one and now
I'm going to be able to measure every
goal I have active and goal set one
against the channel so if I choose goal
set two whatever goals are active there
goal set three Etc notice I don't have
any goals 16 through 20 active that earn
goal set four therefore I don't have
that option available to me so back to
admin the bottom left navigation again
goals okay we want to measure somebody
going to the thank you page we have edit
access we're going to choose custom as
our goal setup we're going to type in a
goal name I'm just going to say thank
you okay this is goal 15. now this is
the important part Google analytics has
four different goal types destination in
duration pages per session or screens
per session to screens per session is
related to mobile because Google
analytics measures mobile app activity
and then you have an event so we're
going to cover all four of these but for
the sake of this simple example I'm
going to choose destination why because
if somebody goes to that thank you page
we're going to go ahead and put in the
thank you page as the goal the goal URL
so for example destination is my choice
I'm going to click continue now this is
where I'm gonna put the URL so if my URL
is just simply thank you.html I can just
go ahead and put thank you.html or if
it's just thank you then I can just do
thank you depends on the website depends
on the URI structure so whatever that
URL is that's what you're going to put
in and when you're done you can verify
it so what Google analytics does is
actually will verify over the last seven
days if anybody's actually gone to that
particular page so if we click verify we
can see zero percent conversion rate so
that tells us that if this is the
correct URL then we've had zero percent
people go to that page this is just an
example however if you didn't see a
conversion then you might want to make
sure you check the URL here that you put
in and if you do see a conversion rate
then you know it's working so Google
analytics actually has options so we're
saying thank you is equal to so the
destination URL is equal to thank you or
thank you.html or thank you dot ESP or
whatever that thank you page is okay you
do have options so if you have a long
URL you could say it begins with and you
could say it begins with say thank you
so this is the logic we're going to say
hey if anybody goes to a URL that begins
with thank you thank Canada's a goal or
you could say equals two so if anybody
goes to a URL that equals two thank you
then count it as a goal you have one
more option Here regular expression so
Google analytics understands the
language of regular Expressions so
regular expressions are just special
characters used to communicate with
Google analytics in order to hone in on
exactly what you're trying to track so
we can always say you know starts with
or ends with so we can you know use
characters like the dollar sign ends
with or begins with so we can always do
that so you can use regular Expressions
as well if you're familiar with regular
Expressions if you're not then you don't
have to use them but there are special
characters where that you can insert in
that are used as regular expression so
if you're not familiar with regular
expression don't choose that option you
can choose the other option of equals to
or begins with now note that on all
three of these options I didn't put the
domain so if my domain is Amma Dash
foundation.org slash and then thank you
I don't need to put the domain because
analytics is already knows what domain
we're tracking so you don't have to put
in the domain here when you're entering
in in this case the go URL so you can
omit the domain so when you put in that
URL you know that you have three options
to work with and then you always always
want to verify that goal URL you always
want to verify it because if you see
zero percent conversion and in this case
of the last seven days then that should
tell you something either your goal is
not set up correctly or you just don't
have any conversions either way you want
to double check that now when it comes
to the destination URL goal you do have
an option here for funnel so if I turn
on funnel then that means I have the
ability to track how people went through
my funnel so if I have a cart and I want
to be able to check how many people go
in and out of the cart then I have the
option of adding specific Pages as part
of the cart so we could say you know
step one which is basically cart we
could say step two is billing
information that could be slash billing
we could see step three is shipping
information slash shipping and then step
four could be you know confirm and that
could be slash confirmation so whatever
your url structure is for your cart and
it doesn't necessarily have to be a cart
basically all I'm doing is putting a
series of steps with URLs as each step
and why do I want to do that because I
can then track how many people go
through my funnel that I've created okay
so here I could see this is my funnel
that I've created for this particular
goal okay and the funnel is only
available for the destination URL so the
funnels available if you want to see
traffic through the goal okay and how
people go through the funnel and where
they drop off now you have an option
here to make the first step required so
if you make that first step required
then that means you're measuring the
funnel through the first step only now
if I turn that off then I'm measuring
the funnel through each step meaning
that I can measure people as they drop
in and out of the funnel where if it's
required the first step then I'm only
measuring traffic as it enters in the
top of the funnel so you have that
option available to you the funnel and
then for all goals you do have a value
so if somebody did actually convert Okay
Google analytics is going to count it as
a conversion and you can assign a value
so if you're not an e-commerce website
then you may want to think about
assigning value if you are an e-commerce
website then analytics has the ability
to track e-commerce revenue for your
website so you don't need to add a value
but in this case let's just say your
non-profit organization and you're
collecting donations
and on average over the past year every
donation that somebody contributed was
equal to five dollars well you can just
go ahead and put five dollars in there
as the value for that goal so that means
that if somebody did go to in this
example slash thank you and convert
analytics is going to count it as a goal
and then assign five dollar value
alongside that goal so if you're
non-ecommerce if you're say a non-profit
like this organization or your B2B and
you want to track some value then you
have that option there so with the
destination URL goal you have the option
of adding a funnel with all goal types
you have the option of adding a value
all goal types and we're going to go
through the rest of them you have the
option of verifying that goal so that's
the structure of setting up a goal
destination URL is just one goal type
we're going to talk about the other
three goal types because in Google
analytics there are four goal types
again destination is one of them with
destination as you do have the option
with all goal types is you have to be
able to choose your logic here so we're
going to cover that with the other three
but just know when you set up a
destination URL goal you have the option
of adding a funnel now when you actually
do set up a funnel what's going to
happen is analytics is going to measure
traffic as it goes to the funnel so
where do you look for that funnel in
information well you want to get out of
admin you want to go to the left side
navigation you want to click on
conversions then goals then funnel
visualization So based on the funnel you
set up you're going to be able to see
traffic as it goes through the funnel so
notice on this particular funnel we
don't have the first step required why
because I could see traffic as it goes
in and out of each step of the funnel so
let's go through this funnel and see how
people react so here I could see the
first step is the store front page so
over this particular period of time I
had 84 sessions enter the storefront
page so out of those 84 I can see 21
left the storefront page 63 went on to
the next step in the funnel which is the
cart page I can then see 24 people went
on to the cart page directly and 5
exited the site altogether okay so that
gave me 87 total and from 87 I saw that
82 went on to the next page for the next
step what analytics does is they give
you a percentage so in the first step we
had 63 move on to the cart page out of
84 that's 75 percent so from the cart
page to the create your account page we
had 94 move on so we didn't have anybody
enter in the create your account page we
didn't have anybody leave to create your
account page so if 82 82 create your
account and then we have 82 move on to
the payment page so that's a hundred
percent okay we have one exit so we have
81 that proceeded to be on the payment
page which was purchase so 81 of 82 is
and we started with 84. so that gave us
Plus plus the 24 that we accumulated
along the way so that gave us a 75
percent funnel conversion rate so 75
percent of the people who entered in the
funnel went on to purchase okay so don't
be confused with the overall e-commerce
conversion rate so 75 is the funnel
conversion rate the overall conversion
rate for this particular goal is
18.45 percent over this particular
period of time why because that takes
into account all sessions that have won
to the website so 18 of all traffic went
on to convert but those that did go into
the final 75 converted so that's a look
at the funnel so if you set up a funnel
that's what it's going to look like you
have the option to measure everything
from step one and Beyond or measure as
traffic goes in and out of the funnel so
the purpose of this is we're going to be
able to see see where traffic drops off
how effective our funnel is what pages
we need to address in that funnel okay
so that's the whole point of the funnel
and the funnel is available with the
destination URL goal so if I go back to
admin if I go back to goals Under The
View I can actually see what that funnel
looks like so here we chose regular
expression so this is what the URL is
okay you can see our funnel in each of
the steps we have set up notice we're
using regular Expressions here and then
if we verify this goal we could see over
the past seven days 19 conversion rate
so that tells me something's working in
this particular with this particular
goal because we do have a conversion
rate okay so that's the destination URL
goals let's now talk about the other
three types of goals so the next goal
type we're going to talk about is pages
per session so if you're you're not sure
what type of goal to set up for your
website at the very least you should try
and set up either duration related goal
or pages per session related goal so
let's talk about the pages per session
so basically what this goal is going to
allow us to measure is for example if we
set the goal to three pages per session
then we're going to be able to measure
if how many people went to the site and
looked at three pages per session so
let's take a look at that goal so if I
open up the goal here I can see three
pages per session is what we're naming
it so basically what we're asking
analytics to do is anything greater than
two pages which would be three and
Beyond count as a goal so if anybody
comes to the site looks at more than two
pages three pages or more then it's
going to count as a goal and so here we
can verify it so if we verified over the
last seven days we could see a 4.12
conversion rate and that tells me that
four percent of my traffic over the last
seven days looked at at least three
pages or more so you're probably asking
yourself well what number should I put
in for the actual variable so in this
case we see two well what you want to do
is you want to look at on average let's
just say year to date you want to make
sure you have statistical significance
so you want to look at a period of time
so if you go to analytics go to audience
okay and then if you go to overview and
if I change my date range to year to
date I could see on average right now I
have 1.21 pages per session so that's on
average
so we don't want to make our goal one
page we don't want to make our goal two
pages we want to make it three so we
want to be able to basically measure at
a higher rate okay why do we want to
measure at a higher rate because if 1.21
is the average then two pages per
session really isn't moving the needle
so what we really want to do is get
people to stay on the site longer look
at Pages more during their session so
look at more pages and so we want to be
able to see what segment of the audience
is looking at more pages what channels
driving traffic that's looking at more
pages what pages are contributing to
more pages per session so the whole idea
is you want to hone in on what your goal
is and see what's working and then see
what's not working so you can make
adjustments the whole idea be on Google
analytics is to improves website
performance and so if our average is 1.2
then if we change it to just 2 it may
not be good enough so in this case you
know we want to up the bar a little bit
so we're going to choose three now you
can choose four or five that's perfectly
fine just know if your average is 1.2 I
wouldn't choose one page per session as
my goal and I probably wouldn't choose
two so I'd set the bar a little bit
higher now the third goal type available
in Google analytics is also engagement
related and that's duration so just like
pages per session we can measure how
long somebody stays on the website and
we could set up a goal for that so in
this case I have a goal set for one
minute 30 seconds so my goal type is
duration so if I click continue then
basically I'm asking analytics in this
case anybody who stays more than one
minute and 30 seconds on the website
count it as a goal and so so before you
actually put in the number of hours
minutes and seconds you want to look at
that average so if you go back to
audience overview here I can see a
minute and seven so do we want a minute
and 30 maybe we could do that maybe we
can go with two minutes so again the
whole point is you want to set the bar a
little bit higher than what the average
is and so here I could see over the last
seven days if I verify this particular
goal I can see eight percent of my
traffic over the last seven days stayed
on the site at least one minute and 31
seconds okay they stay greater than one
minute and thirty and so the whole point
is you can hone in because this is a
goal I can go in this is goal okay this
is a goal here and so I could see that
this is gold 13. so now I can go to
acquisition as an example I can go to
channels as an example since this is I
go this is goal 13 so that would be in
goal set three so I can actually see
what channel is basically driving that
goal okay in other words what channel is
driving traffic that is staying on the
side at least one minute 30 seconds and
so that's the whole idea behind goals so
likewise for pages per session we can go
into channels and here I can see we have
a over this period of time year to date
pages per session we have three percent
conversion rate and here I could see for
example organic search has a 13
conversion rate here I could see social
media has a 10 so I could see that or
people coming from organic search are
staying on the site longer or they're
looking at more pages than any other
channel so just like duration or
destination or any goal you set up you
can measure that goal against any
Dimension just because his engagement
doesn't mean you can't you absolutely
can and so the whole point of Engagement
related goals is to figure out what's
driving traffic the site but what
traffic is engaging so you want to be
able to pinpoint that so you can improve
website performance now the fourth goal
type available in Google analytics is an
event so if you click on new goal
include custom click continue you have
the option to choose an event so an
event is something that you can measure
on your website that analytics can't
measure by default so if you want to
measure PDF downloads or clicks on
buttons or clicks on play buttons on a
video or click on a submit button or
click on an external link I mean you can
measure pretty much anything with an
event then you want to be able to turn
that event into a goal so let's quickly
summarize what an event is so again we
want to be able to measure a particular
event that happens on the website so in
order to do so we need to identify that
event so if I go to for example this
particular website here and I want to
measure how many times somebody clicks
on the Donate Now button well if I met I
can measure that as an event so when you
set up an event in analytics you have to
actually assign a category and an action
for that event so that's the first thing
you need to do when you identify an
event or let it go first you need to set
up the event in order to set up the
event you need to assign a category in
action okay so once you identify what
you want to track as an event on your
website you're actually going to go on a
tag manager or have your web Master go
on a tag manager and set up a tag and in
that tag they're going to assign that
particular category in action and so
here you can see we have this set up our
category is named donate now and our
action is click and that's what we want
to do we want to measure how many people
click on that donate Now button so
anytime somebody does that then the
category donate now is going to appear
in analytics with the action click so
when you actually do set up an event you
can go into analytics and you could test
that event so if I go to the website and
I click donate now Okay the reason why I
have this as an event is because I'm
taking to a third-party website to
handle the donations so here I can go
into analytics and now I can see a
category is being fired for header
donate with the action click so that's
my category and that's my action so that
category in action is what is firing
after somebody clicks on the Donate Now
button so if I want to turn this event
into a goal I can easily do that now
that I've set up the event now that I've
identified the category in action I want
to go back to admin and set up the event
with these parameters in place so just
turns out we already have the goal set
up so let's go through how this goal is
set up so first we chose custom we chose
event we gave it a name it has the best
practice when you actually set up a goal
as an event or turn an event into a goal
I would add the prefix event colon to it
and then that way when you're
identifying goals in your reporting you
know it's an event so I'm going to click
continue and now that I've actually have
set up the event already in Google tag
manager I giving it a category give it
an action okay see here you can see we
have a regular expression set up so
anything with the header donate or
donate is going to fire this goal so
over the last seven days I have a 0.81
conversion rate okay I could have easily
put in equals two and put in whatever
the action what or the category which is
donate now or I could have put action
equals click I could have done that as
well so let me show you another example
here so if I do this custom continue
events donate now here's my goal ID it's
going to be an event so all I need to do
is put in the category in action so
donate now and then click so that's all
I have to do and that's my goal so I can
verify it okay to see if anybody's fired
it and basically that's what I need to
do to turn that event into to a goal
okay so you need to set up for an event
first you need to identify the event set
it up and Google tag manager which is
another platform and once you've done
that then you have your category in
action once you have your category in
action you're again going to go into
analytics and then simply put in that
category in action into the appropriate
fields to set up your event related goal
now all events don't have to be turned
into a goal if you actually do set up an
event and you're not worthy of a goal
meaning it's not a kpi or a dozen align
with your business goals well don't fret
you can always just go to behavior okay
you can always go to events you can
always go to overview and measure your
events that way so here you can see all
of our events that are fired now we do
have this one turn into a goal so if
it's important for a business then we
want to make sure we we convert that
particular event into a goal okay if
it's not important for example
somebody's just clicking on a social
button then you don't necessarily have
to turn that event into a goal if you
don't want to know that it's sitting
here under events under Behavior so the
point I'm trying to make here if it's
important to your business and you're
already tracking it as an event via
Google tag manager then feel free to
turn it into a goal all you need is a
category all you need is that action and
so so one final note on that event
related goal just like any other goal
you can add a value okay so if I have an
event set up I can choose to add a value
here or in Google tag manager if I've
assigned a value to that event so if I
go back to the actual event and Google
tag manager you can see I have a value
set up for one dollar then I could just
go into analytics and say you know what
I already have the value added so go
ahead and use the value added in Google
tag manager okay so I'm going to choose
yes now if I choose no I have the option
to add the value here just like I would
with any other goal so just keep that in
mind you can add a value to any goal
type with an event related go you can
add the value right into the tag in
Google tag manager just as I've done
here so remember when you actually set
up your goals whether it's a destination
pages per session duration or an event
you can just go ahead and choose that
goal set that it's in and measure any
Dimension against that particular goal
so here I can see e newsletter sign ups
by Channel I can go into another goal
set here I can see contact form
submissions okay I can see what
particular channels driving contact form
submissions okay so just know that you
can align a goal against any Dimension
so if you have e-commerce you don't have
to set up for goal for that that's
separate but if you want to take a look
at your goals and analytics and on its
own you can just go to conversions goals
overview here I can actually get a good
sense of how my goals are performing
over a period of time so again if I
choose for example year to date now I
can see based on the goals I've set up
how many total goal completions value
which takes into account the value we've
added into these goals okay the total
conversion rate and here I can see it
broken down by the goal I actually have
set up and I can see it by Page or I
could see it by Source a medium so I
could see Google organic is driving the
most gold completions then Google CPC
direct and then I could see some others
in here as well out contributing to
goals now I do want to point your
attention to another report in Google
analytics that does take into account
goals and that's multi-channel funneling
so again under conversion goals
multi-channel funnels if I go to
assistant conversions I can actually see
what channel in this example is
assisting with the conversions I've set
up and so what do we mean by assistive
conversions well that means that if a
channel let's just say organic search
drove traffic to the website and that
traffic didn't convert when it arrived
at the website and left but it came back
a week later via another Channel let's
just say email and when they came back
via email they did convert during that
session well what analytics does is they
give an assist to organic search because
they help Drive the traffic to the
website so it's similar to the game of
basketball if I have the ball and I pass
it to my colleague and my colleagues the
one who scores because they had the ball
last well they get the credit for the
point I.E the conversion but I get an
assist and so analytics works the same
way they're always going to give credit
to the last click or direct conversion
but they will give credits to the
channel in this case that assisted with
the conversion so that's under assisted
inversion and that's based on the goals
you have set up you can highlight any
particular goal here if I want to hone
in on say the Donate clicks only then
I'm going to be able to see what
contributed to that particular goal so
there's another report in here top
conversion pass that I think is
important so after you set up your goals
you can actually see what channels in
this particular example help to Drive
conversions again this is year to day so
I can see all the different combinations
of channels that work together
to contribute to a conversion so again I
can choose a specific goal or I can
choose all my goals so those two reports
are under multi-channel funneling
there's also another report that I think
is good that's time lag meaning how long
did it actually take somebody to convert
so here you can see most of our
conversions 265 year-to-date happen on
the day somebody arrived on the website
but I could see I did get some
conversions a day later two days later
Etc so you have time lag top conversion
pass assistant conversions they're all
under multi-channel funneling and
they're all available after you set up
at least one goal and so if you're not
sure what goal to set up okay don't fret
you can always at least set up an
engagement related goal so that's
available to you duration pages per
session you also have destination and
event tracking and they're all available
to you you have 20 available per view
now if you're not quite sure exactly
what type of goal to set up there is an
option available in analytics and that's
the gallery so you can always import a
goal from the gallery so in other words
we could take a look at what other
people have set up in terms of goals so
you just have to click on the button
import from gallery and it'll take you
to the gallery and you'll be able to see
what are the goals others have set up
today we're going to talk about how to
set up event tracking in Google
analytics so let's get started so many
of you out there have a website similar
to the one I'm looking at now this is a
non-profit that I work with I'm a
foundation and like this website and
probably like your web website you
probably have some interactivity on
there that needs to be tracked for
example buttons uh if you have buttons
like this one that says donate or
newsletter sign up or there's a PDF
download or a video that needs to be you
know tracked based on the amount of
people who click on the play button so I
mean all sorts of inter activity on a
website have you ever wondered how to
track that well there is a way to track
that because by default Google analytics
can't track interactivity and engagement
on your website like you probably want
to have your website tracked so if you
have buttons and videos and things of
that nature that you want to attract but
you're going to need event tracking and
if you're in analytics and you're always
wandering around the data and you happen
to find yourself under events well if
you want events on your website and you
want data to populate under Behavior top
event events you're going to need to set
up event tracking so event tracking is a
two-part process and we're going to talk
about that two-part process the first
part of that is to identify what you
want to track okay so if we go back to
our example website here I'm a
foundation again we noted there's a lot
to track here we gotta donate now Bob we
got a newsletter sign up we have some
social icons okay we got a donate Now
button here we got a play button here
got all sorts of interactivity you know
we got a button here that says you know
purchase tickets for an upcoming event I
can go throughout the website and find
different buttons and things to to track
let me just say this there's no shortage
of what you can track on your website
with event tracking so event tracking is
just basically in layman's terms
tracking engagement on your site because
Google analytics by default is only
going to track page view data meaning
how somebody got to your website what
page they looked at how long they stayed
on that page what page they left from
more or less they're timing how long
somebody stays on the website and what
pages they look at so there's more to a
website than just how long somebody
stayed on a page and so in this example
we want to be able to track everything
here not just the Donate now but
everything because once you get the hang
of event tracking then it's very easy to
set up okay so step one identify what
you want to track okay so there's a lot
we want to track we're just going to use
one example to start off with and that's
going to be this donate Now button okay
so this donate Now button we want to
track now we have a newsletter sign up
we have Facebook and and that's fine you
could track all that but for the sake of
going through a step-by-step process
today let's just focus on the Donate Now
button what's focused on the donating
Now button then we'll come back and
start tracking these other things but
this is what we want to track to start
out with okay so step one identify what
you want to track now when it comes to
tracking events on a website you want to
identify those events so we did that by
choosing this donate Now button now once
we identify what we want to track we
need to assign two parameters for that
event so with event tracking you have
three parameters but one is actually
optional so you have two mandatory
parameters that you have to assign to
everything you want to track on your
website and that's the category and then
the action so event label or label is
the third parameter but again that's
optional okay so basically when we
identify an event on our website we want
to assign it a category and an action
okay so why do we want to assign it a
category in an action because when we're
in analytics under Behavior under events
top events we could see we have
different categories here and we have
different actions we have different
labels so if I click on any one of these
Dimensions I'm going to be able to see
some of the parameters I've entered in
for previous events I'm tracking okay so
the whole idea is you want to be able to
group different events together into a
category and assign an action and assign
a label to it that's really what you're
doing you're just grouping and
identifying the events you're trying to
track and so in this case I have this
donate Now button sitting in the header
okay in fact I have a lot of things
sitting in the header so if I wanted to
and I want to track all these buttons I
can create a category called header and
then if I track all these buttons all
these buttons can sit in that same
category if I wanted to or I can create
a separate category for each of these
buttons it's up to you how you organize
your categories because basically all
you're doing is giving a name to what
you're trying to track and the name is
equivalent to a category so in this case
the Donate Now button is very important
I'm just going to call it category head
or donate now I need to give an action
to each category and so in this case I'm
just going to say click because that's
what the action is doing it's it's
somebody's taking the action of clicking
now if it's a video and it's a play
button I can assign an action of play
it's up to you whatever you name these
parameters you just need to be organized
and methodical about what you name it
that's all and so in this case header
donate and then click okay and so that's
our category in action and so that's
clearly step two so step one identify
what you want to track step two assign a
category action and or label but
remember label is optional so if we go
back in analytics here I could see some
categories and if I click on action I
can see some actions that I've named now
step three so we've identified in step
one what we want to track we've assigned
a category in action so step three is
going into Google tag manager to set up
the event okay so if you're not familiar
with Google tag manager then you can
easily just you know do a Google search
for Google tag manager and basically
you'll have all sorts of information on
it there's a good video overview of tag
manager here that you can watch so tag
manager basically is what we want to use
to set up event tracking now tag
managers use for a lot of different
things but the main thing we're doing
here is setting up an event for our
website and so I'm logged in to the same
email address I'm using for analytics
okay so now I'm in tag manager and I
want to set up my event for this donate
Now button so what do I need to do well
for every event I want to set up I need
to set up a tag okay so if I go to tags
I can see I already have some tags set
up and some of these are events and so
when you actually set up a tag I
recommend having a naming convention so
here you can see any event we set up we
start out by calling it GA Dash event
Dash whatever it is we're trying to set
up and so in this case we want to set up
a new tag for the Donate Now button on
our website so we're in Google tag
manager because tag manager is what's
going to fire that event so if I click
on new okay and I click on tag
configuration I'm going to choose Google
analytics and then I'm going to choose
event as my track type so we want the
data to show up in Google analytics and
we're tracking an event we're not
tracking a page we're tracking an event
and so now remember in step two you
identified what you want to call that
category you identify what you want to
call that action action and you have
some optional parameters like label so
first things first header donates the
name of our category and our action is
click and if you want to add in a label
and a value so if you want to sign a
value you can if you want to add in a
label you can okay those are optional so
you just need to focus on category in
action and then the last setting here
that's probably worth mentioning is a
non-interaction hit okay so this is
automatically set to false and why is it
set to false because it's a
non-interaction no that's false we want
this event if somebody clicks on the
header donate to be an interaction so
for example if I land on this page here
and I click on that donate Now button
that I'm tracking as an event and I
actually leave the site because I have
my settings set to false I want that
click to be an interaction then
analytics is now not going to count a
bounce if I change it to true so from
false to true then that means it is
going to be a non-interaction if
somebody lands on the page and if
somebody clicks on the button so I don't
want it to be a balance I want it to be
an interaction so my advice is leave it
set to false we're going to choose
Google analytics as our setting here
this is our variable for Google
analytics so in other words that
variable is set to our analytics
property ID and more or less that's what
you need to do to set up the tag okay
you need to in step two identify the
category in action and or label and or
value now value can be anything you want
you're signing a numerical value so if
you just assign one anytime that event
fires in analytics it's going to have a
value of one okay and so we have our
non-interaction set default so anytime
the event fires it's going to account as
an interaction and therefore not count
as a bounce if somebody landed on that
page so that's more or less all you need
to do to set up the tag in Google tag
manager now if somebody else is setting
up the tag for you then again you want
to revert to step two you want to be
able to give that person the appropriate
category action and or label and or
value why because you're the one that's
going to be going into Google analytics
and you're the one that's going to have
to go to behavior events top events and
look for the particular at category in
action and or label so you need to be
able to communicate that information to
whomever is setting up the tag now if
it's you great you already know what it
is because you're entering that
information into tag manager so in this
case I'm going to go ahead and choose a
variable for my label parameter and why
do I want to do that because in tag
manager I have something at my disposal
called variables and variables allow you
to see specifically things that are
being tracked so in this case I chose
pagepath okay so pagepath is a URL and
why did I choose pagepath as my variable
for the parameter label because if
somebody does click on the header donate
button and the header donate button on
our website is on every page so if I go
to the children's page I'm still going
to see that header donate button and so
for me I want to be able to see what
page somebody clicked on that hit or
donate button and so this allows me to
actually see in Google analytics what
page somebody clicked on the header
donate Now button and so now if I go
back to GTM Google tag manager I have a
category I have an action and I have a
label which is a variable okay so note
that in Google tag manager you have a
lot of different variables at your
disposal and variables are there to help
you identify specifically what is being
tracked so take a look at all the
variables at your disposal and tag
manager in this example I'm using page
path so now once you set up your tag
pretty straightforward again tag types
Google analytics track type is event you
are assigning the category action end or
label and or value you're changing or
leaving the default in place for
non-interaction hit and then you're
choosing the variable for Google
analytics which is your property ID so
once you've done that you have a tag the
second part of setting up a tag is to
assign a trigger to that tag so tag
manager needs to be able to know when to
fire that event and so here I'm going to
look at a trigger I've already set up
for this this particular event and so if
I click on it I'll be able to see that
what it is it's a click on some links
not all links but some links I'm
actually saying Hey Google tag manager
fire this event when the click ID equals
header donate button now it just so
happens that if somebody did click on
this donate Now button they're gonna go
to another website in this case
networkforgood.com so in tag manager I
could have set the trigger to equal URL
equal instead of Click ID I could have
said URL equal Network for good.com so
that could have been my Logic for my
trigger in this case I decided to go
with the click ID and so in this case
that button has an ID associated with it
called header donate button so if you
wanted to use click ID for your event
for your button you could simply just go
to the website you can right click on
that button and click inspect element
and so when I actually inspect the
element I can see now the button here
you can see it's highlighted in the
upper Pane and in the lower pane I can
see where it's linking to it's linking
to networkforgood.com but here you can
see if I hone in a little it I could see
ID equals header Dash donate dash button
so that's the click ID notice there's
also a class I could have set the
trigger to equal this class or again I
could have set the trigger to equal the
URL or the page that this button is
pointing to I could have chosen any one
of those but I decided to go with the ID
so this is the ID I chose and that's the
ID I have in my trigger okay so that is
what's going to fire that event so if
somebody clicks on a button that equals
header Dash donate dash button it's
going to fire that event which is going
to equal category header donate action
click and then the label is going to be
page path so now that we've set up our
events we want to test to see if it
actually works so there's two ways to go
about testing an event and the first way
is through Google analytics so if we go
to Google analytics and then we go to
real time okay we can go to events and
here you can see one is already fired so
let's go ahead and go to and test this
and go to the website so if I go here
for example and I click on omagar alumni
okay so if I click on that you can see
I'm under our family and if I click on
that button then go back to analytics
and look at real time I should be able
to see this event fire so if I click on
it I'm going to go to network for good
now if I go back to analytics here in
real time under real time under events
per second I can see that event firing
category equals header donate the action
equals click now if I click on the
category here I can see the label the
label remember was page path and here
you can see this event fired on the our
family page which was the page I was
just on so that's one way to test to see
if your event works and in this case
analytics recognize the event so it
works it fired and so therefore it's
going to show up under Behavior under
events you can go under overview or top
events okay and what am I going to look
for in this case I'm going to look for
header donate okay if I click on hit or
donate as my category I'm going to be
able to see my action and if I click on
action I'll be able to see my label in
this case home page and then later on
when the data propagates in analytics
I'll be able to see under label the page
that I clicked on that header donate
button which is slash our family okay
the second way in which you can test to
see if an event fires is if you preview
so if I click on preview in tag manager
okay I'm going to go into preview mode
okay and preview mode allows you to see
in analytics and tag manager and on the
website what tags are firing so here I
could see I'm in preview mode now so I'm
going to go to the website and I'm going
to refresh and in my browser same
browser I'm using for tag manager I can
see the tags that are being fired on
this page already okay because I'm in
preview mode so here I could see
remarketing I could see page views I
could see Google optimize I could see
some tags that are already firing on
this page now if I click on this button
here by holding down my shift command
and then click on that button I'll be
able to see that the tag fired in
preview mode there's my event header
donate and I can see it fired so now I
can see it fired in the preview mode so
in addition to Google analytics in
preview mode I could see that that tag
is fired and I know that it's working so
there you have it you have two ways to
test to see if the event fires again you
have real time in analytics okay so in
real time if you just go up to real time
all you need to do is go down to events
go to your website click on the button
if you see it firing in real time then
you know it works the second version or
second way to test your event is through
the preview mode okay if you see it
firing in preview mode then you know
it's also working okay so let's rehash
our steps first step is we want to be
able to identify what we want to track
okay so it could be this newsletter sign
up it could be click on a Facebook it
could be anything we want to be able to
track an image a click on a CTA button
whatever we want to track identify it
second step identify the category action
and label because that's what's going to
show up in Google analytics remember
label is optional variable or excuse me
value is optional third step go into tag
manager actually set up your tag and
your trigger so if you set up a tag and
it's an event name it GA Dash events
that way you can see in your list of
tags and tag manager what event tracking
you have already set up so when you set
up your tag you set up your trigger your
trigger is based on logic that can be a
URL it can be a click ID it can be a
class ID whatever you want to use to
fire that event and then once you do
that you want to test it you could test
it in GTM or you could test it in Google
analytics if it doesn't fire you want to
tweak your trigger if it does fire then
great and then one thing I would
recommend is if you're setting up
various events for your website that's
the best practice what I would recommend
is set up a spreadsheet and in that
spreadsheet you know you want to put a
note what's firing what are you doing to
fire it could be in this case someone
somebody clicks on the Donate Now button
in the header you want to put the tag
name in here the type okay then you want
to record your category action and label
and then the great thing about events is
you could turn those events into goals
and that's as simple as going back into
analytics okay so if I go in analytics
and I go to admin and I go to go goals
if you set up a new goal okay all you
need to do is choose custom click
continue you're going to choose event as
your goal name and then from a naming
perspective in Google analytics for your
goal I would definitely put event first
and then click on header donate okay so
if I click now continue what is my
category it's equal to head or donate my
action is click and so I can verify to
see if this is working and here I can
see in analytics that the goal would
have a 0.22 conversion rate so that
tells me that the goal is working and I
can turn this event into a goal and when
you turn something into a goal in
analytics then you can measure it across
all dimensions that's what I would
recommend if the event is equal to a kpi
or business goal or it's of importance
it's something you really want to
measure okay it's just a click say on a
Facebook button I wouldn't recommend
setting that up as a goal okay so once
you've set up your event you recorded it
in your spreadsheet it's firing you want
to be able to then go back into Behavior
back into events okay you can go to top
events okay so top events tell you by
category as a default what events are
firing or what category is firing the
most okay so if I choose my date range
here I can just go to here to date so
here I can see my enter donate button
fortunately for me has the most total
events now notice in analytics you also
see unique events and so the difference
between unique events and total events
is that unique events are equivalent to
one per session where total events means
that somebody can come to your website
initiate a session and click on that
button multiple times in the same same
session so if I go to the Yama
Foundation website okay I can click on
that donate Now button three or four or
five different times in the same session
so what analytics is going to do is
actually in that session count it once
but accumulate the number of clicks as a
total event for that session so you're
always going to have more total events
than unique events because in some cases
users May click on the button more than
once in the same session and so here I
can see total events unique events and
if I added a value to that event I
should be able to see it here so if I
added a dollar as an example to this
particular event because it had 164
unique events I should be able to see
164 as my value but since I see Zero
that means that I did not assign value
and so average value basically is just
giving me how much average I have have
per event so it's taking into account
the number of or the value the total
value divided by the total number of
unique page views or sessions and so
because I don't have value I'm not going
to have average value but here you can
see because value is optional here I can
at least see how many events or how many
clicks I receive for a particular button
again it could be a video if I clicked
on this video as an example I can see
how many people actually started it I
could see the unique and the total
events and if I click on label if I have
a label assigned then I'll be able to
see what page triggered that event so if
we go back again to our header donate
button back to category if we click on
label as our primary Dimension here we
can see the home page had the most
unique events been followed by the
children's page the contact form Etc so
what you you can do in analytics you can
also look at the pages that have driven
events so here I can see the home page
has accumulated the most total events
followed by the contact us so that's how
you would look at the data in Google
analytics under Behavior under events
and then under top events or overview is
where you can start analyzing your event
tracking so first you need to do
identify it assign a category action
enter label set up that tag and Trigger
once you do that once you test that it's
working this is where you're gonna go to
analyze have you wondered what will
happen if the pages of your website are
not visible in the search engines
definitely this can be the most scary
thought you ever had
but due to lack of technical knowledge
this is happening in the real world with
the newbies in the SEO industry
well for these beginners this video is
the opportunity and the solution to your
problems
to get your Pages search and appear in
Google search results
it is important that these pages
are indexed in Google
and to get the web pages indexed Google
search console or search console is the
One-Stop solution
before we dive deep into this topic
consider subscribing to our Channel and
hit the Bell icon to never miss any
updates from Simply learn day to get
started click the link in the
description box and embark on your
journey to the professional growth and
achievement hurry up sports are filling
up fast what is search console
Google search console formerly known as
Google webmaster tool is a web service
provided by Google Developers
Google search console is mainly
responsible for optimizing a website for
its visibility
indexing website
detecting crawl errors
Etc
after understanding what is Google
search console
now we need to focus on why search
console is an important part of search
engine optimization
a website's technicalities are directly
or indirectly related to search control
consider you have created a website for
your business
but from past few weeks your website is
not visible in search result Pages here
search console comes into action
there is a possibility that searched
engine crawlers are not able to crawl
your website thus it is not visible in
the search result pages
to make crawlers crawl your website you
will need to optimize your website using
search console
some other technical aspects of search
console includes
fixing indexing problems
sending the updated content or Pages for
indexing
generating search traffic reports
generating alerts if there are any
issues related to indexing or any other
issue gets the list of sites linking to
your website keep the track of mobile
usability
amp pages
and more
so now it is the right time to
understand how search console works
but before we begin this topic have a
look at the range of courses of digital
marketing and search engine optimization
from skill up by simply learn you can
get the link in the description box
below so now I have a question for you
what will you do at first
if your web page fails to appear in
search result pages
well let me know your thoughts in the
comment section below
stay tuned with this video Even though
if you don't have the answer right now
by the end of this video you will surely
able to answer this question so let's
get started by knowing how search
console works
understand the working of search console
it is necessary to have a detailed
knowledge about how search engine works
search engines mainly Works in three
steps crawling indexing and ranking
let's have a look at each step one by
one
so first let's start with crawling
search engines are hungry for content
and so they send Web spiders or web
crawlers also known as robots or search
engine Bots to discover new content or
any updated content
content can be an image a web page a
video or anything else present on the
web this process is known as crawling
now let's know about indexing
as soon as the crawler discover the
updated content or new content
these web crawlers start storing the
URLs of the content into the search
index or web index this process is known
as indexing once the content is indexed
it starts appearing in the search result
pages
when a user enters a search query the
most relevant results are taken from the
index
and displayed in the form of most
relevant to least relevant in the search
result Pages this process is known as
ranking now that we have gained
knowledge about how search engine works
here I have a question for you
choose the correct option with respect
to working of search engines
you need to choose the option for all
the steps of how search engines work
option A indexing crawling ranking
option b ranking indexing crawling
option C crawling indexing ranking and
option D crawling ranking and indexing
let us know your answer in the comment
section below
now let's get started by learning how
search console actually works
search console is a primary source of
information that helps search engine
Bots to crawl index and rank the pages
of your website
thereby allowing the website owners to
monitor the health of your website
all you need to do is integrate search
console with your website and get the
ownership
allow the search engine Bots to crawl
your website and index the pages also
don't forget to submit your website
sitemap to search engines submitting
sitemaps helps the crawler to discover
more pages of your website
thereby understanding your site's
architecture
we will know how it is done in the
upcoming part of the video
also you need to keep an eye on the
errors suggested by search console and
solve them else it may harm the ranking
of your website
now let me remind you that all the
reports that are generated in search
console are based on the activity of the
web Crawlers on your website now let's
understand various parameters and
terminologies from search console
to get a complete understanding of this
webmaster tool
so without any further delay let's start
understanding the basic terminologies of
Google search console and how they work
and improve your website's Health
the first one we have is performance
reports
Google search console provides two types
of performance report search reports and
discover reports
let's first understand about search
reports
search reports help to analyze the
search performance of your website
search performance reports include
metrics and dimensions
so let's first focus on metrics
here there are four types of metrics as
you can see in this image the metrics
include the total clicks or I must say
clicks Impressions average CTR and
average position
Impressions provides the data on how
many times your websites appears in the
search results
as you can see here the graph shows the
number of times this website has
appeared in the search results the next
metric we have is clicks
clicks provide the data on the total
number of times users clicked from the
search results and reached your website
the graph below shows the number of
times the users have clicked from search
results and they have arrived on the any
page of my website so suppose if here is
a number 200 so we can definitely get an
idea
for very number of dates number of dates
provided on the x-axis which shows that
how many times the user has clicked and
arrived on the website and the number
various varies from between like 200 200
uh 250 300 and in between 250 to 300.
and the next metric we have is average
CTR average CTR or click-through rate is
the percentage of Impressions that
results in clicks in the same manner the
graph below shows or the average CTR for
various different dates
the next metric we have is average
position the average position represents
the data about the average position of
the sites in the search results
it is possible that your website is
ranking today at number one position so
it may rank tomorrow at 3 some other day
at four some other day at 9 or 10 and
again it may rank to the one so this
data actually provides the detail about
the average position uh which your
website frequently ranks at so that is
if it is ranking at one two and three in
between one two and three positions so
the average position may be two
now understanding about the dimensions
dimensions are the data attribute that
defines who did something on your site
or from where
here is the list of dimensions on which
the dimension performance reports are
generated that is
countries Pages queries devices search
appearance and dates
the dimension country suggests the
country from which the search came
as you can see here from the left column
you can get the list of number of
countries from the right side you can
get the idea about the clicks impression
ctrn position that is all the metrics
related to that query
from which the search came from or from
that location
or whatever the activity has happened
from that location next we have is the
dimensions pages
Pages show the pages clicked by user or
a page that is viewed on a search so
this this actually you get the reports
from the search console in the form of
the links where you get the link which
is the exact page that is viewed on the
search
if there exists duplicate pages on the
site then only one canonical page or
canonical link will be displayed by the
search engines out of the number of
duplicate pages so basically canonical
links are those links uh like if there
are suppose there is a one original page
and there are two three duplicate page
of the same page so what happens uh the
original page gains the canonical link
and uh this page has more value than the
duplicate pages
so whenever the search engine will crawl
your website or the duplicate pages may
be ignored and all its link juice or
link Equity or anything will be
completely taken for the original page
moving ahead to queries
queries provide the query string that
users search on the Google search
console
so Suppose there is a website it says
suppose uh let's talk about the simply
learn website so suppose a user may add
as Java course and simply learn websites
appears at second or third position so
this query
say suppose user clicks on the website
and reaches the website this query Java
course on simply learn or Java course
will add in the search console showing
that the user has reached to your
website using this query Java course and
again all the list of the queries
appears towards the left and all the
matrixes for that query like clicks
impression CTR and its average position
is appeared towards the right in the
search console now talking about the
search appearance search appearance
helps in grouping the data as per the
search result type or by the feature so
you can get here the number of search
appearance and again the same metrics as
with respect to the search appearance
criteria next let's move towards the
dates
dates groups of data as per the dates
according to the public time zones now
let's have a look over the Discover
performance report
now here you must be thinking about how
the search is different from discover
yes search and discover follow different
approaches users enter a query to find a
required information with search
whereas discover shows the content based
on what result will be best match for
your query as per the Google's automated
system
now coming to the Discover performance
report as per Google's guidelines
discover performance reports are visible
only if your website has a minimum
threshold of impressions in discover
now moving to another important
parameter of search console which is URL
inspection
URL inspection is an interesting tool in
the search console this tool allows you
to inspect whether the URL is indexable
or not
some main functions of this tool
includes
checking the current status of the URL
inspecting live URLs requesting indexing
for a URL
viewing Pages rendered version viewing
crawl Pages viewing tested Pages
Etc
in order to check the index status of
URL open the URL inspection tool
and add the complete URL
for which we need to know its indexing
status
now to understand the results check the
present status if it shows that URL is
on Google as you can see in the screen
this means that URL qualifies Google's
criteria and is eligible to appear in
search results
if it shows URL is not on Google then
the URL does not qualify the Google's
criteria and is not eligible to appear
in search results
you can check more details like URL
Discovery crawl and indexing information
from the page availability tab
click on the crawl page to see the
information about the HTTP request and
response if you find that the link is
disabled just hover over the page to
check the reason
now coming to the live URL test
it is helpful to test the live URL and
check if it is capable of being indexed
it proves helpful when you update your
page and want to compare it with its
latest indexed version just to bring it
to your notice
a life test will only confirm whether
the Google crawler can access your page
for indexing but it doesn't assure that
your page will be included in the Google
index altogether with the help of index
coverage report one can find the list of
URLs which includes the URLs Google has
found on your website the URLs that have
been indexed and identify if any
indexing problem have occurred next we
move ahead to understand about the site
Maps
a site map is the file that contains all
the information of pages on your website
this helps search engine crawlers to
crawl your website and understand your
website structure
and helps them to index the pages more
efficiently
more the crawler indexes your pages
higher the chances for the pages of your
website to appear in the search results
with the help of site maps you can
provide information about various
contents like Pages videos images
Etc as you can understand a sitemap
plays an important role in indexing
process
you must be curious to know how we can
create and submit a sitemap to search
engines
before we understand this process make
sure that all pages of your website are
linked in an appropriate manner with
each other thereby maintaining a healthy
site structure
a site map can be created in XML format
RSS format or in text format
it can be Auto generated or created
manually as well
most commonly used site map is XML
following is an example of an XML
sitemap
this is the simplest version of the site
map that we are representing here you
can submit a site map to the sitemap
reports in the search console
however sitemaps can also be submitted
through robots.txt file let's understand
about robots.txt file
so let's understand the robots.txt file
in short
robots.txt file notifies the web
Crawlers
about the URLs that they can access on
the website as there are lots of search
engines there exists different web
crawlers thus there is a possibility
that some web crawlers may not obey the
instructions from the robots.txt file it
is necessary to know how to use the
proper syntax as different crawlers
understand syntax differently
thus there are chances that some web
crawlers might fail to understand the
instructions from the robots.txt file
a page can be indexed even if it is
disallowed from the robots.txt file if
it is linked to other site
next let's know what enhancement reports
are
all the rich results status reports are
displayed under the enhancement tab
so let's know more about rich results
these type of results are known as Rich
results in serps so basically Rich
results can be any search results other
than the traditional Blue Links for
example image results carousels
Etc
you can check whether the pages from
your website support Rich results or not
using the rich result test tool provided
by Google Developers
now understanding the rich results
status report the enhancement tab
contains separate reports for Rich
result type
some rich results report types are
listed below that are breadcrumbs
education q a event FAQ fact check
guided recipe how to image license
job posting
learning video
review Snippets
Etc
Rich results status reports consist of
summary page and Details page
the summary page mainly consists of
Errors useful items found on your
website warnings
Etc The Details page consists of the
information about the issues when it was
detected item type when was the page
last crawled
Etc
before we understand how to fix error in
search console it is important to
understand the status of each page as
reported by search console
each page has any of the following
status error warning excluded and valid
if the status of the page is valid it
means the page has successfully indexed
the status of the page appears to be
excluded if one purposefully wants the
page not to be indexed
or a page is blocked by robots.txt file
for example setting the meta tag to no
index warnings majorly appears when the
page of your website is indexed
but there are some issues with the page
which need your attention and have to be
resolved as soon as possible
if the page status is error then there
is a need to pay a detailed attention
over the issues in the page as these
issues prevent the page from getting
indexed
let's discuss about the errors in detail
and how we can fix them
some popular errors from the search
console are listed below
that is the redirect error server error
submitted URLs blocked by robots.txt URL
marked as no index submitted URL is a
soft four not four four not four or page
not found error
so let's first know about the redirect
error
some redirect error
that search console shows up are the
redirect chain that was too long
redirect true
redirect URL that exits maximum URL
length and bad or empty URL in the
redirect chain so all these error means
that the redirections are not working
properly and so there is a need to fix
them so suppose for example you have
added too many redirects from one page
to another
so in this scenario
search engine Bots find it a waste of
time to crawl again and again to the
same redirections and at that time the
search engine crawlers or search engine
boards ignore those URLs or redirections
so in such cases you need to fix those
redirection to a single URL
the next we have is server error
the server returns 5xx error when it
fails to fulfill a valid request this
error mainly conveys that something is
wrong with your website server all you
need to do is reach out to your hosting
services and inform them about the issue
and make sure it gets resolved as soon
as possible
the next one we have is submitted URL
blocked by robots.txt to resolve this
issue you need to remove the line of
code from the robot.txt file that
restricts Google from crawling the
respective page the next we have is URL
marked as no index
when a URL is marked as no index it
sends the signal to crawlers that this
page is not meant to be crawled or this
page is not meant to be indexed if if
you want this page to be indexed check
the metadata and remove the no index
attribute
to allow the Crawlers to crawl the URL
now let's understand about the error
submitted URL is a soft 404 and 4 Note 4
or page not found error whenever a web
page load server returns a 200 signal
showing the success status code
in which server returns 200 success
status code and the page not exist error
simultaneously
this is considered to be a bad user
experience
this error can be solved simply by
redirecting this page to any relevant
URL or the home page of the website
talking about 404 or page not bound
error this error mainly occurs
when you delete the page from your
website but the URL of the page still
exists in the site map
this error can be solved by simply
removing the URL or removing the four
not four URL from the site map or
redirecting the URL to a new page
this will help to avoid the further
errors in near future
we will have a detailed look at other
4xx errors in the upcoming videos
now that we are aware of the basics of
search console let's dive deeper to know
some stats regarding the search console
in the SEO industry
when you're thinking of adding a
business online your website should
fulfill all the technical SEO needs
which can be achieved by Google search
console thus there is a huge demand in
SEO industry for the candidates having
strong knowledge of Google search
console
the average salary of an SEO expert
with the Google search console skills in
US is 53 000 dollars
to 78 000 per annum and that in India is
2 lakh 76 000 per annum some begins in
the SEO industry looking for this skill
sets include Accenture Amazon people
group
Eton Etc
so let me know your dream company to
work as an SEO expert in the comment
section below
search console is for everyone whether
you are a business owner a marketing
specialist a web developer or a website
administrator
Google search console will continue to
be the part of search engine
optimization technique
and will keep on playing a major role in
the maintenance of the website and
Improvement in Rankings today to get
started click the link in the
description box and embark on your
journey to the professional growth and
achievement hurry up sports are filling
up fast hey guys
welcome to today's session
my name is Sachin sehgal and I am here
to talk about a very important tool
Google ads and out of all the ads we can
create under Google ads today we would
be talking about a very important one
Google search ad
this is going to be very exciting this
is going to be very deep from my
experience I can say I will going to
take you through a lot of technical
aspects and lot of optimization
strategies where you can really bring
down the cost down if you're really
paying high for your clicks and
conversion so please be with me and I
would try to give you the best from my
site great so let's just start guys
Google ads is something which we have
discussed in the last class if you have
seen my last session if you have not we
will leave the link in the description
where we talked about the basics of
Google ads and we also talked about how
to create this beautiful ad account or a
tool with a free Gmail ID okay
we did talked about few more things that
how many types of ads you can create
just to give you the quick glimpse we
are on Google and when we type something
like if I want to do a data analytics
course
so I would type few things like a word
or a keyword or a query into Google
search engine and then Google as a
search engine would show me few results
the results which we see on the top we
are talking about these today you know
this is the topic or this is the kind of
an ad which we would create today in
this session this is called Tech start
or this is also called Google search ad
okay so this is the first type of an ad
you see or which you can create under
the Google ads there are few more just
like if you would go and search for any
of the e-commerce product probably by
winter
jacket
online
so then there would be results but in a
different shape and color and different
structure there is an ad which is a text
ad but on the top we are able to see
some more ads but they are not just text
they have a pricing they have a title
they have a brand name they have an
image of the product so they are called
shopping ads or product listing ads in
addition to that sometimes you know when
you go to a product a website like speed
test and you see the product ads there
but again in the different shape and
color so they are called
display ads because they've been
displayed on different websites and
different apps so why I'm going so fast
in explaining you different type of ads
because as I told you we have another
video created uh with the name of Google
ads for beginners 2023 you can just
check the link in the description and
you will able to get all this type of
ads and whatever the uh you know bidding
strategies to be used in basic in that
particular tutorial or that demo just
has to show you if you can see that ads
by Google so this is the display Adder
banner ads just quickly I have shown you
three types of the ads but our Focus as
I said today going to be on a very
specific ad which
is the most important ad from the Google
ads family okay so let's just begin guys
when I come to Google ads this is how
the Google ad structure looks like
we have a Google ads account created
again I repeat if you don't know how to
create it please find the link in the
description to create the Google ads
account once a Google ads account
created then you would have a dashboard
like this okay in this dashboard you can
see there are campaigns there are ad
groups there are ads there are videos
there are landing pages so a lot of
things can be confusing if we are just
coming to this account or to this
beautiful tool for the very first time
so to just keep it very simple or to
explain in uh in a very simpler way what
I did is I just drawn this structure for
you okay so the structure says that you
have a Google ads account imagine that I
am a simply learned Google ads manager
so I am running the ads for all simply
learn keywords like data analytics
course digital marketing course or any
machine learning course python course so
whenever somebody types this so there is
a ad which shows like from Simply
probably we have to just assume because
currently I'm not able to see any simple
an ad here so data analytics course
India
and then probably we can see if there
are any
you can always change the keywords but
just to test time randomly changing the
words or I could have just written
simply learned specifically because I
want to go with simple learn only I have
researched a lot and I feel like this is
one of the best okay so probably there
is no ad though
still I would check
probably I have to just change the codes
so I will go for the another course
which is by simply learn again and then
probably we can expect any of the ads
running
because this is not a very peak time so
we are probably you know saving some of
the cost not running the ads at this all
hour anyhow so we can assume that this
is the ad you know I am running for so
how we can create this ad how we can get
the best of clicks as I said it is not
the very best time to run the ad so this
is also kind of a change you know we can
bring into our ads by doing some
research so how all these things are
done we're going to be learning it okay
so when we come here to the dashboard
and then we see our dashboard looks like
this a bit complicated so we can be
confused we can be disheartened that I
have created the account by seeing uh
the first video but now I am all stuck
okay so probably I have to again wait so
the weight is over now we are here to
understand the whole structure okay so
let me just take a very simple example
suppose I uh I'm someone who's selling a
shoes okay because I have just said
simply learn probably let's just convert
it to any of the Google ads account of a
shoe seller probably I am Nike okay and
I am making the add for Nike shoes and I
am selling two types of the Nike shoes
today probably formal or Canvas OR
probably I am selling the casual or any
sports shoes and what I did I created
the campaign named it search ad
uh any month you know whatever the month
you have started with suppose November
so November 2022 that is the name which
I am giving name can be changed name is
something which is being put it up for
my reference so that after creating a
lot of campaigns I'm not confused in
which campaign I have to check the
results okay so I'm running the search
chart for shoes for the month of
February or November or December 22 23
whatever and then I open two ad groups
into it why I'm opening two ad groups
under one campaign because I'm selling
two kind of products under the shoes
only I'm selling formal also
under the shoes only I am selling casual
also so what happens suppose I would
have just you know created one hard
group and would have inserted or
submitted all the keywords of formal and
Casual inside one hat group then if
somebody would have searched a term
called formal black shoes then this ad
group would have got confused that
should I show formal ad shoes or should
I show casual ad shoes because what I
did I have just got all my keywords like
formal casual Cricket shopping jogging
party
office you know all the mix of the
keywords from formal and Casual family
into the same ad group the moment any of
these six keywords being typed or been
searched on Google then this ad group
would have got triggered and then again
randomly it would have shown the ad of a
formal or ad of a casual because both of
the ads would have been under this okay
but after doing uh this bifurcation or
after doing this segmentation what would
happen all the formal keywords like
party shoes office shoes formal shoes
formal black shoes would go here
this ad group would trigger if any of
this keyword would search and
accordingly this ad which has everything
related to only formal shoes will be
shown and of course with that ad the
landing page is connected which would be
open you know when somebody clicks the
ad okay and vice versa if somebody would
have searched for a casual term like a
casual shoes sports shoes jogging shoes
running shoes then this ad group would
have triggered and then the casual shoes
ad with all the headline related to that
casual keywords would have been shown
and accordingly if somebody would have
clicked then the landing page of casual
shoes you know would have opened okay so
if this is clear actually you are very
much ready to uh dive into the Google
ads because many people takes a lot of
time to understand the structure because
uh you know maybe they are very much
confused at the art group level but I
have just tried level based by bringing
this example why I am creating two
different ad groups I why I'm not just
going with the same ad group you know
mixing all the keywords
second scenario could have been on a
second permutation could have been I
would have just you know probably
created two different campaigns all
together I would have named The Campaign
one with search ad formal shoes November
okay then only that only this part would
have belonged to the first campaign then
I would have created a different
campaign altogether and would have named
it campaign search ad
casual shoes November then this second
campaign or a second campaign can be
assumed here with you know with a green
color would have been drawn okay so this
is how on the structure it works like we
can always now create inside so let's
just see a few things uh before we
create the ad okay very important uh
requirement or rather I would say uh if
being the campaign manager of any any
any any company you name any startup you
name or any client you work with or
probably for yourself as well you have
to be very much sure how these terms
works like Okay so this terms when I
talk about is going to be a bit inclined
towards the search ad today only and
when I talk about the display ad in the
next video then I would you know take
you through about the terminologies and
all the kpis off display Banner or video
ads okay so now if I talk about a search
ad a very important
um term which we should be aware of is
the maximum bid price
okay because we all know when we're
talking about this ad which is called a
text ad then we are paying on every
click okay that's why this is also
called PPC ad this is also called PPC
marketing or you can understand in a
very simple words uh Advertiser which is
Emirates this in this particular ad only
has to pay when somebody like Sachin
this movement clicking this ad I click
this ad I reach to the landing page of
this particular University or this
college and a certain amount is deducted
from this particular ad account and that
certain amount actually decides or
decided on the basis of the keyword
helped to show this ad okay so as an
Advertiser must have paid something to
Google ads for showing this ad for this
keyword okay so when I say a maximum bid
price it means it's a maximum bid price
of a keyword that's why now this would
be easier to understand by this example
suppose I want to run the ad on the term
called data analytics course 2022 what I
did I have opened the Google Keyword
Planner you know I did talked about this
in the previous session but I will take
you through again how you use a Keyword
Planner smartly so I have got this data
from the keywords planner that the
average price I have to pay for this
keyword to show my ad is 5 to 10 Rupees
so what I did I just played a bit of
maths and I have bidded something over
the minimum bit price okay this is the
minimum bit price is the maximum bit
price okay and this is what I've got
from the Keyword Planner so rather than
going for a very high price or the
maximum bit price to secure my position
I want to play safe and what I would do
I would just take a chance maybe 30 40
over the minimum bit range and then I
will see if the Impressions or clicks
are coming or not if this starts coming
it means that my ad is accepted and my
keyword is you know winning in the
auction and I'm able to get the clicks
but if it is not picking then certainly
I have to increase my bid price but
coming back to the terminology is what
we're talking here is once I have set it
up my maximum bit price of 7 rupees then
my ad would start showing suppose my ad
shows for thousand times today and every
time when my ad been clicked you know
certain amount being deducted there is a
competition there are other advertisers
also you know who are running the ad and
after showing my ad for the whole day
Google in the dashboard just shown that
you have paid average CPC of 5 rupees
only so I bid it for 7 but by seeing
different uh you know factors like the
competition the demand and how many
times the ads got clicked what was the
position where my ad was shown I ended
up in paying five rupees for every Click
by the end of a day so the average CPC
sometimes you know people get confused
they have a CPC and the maximum build
price is the same no so maximum bit
price is something which I uh you know
submit to Google that this is the
maximum I can pay for my ad to show on
certain keyword for every click and I
have a CPC something which actually you
know I pay every day or you know in that
average of the duration you had got
displayed or got clicks uh for every uh
click on that particular keyword okay or
the number of keywords if you have more
than one keyword submitted and suppose
I've got 100 clicks then you know it's a
simple math that my budget which I have
spent today is five rupees for one click
500 rupees 400 click so daily budget
would be 500 rupees and tomorrow if
company says I need 300 clicks then of
course my average CPC which I have from
the historical date of yesterday you
know I would just do my maths and I will
going to submit the daily budget of not
100 rather 300 today so that in 1500 I
can expect 300 clicks at the cost of
five rupees per click okay so this is a
very simple of the example to just make
you explain how things works you know
you submit something then on the basis
of a lot of factors you know Google
calculates Google gives you clicks and
once you have the data then you know you
can just understand how this all is
working okay last thing before we dive
into the tool is Keyword Planner so I
just told you we have done in the last
class how this works like so we go into
tool and setting and then we go into
Keyword Planner I'll show you in the
account also the Google ads account just
after 30 seconds uh the screenshots over
so your Keyword Planner opens and then
you discover the keyword suppose I am
selling data analytics course so I would
just put my search term data analytics
course and then I'll click the get
result and then accordingly it will show
me lot of options and this is the
pricing I was talking about it gives me
the low price and the high price so I
would take the 30 40 percent over the
low bid price or the average price
between these both and that would be my
maximum bit price and after checking all
the permutations Google would show my ad
or either it would not show my ad also
that there can be a chance so I have to
just wait for my impression and clicks
and the results by the end of a day and
I would you know I would know uh how
much the average CPC actually I'm paying
for each keyword okay so I'll show you
all those reports in a while
uh that's it right now let's just go and
see few things so the Keyword Planner
will start with suppose I start
you know in researching all these things
my campaign is about data analytics
course
I'm making it for symptom probably and I
would go and I would just try to you
know search into planning my Keyword
Planner and then I will write a term
quickly here you know whatever I want to
show my ad for
suppose data analytics course as I said
okay probably let's check digital
marketing because we would have more
results so it's
easy to understand with a lot of results
because I would able to tell you how to
sort and filter them down uh digital
marketing course and you can just test
it with any of the keywords I'm just
doing a random check
so once we are here we have a lot of
keywords in addition to what we have
submitted so the keyword which I have
provided is this and the result shows
that it had over 100k uh you know
monthly searches and uh of course in the
range of 1 million in the in the you
know in the month of 2021 to September
22 so this is actually the average
monthly searches happened in between
this period and uh the advertise is
actually paid as low as 44 Rupees to as
high 20 224 rupees okay that can easily
be uh you know converted to dollars uh
half a dollar or maybe more than half a
dollar UH 60 70 cents probably and uh
this is like going to be a three dollars
cost okay so what we can do is we can
see now there are a lot of keywords been
given and we can easily sort them down
here on certain you know uh bases like
you know suppose the monthly searches
are high or the bid is low and all that
of but this is quite you know difficult
when we have to sort down here in the
Keyword Planner so what I do is I'm just
going to talk about the same you know
like hi how I actually go when I am
working for my clients okay I have
clients here a lot of clients I don't
want to show you but yeah I have and um
suppose I just go and download this data
from here
and then this would be you know
downloaded in the Excel format and we
can just save it anywhere suppose I just
bring it here and then now I would open
the keyword sheet
and I would have a data in my Excel okay
so I need this this one so this is the
most important column because I have to
highlight uh which column is important
and what is not required right now so
whatever is required I'm just I'll be
keeping with me and what I feel like is
not very important as of now I'm just
not going to be taking them so now there
are
five column which I have kept with
myself like
these four where we talk about the
results
okay
this is not required this is not
required so I'm just going to be
deleting or hiding them okay so when we
talk about our competition index value
so this actually tells us that a
particular keyword is how much uh you
know from the competition point of view
is difficult to rank suppose I talk
about two keywords right now let me just
take
um a one with a lower score suppose this
one and I would take the higher or the
highest one probably is this one okay so
now when I talk about a comparison you
know probably uh or or probably let's
say this this one because this has a
monthly searches which are equivalent uh
you know from the compression point of
view they are very different but the
search has been same so if I would stuck
to something of this sort that if I have
to finalize between these two so what I
would do you know that's something which
we are talking here you know if we have
a kind of a combination where we have to
decide out of these two so both are of
the keywords meaning very important if I
would just check from my naked eye a
quick Scan they look very promising they
look very great to me suppose and they
have a equivalent number of searches in
the last you know one year on the
average monthly basis but there is a
difference between the competition okay
now people can be confused what is this
competition so I would just make you
explain in a very simpler way Suppose
there are 100 companies so there are 100
you know ethic institutes or probably
physical institutes who teaches uh
digital marketing because we are doing
online marketing or you know additional
marketing course online so so let's keep
it online uh institutes like simply
learn and all okay so what they have
done is in the last one year they all
have used these keywords to run their
ads you know to show their advertisement
or their digital ad on a Google space
okay when this data has been given so
this is telling me that out of those 100
advertisers or my 100 competitors
66 or a 66 percent advertisers have used
this ad
okay or have used this keyword to show
their ad okay and out of 100 33 percent
or if it is 100 then 33 advertisers have
used this keyword to show their ad okay
so it brings you know kind of a
comparison to US that probably these two
keywords are very much in demand you
know like equally from the searches
point of view because both have been
searched equally but whenever this has
been searched then there has been a
competition where 66 people or 66
advertisers or 66 percent advertisers
are fighting to show their ad okay and
when this keyword being searched as
equally then only 33 percent or 33
people or 33 advertisers are fighting to
show their ad on Google space okay when
I talk about 100 then that seems to be
okay where my AdWords apply you know
where my ad would show because if I just
go on a Google space you know that only
seven ads are shown when you know when
we go on a Google search engine one two
three and four and then the rest three
would be at the bottom if they are shown
at this moment or not I'm not very sure
so three would be here somewhere so
total seven adds placement on the first
page nobody goes beyond first we know
that 97 of the worldwide audience won't
don't go beyond the first pagination
okay so we have to be on our first page
so if I talk about from the first page
seven positions point of view it would
make more sense so let's imagine there
are only 10 advertisers of digital
marketing course so out of 10 if I take
out 66 66 percent then it means almost
like six to seven advertisers are
fighting or have bidded or probably are
trying to outrank each other to show
their ad on the top or on the first four
versions of Google but when I talk about
this then only three to four advertisers
are fighting or have bidded for this
keyword to show the ad on the first page
so this actually is a very important
data sometimes we just you know Miss it
because it has not been uh I think
explained anywhere else that what
exactly this value is we only go by the
low medium high which is the very first
column I delete nowadays you know I
don't you know go by this because they
both come under the medium but there is
a big difference you know seven out of
ten would have been bidded for and only
three to four would have been bidded for
this keyword so never go by the high
medium or low just go by the index value
because that's a percentage of The
Advertiser who are actually trying to
fight for the same keyword to show their
ad on the top okay this is how we you
know shorten or we get the best keywords
we try to get the best searched keyword
with the you know kind of a index value
between 50 to 60 less than that and then
we of course you know go for the bit
value or a bit price which is also on a
very lower side not a very high price
keyword we go with so this is the
criteria you know I actually follow and
that's something which you know you can
see I have also mentioned here you can
see that much uh you know we go for the
high search keyword and then we'll try
to get the low medium competition
keywords which of course less than 60
index value and then I put a price you
know kind of a price of my price you
know which is like if the low bid price
is 10 Rupees then I just make it 13 by
adding 30 to it so if the pricing is 10
so I would add 30 to it that makes my
price 13 and then I check you know uh if
in the first if the Impressions has come
it means my price actually been accepted
but if any of the keyword my price is
not accepted then I would again revise
the price by 20 30 and then would wait
on the secondary report and that's how
you know I keep changing for the first
two three days and keep seeing the
results and once the you know every
keyword gets pick up and I get the you
know it starts getting the stable
results then I uh just as allow the
campaign to work uh you know on the
algorithm and in I I see results
actually moves in the positive direction
when you give some time to campaigns to
read and to learn you know from the
audience Behavior okay so this is about
the keyword planning which we have just
seen
now moving to again a very important
aspect because campaign making is
something which I've already given you
the you know Glimpse in the last class
so I would again give you today but
before that I really you know wanted
today to speak on all these technical
aspects you know which works at the back
end so that's why my focus is more on
this uh presentation parallely I would
keep showing you the uh you know the
Google ads other demo and everything
okay so now when we move to the next
part next part is very important from
the
um add algorithm point of view so what
happens or what used to happen uh when
when the quality score in which I'm just
trying to speak now I was not there uh
what used to happen the one who used to
pay the highest bid price used to get
the first position and the second one is
to get the second position and the third
bidder used to get the third position so
I have just brought into this table
suppose a Advertiser has been at 8 rupee
B10 C 15 and D 20 and when the quality
score concept was not there so they
actually been given the very direct
position this one first this one second
this one third and this one fourth but
they have realized or Google has
realized that the one who is paying the
most is not having a very good quality
of the ad uh his uh landing page or the
website it's is not working or probably
the pages which is which are connected
are not very relevant and the keywords
on which the ads been shown is nowhere
near uh you know when the landing page
is open so it it was like a very
negative impact on Google when the
review has been checked and people or
the users who are clicking on those ads
were not happy so what Google did Google
brought us you know kind of um uh test
score or a check which is called quality
score for every keyword we bid okay and
this is only for the server chats that's
why I said on all the keywords we made
okay I'll just show you the result on a
client side so when we submit our ad on
the basis of you know different keyword
we bid and the and the strategy we use
and the landing page we connected the
backend so what the system does is
system starts analyzing and starts
checking everything from top till you
know bottom from the start till the end
and I would just talk about the factors
and what impact it brings is so the
quality score the score which has been
given out of 10 is then been given to
every Advertiser on the basis of the
keyword suppose every Advertiser here is
bidding on the same keyword you know
let's let's
um assume that they all are running the
ad for the digital marketing course so
what would happen they would check and
on the basis of the you know factors
they would give a score out of 10.
suppose the a Advertiser who bid it for
the least had the best of the quality
score because of the reasons we'll just
going to talk about B got 8 out of 10 4
out of 10 and 2 out of ten so the one
who have bidded the most for the very
least quality score probably the reasons
you know would be more clear once we
talk so how this allow we're going to
impact the whole position system is that
their Google rank not Google position
okay there is a Google rank kind of uh
kPa can be understood your Matrix which
is a product or a multiplication of what
you bid and how much quality score you
were able to get so 8 into 9 being 72 10
into 8 brings 80 15 into 4 bring 60 and
20 into 2 is 40. okay so the combination
of a good pricing and a good quality
score got B bidder as a first position
okay and the one who got the best
quality score but still paying very less
from the average price in globally is
you know brought the Google position or
add position to Second and then the one
who was spraying very high but the
quality score was below average which is
a Force 5 6 is average price average
score they've got into third position
and the one who was paying so High
probably would not get a position
because this is the maths from the match
point if you have got these numbers if
the quality score would have been below
5 then the ad would not have got any
position rather because Google always
tries to you know show the ads which are
the best uh for the users you know
because Google always pays very
importance to the users behavior and
users um you know expectations so and
when I said that I think you were able
to understand more now how the factors
you know which which actually results in
these quality score is
um like relevant score like buy 11 score
means when you type a query or a person
would come here would type a query so he
doesn't know that this is called a
keyword we as additional marketers know
this is called a keyword for them it is
a normal query because they are about to
start a course where they would be
taught about all these things but right
now they are not very aware you know
very much aware of these things so they
are putting a query when they put the
query they want to see the ad or ad
extensions or a description relevant to
what they have searched and when they
see all these three things here with the
search uh you know what they made they
would definitely going to click more and
Google only earns when somebody clicks
so it means Google making Revenue only
when somebody is clicking so from that
perspective also Google always tries to
pay you know or rather give more score
and give a better position to the ads
where all the components of the ads are
perfect are relevant and the ones who
starts getting more clicks in the very
first hour or first day okay so the
important factor which after the click
is the landing page so when somebody
opens this so it has to be very relevant
to this query and do whatever being
shown outside they cannot just show
anything here which is not relevant to
the ad which has actually been shown
outside so all these you know factors in
combination gives the quality score very
important factor is CTR which you must
have understood when you know we I I did
you know explain the last session the
basic one but if you do not aware of it
so CTR is called click through rate okay
and a click through rate is a ratio of
clicks to impression
okay it is a ratio of clicks to
impression
just a spell check okay so suppose today
when we are saying ABCD so let's see
these are this is the a or this is B and
this is C and I've got you know
equivalent quality score on the basis of
all what they have done okay their
landing page their ad their description
everything is very much common so Google
in the starting of the day you know when
the ad actually started to show for
everyone uh you know giving them a very
good quality score probably of five okay
and when this quality score of 5 been
given to them then the other factor
which actually adds on you know to that
algorithm is the CTR so CTR is I just
told you is the ratio between click to
impression so now they all have a same
quality score but this got 100 clicks
out of the Thousand Impressions been
given today this got 50 clicks out of
the Thousand Impressions given today
this got by any mean probably 200 clicks
out of the Thousand Impressions given
today okay every time this this search
is happening here digital marketing
course so these
ads are very much visible equally so all
got thousand Impressions thousand
Impressions thousand Impressions but
this got 100 clicks this got 50 clicks
and this got 200 Clicks in the very
first hour or maybe in the next two
hours okay so this CTR you know when we
are talking about 100 out of 1000 to 10
percent This Is 50 out of thousand it
means this is going to be five percent
and 20 uh sorry 200 out of 1000 means
twenty percent of the CTR so Google was
actually benefited or made the most of
the revenue and you know clicks have
come from here because it is almost like
a double or a four times of this so
because of the high CTR the quality
score of a force you know every every
Advertiser would improve but this one
would be improved from probably from
five to seven and this would you know
probably from 5 to 5.5 and that's
probably from five to six so because of
that quality score has improved and uh
you know because of the high CTR this ad
has got so this position will be changed
and this would you know probably would
get the first page on the second
position and at the end of a day this ad
has to pay or Advertiser has to pay
lesser because it's quality score
increase we have just seen it is you
know almost like the uh you know
inversely proportional the ones who are
actually paying or the ones who are
having the best of the quality score are
paying the least one has to pay the
least okay so this is all basically you
know can be checked once your ad starts
running so I will just open the client's
account uh where you can just see this
with
you know a bit better
understanding you would able to get out
of this I mean hopefully I am able to
show you from okay I'll just see because
I have multiple
advertisers you know
but I cannot just show for all so let me
just check if I can show you how many of
the older one
just wait it is actually asking you some
verification
it's taking too much time
yeah it's just done now
so once this is done
so I'll just take you to one of the
accounts where
my main focus will just show you how the
quality score report look like and then
you know you will get a fair idea about
all the factors you have to be focusing
to bring your quality score high or to
take your qualities for high
okay
so I'm just going to open the search ads
because we're talking about a search ad
here only and suppose if I just go into
this
Campaign which is of course you know not
running right now but I just want to
show you how you check the report and
all suppose this is the campaign you
have run for and you got 75 clicks at uh
you know
um app with CPC price of 40 peso and you
have just given this much pricing and I
have made it for many keywords but I
want to see which keyword had got the
best of the quality score and how the
qualities have been given and all okay
so once you reach to the keyword report
here you know at this level then you see
um uh you know uh the kpis or metrics
here which gives the quality score out
of 10. okay you can see here very well
and every keyword being given another
you know if there are 10 keywords I
don't know how many keywords for we've
bidded 50 keywords okay and you know you
can see all the keywords here and every
keyword being given the quality score
out of 10 okay because their CTR which
was the last part which I've explained
you the ratio between the impression two
clicks got the above average so they
give below average average number above
average so above average is best
actually for any of the factors so the
CTR is above average the landing pages
above average and their ad is above
average means all are perfect then they
got the 10. the moment anything goes
below average or probably to the average
suppose you can see this is above
average for them this is above average
for them but they're landing page
experience from this keyword point of
view is only average their quality score
has come to eight okay if you go further
down uh let's see anything where two of
them yeah so here the kids ride on is a
keyword where CTR is also not as high or
as great you know to as compared to the
other keywords which we have seen and
also the landing page is not as relevant
to the keyword so there are two factors
like CT and landing page has come to
average as compared to the Android 11s
which is above average so their whole
quality score got impacted which
actually came down from 10 to 8 and then
seven for this particular keyword and
last not TC if I just take you to
somewhere where
something is below average has come now
one is above average
one is okay they are getting clicks but
probably the ad is still not very much
relevant to the keyword okay so they are
below average above average has brought
the quality score to 6 out of 10 which
certainly would have you know impacted
on the cost and also to be positioned
okay so this is something which you
would see
when you come here also you can check
one more thing here suppose you have
bidded for your keyword and your bid
price where you are paying for is
maximum bit price let me just see where
that column is
so otherwise I would just add that
column so that you can learn that part
as well
okay
[Music]
just wait okay so this is basically
CPC prizes been given in the average
cost 2.50 is the cost for every click
and we got 249 clicks so got 623 you can
just check the maths it's always good to
cross check so 249 clicks multiplied by
the CPC price which is 2.50 rupee would
give you 6 22.5 which is the cost you
know for the keywords uh you know we
beat it for and the total clicks we have
paid okay and the
maximum beta price suppose you know you
have got uh the maximum bit price of uh
one rupee and you paid 17 PESA 1.66 and
all and then what happens you wanna
secure your position suppose the very
first page bid you're seeing that you're
getting the position but you're not
getting the first page then here because
this campaign is not running so I'm just
giving you the hypothetical example so
whatever the pricing you would have
given for the particular keyword suppose
we talked about these three keywords
right now or particular one keyword uh I
suppose so this is something which I am
you know trying to show on a one rupee
cost but to show on the first page it is
saying that you have to pay 1.5 okay to
show on the uh first four positions here
one two three four it is saying that
probably you have to pay 2.5 and to get
the absolute first position which is
going to be the top most it would tell
you that you have to probably pay five
rupees you know you paying one it is
asking 1.5 the first four it can be paid
for 2.53 or this has to be five so you
can always go and change your you know
bid price for the particular keyword
okay so there are ways to do it suppose
if I'll just go here and I just go to
the edit I can change my maximum CPC bit
price for this particular bid or a
keyword like 25 rupee okay because I'm
not changing for all the keywords so I
have selected that particular keyword
and I have made the change to this
particular keyword to five rupee so if
you know the average price was one and I
was not getting the keyword uh from this
keyword the position secured on the
first page or the first absolute
position and I want because this is the
most important keyword for me then I
would just come here and would check the
pricing okay this says five rupees you
have to pay for the top position so I
will just go here edit and would change
the bid price or a maximum CPC bit price
of this particular keyword you can do
for all you know you have to just of
course you know select all of course but
if you would do for all then it you can
really impact your whole budget okay so
try to go for the keywords where you
really feel like it is required and
always go by the quality score it has
you know it has a very good quality
score so I should be paying or I should
be ready in paying uh the maximum price
which actually Google is asking me to
pay to secure my first absolute position
and certainly that would increase the
chances of clicks and certainly if
clicks are there so conversions can be
expected too okay so this is all from
what I've just taught you as of now now
I will just move to the campaign making
though we have done as I told you last
time but I will try to make it again so
that we can quickly see how the Google
ad search ads or the search Google ad
created okay so if I just go to the
campaign uh My Demo
account so if you just go to the Google
ads account the dashboard and then I
would come to the campaigns
I would just click Plus
new campaign
and whatever the you know
objective is you can always go for
website traffic or without a guidance
because this would have all the settings
inside the same more important part is
what we select next so we select search
campaign because we are making the ad
for the search Network you can always
test for website traffic that would not
make much difference and click continue
I will talk about the conversions and
remarketing in a separate session
altogether so we are not doing the
conversion and remarketing today we are
making a normal search ad with all the
strategies we have just understood and
with adding the extensions to the ad as
well today okay website visit and
suppose my website is just open safety
learns
landing page
so that I can make the ad for
simply additional marketing as a demo ad
of course not a
mean AD
so copying and just putting in here I
have to just put a you know website
domain that's it I don't have to bring
the whole landing page here and then I
can just name it probably November
search ad
and then I will just go and continue
start new
and then I'll just select my bidding
strategy which is going to be clicks
and of course from my Excel I would
learn that okay my bid price which I'm
going to be paying uh you know is
certainly in the range of something like
probably 50 60 and I have just told you
that I bring my price kind of a thing
into this like I always bring like this
and then
let me just delete all the other columns
which are not required
so this is the sheet which I did explain
to you earlier with the index value and
all so my price what is my price like so
I always pay 30 40 extra to the low bit
price so I can you know just get the
formula here like
this Plus
this 30 percent
okay so that is just going to make it 57
so you can just understand 44 plus 13
going to bring 57 and I can just drag it
and now I've got the average suppose
these are the you know keywords which I
have finalized just assuming so these
are the keywords which I have finalized
probably because of x y z factors such
as an index value and all that and I see
that my pricing is varying from 35 to 89
so maximum being 89 so what I would do
keeping that in my head I was going to
give the limit to my bid price and I
don't want to pay anything extra or more
than 90. okay so this is something which
you can do on this particular level
and then you move ahead and you remove
this because you just want to keep your
ad on the Google search and then you go
down you select your countries you
select your location if you want to show
the ad in all the locations then you
certainly can just go and keep the very
first option open which is all countries
and territories if you want to just show
your ad
um
in a particular country like you know
right now if I just go India so the
whole India would see your ad and if you
want to go for a manual locations like
suppose I want to select any of the
states or cities then what I would do I
would just probably take daily so Delhi
would be targeted like this okay or
probably I just want to Target the state
of Texas here so I just would go and
Target the whole state or if I want to
Target any of the provinces of Canada so
I would just go and take the uh
provinces of Ontario Canada and I would
just Target the whole Province and now
if I also want to go for any of the uh
PIN codes suppose I want to Target to a
certain pin code then I can just go and
Target the PIN codes like this so it is
up to us that we want to go worldwide or
if you want to go for a country specific
if you want to go for us State specific
or if you want to go as a province or a
pin code specific okay otherwise if you
suppose
um a restaurant or if you are a you know
somebody who only delivers into certain
radius then you can just leave all these
options and you can go and advance
search
and then you can go to radius and you
can just bring this whatever you
understand better in India we understand
kilometers better maybe the person us
would understand miles better so we just
go and take that two kilometer radius
and probably I am the cake shop in Delhi
so I'm just going to search my location
this is my location and now we're just
going to Target people around 2
kilometer because I don't deliver
outside two kilometers so it's all up to
us how we're gonna go uh this is called
radius targeting or geofencing when we
go to the locations we can also learn
one thing suppose I want to show the ad
to the
um whole country India I have targeted
at the same time I am not delivering in
um uh in in in Mumbai okay or probably
in Karnataka you know Bengaluru where
the city is okay or probably I'm not
delivering in any of the uh northern
states like haryana Himachal Punjab so
what I would do I would just take Punjab
suppose for example and I'm just going
to exclude that okay so what would
happen now my ad would show in all these
states and all the cities of India but
just not in Punjab okay so I can save it
that's how you go about the location
language is you know in which language
the users will uses the search engine
and all so you can keep it all languages
that's the best and
audience we don't cater here much
because we are doing the search ad which
actually shows the ad on the basis of
keywords and location only so in the
display ad we're going to talk about
this uh one and that would be the next
video I would create so we're going to
learn a lot of things from the audience
segment in the next display ad and then
the more settings comes where you talk
about the add rotation so add rotation
is already default being selected as the
perform best ad uh if because the
nowadays the ad actually been created a
responsive and dynamic so when we'll
reach to the ad level I'll show you the
headline changes for every user the
description sometimes changes for the
user what I mean is if Sachin is
selecting or you know writing this
keyword so probably this headline is
shown to be and after one hour if I'll
come again and put search the same term
so the headline from the same Advertiser
could be different or the description
could be different so that's how these
anime cards works like okay so once you
are done with this okay the start and
date is important and you know the
basics from the previous chapter so I'm
just going a bit faster in here so you
would select the date and
then if you want to schedule this
campaign for a certain period like
suppose you don't want to run on the
weekends so you can just select Monday
to Fridays and you know our timing
whichever suits you suppose just like a
very common time of 8 AM to uh you know
the late nights like 23 45 and you don't
want to run the weekends if you want uh
Saturday Sunday to be you know 24 hours
then you don't have to put any timing so
that goes like 24 hours for Saturday
Sundays and then you click next and you
reach to the next level
where it will just going to ask you for
certain things like keywords you want to
submit and the ad you want to run for
and the ad copy you know you have to
create okay so once you come here it is
the you know work you have done so you
can just copy paste them and you know
bring in there and otherwise these all
keywords are the ones which Google has
suggested you from you know the page
which you have submitted okay so the
landing page is this so I'll try to
change the landing page first so that I
can get more appropriate keywords and
then it would mean to search again on a
scan again for us update keyword
suggestions of course we can always
click on and now the keywords would be
more digital marketing oriented because
this landing page will be scanned by
Google and this would show a certain
results which would of course going to
be digital marketing oriented but why we
don't just uh you know use them because
we don't know uh what is the pricing of
these keywords what is the competition
of this keywords is how much the monthly
search has been so we go by our own
maths we we calculate we do all this
free homework on the Keyword Planner
sheet just like we did today and then we
bring them here by deleting all what
they have actually submitted or
suggested us okay and once this is done
then we ensure that our keyword uh uh
you know in the headlines and everything
been used how that copy is created I'll
just show uh you some you know strategic
part of it ensure that your landing page
is correct and it is opening there you
know otherwise your ad would not be
approved secondly always give a display
path display path is something which is
added after the ad or the landing page
link suppose I'm selling online
digital marketing so I would just going
to write whatever I want to show
okay
probably I'll just keep it here
okay so that works okay so now it has
computational marketing and then the
part comes where you know you have to be
you know
I'm just going to tell you the call
extension once the art is created so
headlines and all so the headline is
something which shows
you know you know the basics so I'll be
fast again
under the landing page link this blue
which actually uh you know brings the
most of the engagement or which actually
appeals the user to click it is
something in blue which is you know
going to be the headline so we have to
be focusing very much on bringing the
best of the headlines here so that we
can get the best of the clicks because
you know once the click increases the
CTR increases CTR increases the quality
Square would increase quality Square
would increase your costing would come
down and your position would rise so you
have to ensure that your headlines your
clicks everything is in you know in a
line whatever we have learned so your
headlines right now has been given these
of course they are not very relevant so
we're going to just bring the headlines
which we feel like are more relevant to
the ad we are showing okay and
I'm just going to get the headlines as a
suggestion been given okay and
we can have more ideas from here by
clicking this so they are not giving any
so we can always have from the keywords
which we have submitted so probably
digital marketing course online
try to get your best keywords here
this is okay
this is nice this can be changed
digital
marketing course
online is not taking so it's Marketing
Online probably I'll just stay because
course I already submitted and then I
can take few more like social media
marketing I just seen
or whatever the length it would accept
I'll take otherwise I'll delete the rest
this is the one and I should ensure that
I have at least 10 headlines or 12
headlines so six been given and headline
section actually you know been given egg
a half blue and then I would see
headlines which are unique so unique you
should have um uh you know online
availability benefits and the offers and
all or call to action so enroll
register
today
or free
demo
then we will talk about
you can see the moment I've added the
headline this the strength has changed
100 plus
tools for free
job
assistance
program
okay so I'm just adding few random
things I'm just not paying much
attention but yeah of course we would
have seen these headlines in any of the
editing companies ads uh include some
popular keywords popular keywords could
be your brand name as well so simply
learn
courses online
of hopefully the spelling is fine and
we can batch for
professionals
oh
[Music]
um
just a batch for professionals
and that's it you know because I already
added a lot of keywords a lot of red
lines probably they win so I would just
not work on the headlines anymore uh
I'll see you know if deception doesn't
takes it high then I'll just add one
more but right now the description is
also not giving me the full uh tick like
in the headline unique and the headlines
been given so I'll just try to bring the
description so simply an online to do
online that's great that's great so just
try to get something from Google itself
let's see what they have given so I'll
just going to bring this one
okay so that it is being taken from the
landing page itself so that would make a
difference to
uh the quality score simple digital
marketing courses focus on so we're just
going to put
our courses focus on skills
to focus on
else like success
so we're doing this one here so then
has been picked up so now you can see
this has also been picked up and the
last thing I would do is now going to
bring some headline uh again you know
I'll just check probably
uh digital marketing
notification I'm not sure if this
headline I have submitted earlier or not
but I'm just going to test it out okay
so
you should
yeah
training
so now it has you know come down to good
and uh that's the best you know right
now we can do of course you can take it
further but yeah that doesn't
matter if you are just stopping it to
get this one completed you have to just
ensure that all the keywords all of the
headlines are relevant just do not
overdo 10 to 12 are okay okay once this
is done your ad is created you can just
click done and you can click next
and then your budget so we just
discussed about the budget when I was
explaining we'll just take you back so
because you know that your average CPC
price would be around 80 you know
whatever the pricing you have just got
from here if you know the sheet and I
was explaining you so the the bit price
which you have submitted for you know
when I told you is like something which
is in this range uh like 80 90 whatever
it is so you know that bit price would
come down to 90 and you need
um at least 100 clicks today so 90 into
102 mqp you are 9000 daily budget so
because you know that you know you would
end up in paying maximum 90 rupees per
click because that's the maximum bit
price you have submitted if that comes
down to 70 80 60 then of course your
clicks would increase but right now
though being very uh you know hypothetic
hypothetically thinking that okay I
would pay 90 rupees per click at Max
because that is what I submitted so to
get 100 clicks I have to pay 90 into 100
which would be 9 000 your you know
delivers it has to be so we would have
come here and you were just going to
change it set a custom budget and you
were going to bring down 9000 Rupees
here okay so on that yeah I have a CPC
whatever it would be you would get the
number of clicks if you have a CPC goes
down from 90 to 45 then of course you
are not going to get only 100 you'd
rather get double amount which is going
to be 200 okay once that is done then
you just click next and your budget goes
uh you know your campaign goes for a
review
and then you can add the extensions from
outside okay so they're just giving you
some of the uh you know kind of uh
suggestions so let's see uh there is one
issue in the ad
let me just check that first
let me just see
you can always fix it
with that food again you're not going to
give you the option of publishing you
know till you fix it but it is not
clickable or not no
uh what is the problem
I'll just go away from here you know
sometimes those links doesn't work so
let's see what is the issue
one point I'm going to use
okay so because just to do that the
get the limit part I have not given the
space so that is something which is not
acceptable by them
I'm just going to put like skills like
this and
now so these all small things you know
they do
take care of so here only because you
have come down so why not you know just
to see the extension here itself because
that would I'm going to save our efforts
by going from outside so when you see
the ad you see some extensions here like
you know when you have created the ad
right now so you have created on detail
this limit okay this is the elements you
have put it up right now the landing
page the headline the description but in
this ad by emirators you can see more
links like applied to IMS learn how
industry so one is landing page and
three different uh Pages or a sub pages
also been shown in this same ad how they
are done so they are done through the
extension called site link okay so you
can see here if you go down after the
headline there's an option to have the
site links here okay so you can just
click Plus
here itself you know I'm not submitting
the ad because I wanted just to show you
from here itself and then you can go
down because in your case these would
not be given because mine are already
created yours or not so you would go
down and you would create the new South
new site link from here and you can just
give a name suppose download
brochure
and then you can give a URL of that
download brochure page right now I'm
using this URL and I'm just going to be
adding my own made page
like this like this has to be the
landing page which is workable for the
downloading version of course so this
would be added and then I can just go
and probably add
um
testy nails
and reviews
okay so somebody wants to read the you
know testimons and reviews of when they
see the ad so you can see that on the
desktop how that would look like so they
would have an ad and then they would
have these four links and all which you
have just seen in the Google when I show
new so final URL of reviews can be given
which should directly take them to the
page where the reviews being given and
site 2 could be anything you know which
can just see
um industry ready modules or the fee
structure you know the fee structure is
something which people always wants to
just know
from the uh very first glimpse of the r
itself so I can just maybe
take them to the page where V is
actually been you know talked about and
the last could be uh maybe tools
provided
the tools and
certificates
you would get so that can also be one of
the links which people would very much
interested in you know clicking and
checking okay so you would see the the
ad in certain shape you would have a
normal headline uh the description which
you have put it up and then four links
where people can directly reach okay and
then you know this had to be saved here
and you can always see the preview which
I've already shown you but yeah this is
how that would look like so you add
your ad and your four
extra links which actually been added
okay so this is one which you can apply
now
and now your ad has the extensions in
addition to that you might have seen
somewhere that you know your ad as the
number as well sometimes you see the
number being given here because right
now it is not showing any of the ads
with the number but the you know uh
generally have when advertisers have now
raised the numbers in addition to the
headline and everything okay so you can
add that as well by just going up and
you can see there is an option of calls
okay okay let me you can add from here
uh certainly I can show you wow you know
you can just go down and add the number
by clicking your
country and you know giving your number
here it will just be cross checked by
some verification and all so that is
done you can save it so you can see what
actually I was showing you you know I
would just show you
um from outside also that if by any of
the uh you know
um that is done that we have corrected
so you don't have to be you know
uh worried about so if I just click done
so that should not be there if it is
still there I have to check now which
spacing it is actually talking about
um
actually I have unacceptable spacing
contains comma and I think I have just
corrected it but it is not taking maybe
I have to just
um
delete the whole description probably
that would something which
and I would say about time
so we're not adding that description
though
just click done so this is actually you
know kind of a bug because that is
something which has been deleted rather
in front of you so this is not um
taking but I will just click next and
probably this would now be not the error
in which we would see
so you go for a review so what I was
saying I did shown you from outside the
you know the the campaign was created
from the ad itself how the site link is
connected and how the uh call been added
for now the publish campaign you can see
because that ad error actually been
rectified so if by mistake you know you
just forgotten that you have to add the
call number or extension you know which
we just added so what you don't have to
be worried because once you back to the
dashboard you know where you would see
all your campaigns certainly you would
see your this campaign as well in which
you had just created then you can just
go inside the
um add group and then
you can see there is ADD and assets
let me just click that
so there is an ad which you just created
and there's an assets
you know where you could see the
extensions and not like you know you
just have added today now we just added
this site link and this number so if I
want to add again or if I would have
forgotten then what I can do I can just
go and take from here suppose if that
call extension was not added there you
know when I just added you would come
here in the assets you would click that
plus button
and then you would just go to the call
and you would see the same kind of a
preview which you have seen inside the
ad when we were creating okay nothing
different it's just like the you know
where you do it you know either you do
when the ad was created or otherwise you
can just go uh let the campaign be
created published and you can come from
outside you can click the add an assets
you can go to plus and you can create
any of these extensions I will talk
about more in the coming you know
tutorials and demos uh and the sessions
but today you know we'll wind up here I
just uh you know wanted to give you the
thorough learning on the Google search
ad with the extensions and also the main
uh agenda for today was to make you
understand how these you know terms
works like and how the keywords can be
researched how you can bring your own
pricing to the keywords how can you save
the cost and of course to understand how
the quality score works like you can
have a lot of videos on a YouTube where
you can find the quality score of Google
ads working do I try to you know bring
everything under this session but still
if you want to go for a deep learning
you can always search more and research
more ready to get started click click
the link in the description box and
embark on your journey to the
professional growth and achievement
hurry up spots are filling up fast
identify it assign a category action
enter label set up that tag and Trigger
once you do that once you test that it's
working this is where you're gonna go to
analyze the data let's start out with
why GTM so let's just say you're Sam and
you have your own e-commerce website you
want to understand how people are
interacting with your website well Sam
today's world of websites contain a lot
of interactivity everything from videos
to PDF downloads to commenting to form
submissions uh to all sorts of chat
functionality interactivity going on
throughout the website so there's just a
lot that you need to track outside of
just page views and so really what GTM
does is they help you you track all
these things I just mentioned everything
from somebody clicking on the play
button of a PDF to somebody clicking on
the submit button of a form to somebody
entering in something on a chat function
so that's what GTM is so why GTM because
it helps us track all that interactivity
so all GTM is is really allows you to
really place a piece of java code which
is just script and this script that's
added to a web page to collect
information so that's really what a tag
is it's just some script that gets put
on a web page in order for you to
collect information like page views
clicks Etc and they send it to
third-party tools okay so that's what
GTM does it basically allows you to take
all these tags that collect information
and you can use them in GTM so if you
want to for example collect how many
people you know and enter a chat
functionality and start chatting well
you're going to take that script and
you're going to put it in GTM and GTM
will then allow you to start tracking
that information so that's really what
GTM is it just allows you to put tags
into a container or think of it as a toy
box you have all these toys and you want
to track well you can put all those
those toys or tags in a toy box or
container we're going to talk a little
bit more about that but before we get
into GTM let's just say you know you're
communicating with your developer and
there's a new user request on your web
page and you want to update the tag well
your developer considering it's probably
a small update your website is probably
gonna not
um hesitate and is going to go ahead and
turn around and do it normally and so
normally what happens is the developer
is going to go to the website and update
the tag well what if you have a few
things that you want to track all all
these things I mentioned before from
downloads to clicks to you know somebody
checking out to watching a video well
your Web Master your web developer is
going to go well hold on a second now
all these requests are going to take
time I need to put them into the work
queue so to speak well what happens is
when they go into work queue usually
it's going to take some time and in some
cases you as a marketer need to launch a
campaign and you want to get that
tracking added to the website in time
for the campaign launch so you want to
go ahead and quickly turn around the
tracking for that particular campaign
let's just say you're launching a
campaign and you're sending people to a
landing page that has a form submission
and you want to be able to track how
many people click on the submit button
of that form submission well if you need
to turn that around your developer's
like well I need to put that in a work
queue the timing isn't going to always
work out between you and your developer
is my point and so that's where GTM
comes in because there is is a solution
update your tags faster and that's
Google tag manager so when we say GTM
that's what GTM stands for Google tag
manager it's a place for you to add tags
quickly and easily so tags remember are
just Snippets of code that allow you to
track things on your website
interactively interactive actively and
basically when you have GTM you can
bypass the webmaster and do it quickly
and easily so that's what GTM is all
about so why GTM because we just
identified two benefits one you could
track all the interactivity on your
website and two you can bypass your web
developer or webmaster and so that's the
benefit of GTM so the benefit you get
those tags updated very quickly via
Google tag manager okay so that's what
tag manager is so what we're going to
talk about today is specifically what
tag manager is and what it does we're
going to list some of the benefits of
tag manager we're going to show you how
it works and then we're going to show
you how to get started with tag manager
tag manager if you're not familiar with
working with webmasters and dealing with
JavaScript and tags and all this jargon
is just new to you today okay well don't
fret sit back we're gonna take it slow
this is an introduction into Google tag
manager again let's start out with what
is tag manager so we've already
introduced it to some degree because we
already introduces a tool where you can
put all your tags into a toolbox toy box
or container so to speak right and we
already already mentioned that hey you
can bypass your webmaster so you're
probably thinking well if I'm if you're
not familiar with tag manager how can I
bypass my webmaster well first of all
it's a free tool and it's a Google tool
hence the name Google tag manager and it
helps you really that's the main point
it's deploy and track tags on your
website bypassing your webmaster so that
that's tag manager and so examples of
tags that can be deployed via Google tag
manager are numerous these are just some
examples like Google analytics
Facebook's pixel tracking or Google ads
There's No Limit into the number of
texts you can track and tag manager
there is no limit you can add any number
of tracking tags and tag manager okay so
some of the benefits well again I we
just listed two you can put any tag into
tag manager and track that onto your
website and we know you can bypass your
web developer or webmaster and what it
also does is it also allows you to test
and deploy your JavaScript codes quicker
so remember these JavaScript codes or
Snippets of codes are just there to
track certain things on your website
whether that be a page view or somebody
clicking on a play button or tracking
somebody who converts or even just goes
to your website so the biggest benefit
is you can take that snippet of code
let's just say Facebook let's just say
you're doing Facebook marketing and you
want to put that Facebook pixel on your
website so that you could track people
who come from Facebook and convert well
you don't need to put that Facebook
pixel on your website you can go right
to tag manager and you can put that
snippet of code right in tag manager
really quickly and the other benefit
here is all tags are managed in one
place and that's that to me is really a
good benefit because when you start
adding tags on your website and you have
some tags and tag manager it just gets
very confusing so ideally all the
tracking codes you have on your website
needs to be in tag manager think about
that all the tracking so if you're doing
Bing or you're doing Facebook or you're
doing Twitter or you're doing LinkedIn
and you're doing Google you're doing all
this type of marketing on all these
different platforms you're going to have
tracking code for all these different
platforms and instead of putting all
that code on your website return gonna
slow down the slow time of your web page
and website you want to put them all in
tag manager so they can be organized and
you know exactly what you're trying to
track and the other great benefit of tag
manager is there's a versioning control
so let's just say you have added tags to
your website via GTM for the last six
months well and let's just say you add
another tag yesterday if you added that
tag yesterday and something doesn't work
well you can just roll back to a
previous version It's that simple so you
have versioning and that's that's a good
thing when you have versioning you can
control what gets published and if
something doesn't work after it gets
published then you can roll back to a
previous version so it's a a peace of
mind so to speak just because you've had
coached your site there's no guarantee
it's going to work and so you can always
control what version you're dealing with
in tag manager and we'll talk a little
bit more about that so the biggest
benefit here to me with tag manager is
you have event tracking and so we talked
about some of the things you can track
on your website from videos from play
buttons to somebody clicking on the stop
on the video or pausing it all the way
to somebody again chatting or let's just
say somebody clicking on that purchase
button on your website okay and you want
to track all these different things
these different interactivities and
buttons well event tracking is what
you're going to use to track all those
buttons and to me this is the biggest
benefit of tag manager and I'll show you
some examples as we go along and if we
didn't mention it already I'll mention
it again it is free tag manager is free
there's no limit so once you have tag
manager going you can add as many
tracking codes as you want there's no
limit on the number of tracking codes
you can add to tag manager okay so it's
free and you can use it to its fullest
Advantage okay so it's also high
security meaning that it has different
levels of permissions okay so you can
have uh somebody just go in and look at
the different tags and tracking codes
you have in GTM or you can ask somebody
who is very familiar with tag manager it
can go in and add the tracking code to
tag manager and then publish that
tracking code when it gets added so
those are all the benefits let's talk
about how it works now specifically how
does tag Manager work because you're
like Rob okay again a lot of jargon you
know you you got tags and JavaScript and
and versioning and Publishing and all
this other stuff well I know I'm
throwing a lot at you at once but just
bear with me here okay so let's start
talking about how it actually works so
you have a website okay whatever that
domain is you have a website and there's
chances are on your website you have
some form of interactivity whether that
be a video whether that be a Blog
whether it be a form submission you have
a website with some interactivity and
let's just say you're even thinking
about getting ready to launch some type
of campaign on maybe Google or Facebook
book and you want to drive traffic to
your website fair enough you're joining
the millions of other websites that are
out there that have interactivity that
also Drive traffic to the website so
incomes Google tag manager and so tag
manager is important because again we
know we want to track people coming from
that Facebook campaign or that Google
campaign and interacting with our site
so if you are running Facebook and you
are running Google analytics well guess
what you want to put that tracking code
in tag manager so Google analytics being
a Google product works very nicely with
tag manager Facebook has its own
tracking code and but you still want to
be able to track people who come from
the Facebook campaign to your website so
you're going to get that tracking code
from Facebook and put it in tag manager
that's generally how it works so here
information from your website is shared
with another data source through tag
manager so think about that if I add
Facebook tracking code to tag manager or
let's just say a Google Analytics
tracking code to tag manager tag manager
is the one that's pushing out and doing
all the heavy lifting they're the ones
that are controlling what code gets
fired and what code doesn't so if you're
putting the code in tag manager tag
managers controlling the code think
about it that way and let's show you an
example of what that looks like so here
I am I'm in tag manager I just went to
tag
manager.google.com and here I could see
a list of tags so in our conversation
we're talking about tracking Facebook
and we're talking about tracking Google
analytics well Google analytics is easy
because it's a Google product so here if
I look at all the different tracking
code I have on my website through tag
manager let's just take a look at Google
analytics so if you're going to use Tag
manager you might as well put the Google
analytics code in here so here I can see
I have Google analytics as a tag in tag
manager now for Facebook if I'm running
a Facebook campaign well I can take take
that pixel tracking and put it in GTM as
well and here I could see Facebook pixel
that is that code is added to GTM I just
basically took what Facebook gave me and
put it in the Google tag manager so you
can see I can add Facebook and Google
analytics and again I can't stress it
enough any tracking code from any
platform I can add to Google tag manager
in order to track the behavior from
those sources so let's take a little bit
deeper dive into how tag manager works
so I just showed you an example of how
you could take Facebook and Google
analytics code and put it in the tag
manager but if you're not familiar with
tag manager then how do I do that well
let's talk about the structure and how
tag manager works so when you have a tag
manager account you have a container
remember I mentioned Toy Box earlier you
have a bunch of toys if they're their
code and you're tracking different bits
of code from different platforms like
Facebook think of those as toys and you
have a toy box okay well that's what
this code is and that's what a container
is the code is the code and that's going
to go into the toy box for a container
and so the way tag manager works is you
have tags triggers and variables so if I
take my Facebook tracking code and put
it into a container I need to set up a
tag and a trigger okay so let's take a
look at what that is so first if I go
back to tag manager I'm going to have an
account and if I have an account I'm
going to have a container so here I'm
just going to click on an account with a
container and a container is nothing
more than what website you're adding the
tracking code to okay that's all the
container is we're just letting tag
manager know this is the website we're
adding all this code too so you have
tags triggers and variables that's the
structure of tag manager so tags are
just what it says tags what are we
trying to quote unquote tag well if it's
Google analytics that's easy here I
could see I have Google analytics added
so if I click on Google analytics here's
my tag and if I take a little bit of a
deeper dive there since Google analytics
is a Google product it integrates
already with tag managers it's pretty
easy I can just choose Google analytics
then I'm going to check page view and
that's my tag now every tag needs a
trigger okay so I need to tell tag
manager how or when to fire the Google
analytics tracking code so in this case
I'm going to tell tag manager to fire on
all pages so if I get somebody a visitor
to my website analytics is firing on all
pages so whatever page that visitor
lands on Google analytics is gonna fire
so that's really what it comes down to
is I have a tag and I need to tell tag
manager when to trigger that back that's
really what the structure of tag manager
is it's tags triggers and variables and
variables what we're going to talk about
here in a couple minutes but do you have
a piece of code you're going to go ahead
and put that into tag manager you're
going to tag it and then you're going to
fire that trigger so let's take a look
at another example here if I go back
here you can see Facebook well here's my
Facebook pixel okay that's my tag so
when is it going to fire well it's going
to fire on a specific domain or
subdomain that's basically what we're
doing we're trying to tell GTM when to
fire that particular tag so those are
the three main components a tag okay
which is going to contain the JavaScript
code that you get from say Facebook the
trigger so you're going to go into tag
manager and tell tag manager want to
fire that code that's the trigger and
then you have variables and so variables
are basically a just additional
information that tag manager may need
for your tag and Trigger to work so
that's what a variable is it's there to
get the tag and Trigger to fire so
variables are divided into built-in and
user-defined variables so common used
variables include say page path or page
URL or hostname or click class again
they're there and these examples I just
gave you are there to get your tag and
Trigger to work think about it that way
they're just that's a component and if I
go into tag manager here and here on the
left side I can see variables so
remember I have built-in and user
defined so built-in means that tag
manager already built these for me so in
case I need to get my trigger to work
with my tag I can use a variable so
those are built in and then I have user
defined so these are what I Define these
are what I created and again the
variables are there air to get the tag
and Trigger to work okay so that's the
job of the variable the job of the tag
is to host that JavaScript code okay in
the case of Facebook or analytics that's
where we're putting our code so here if
I click on AdWords remarketing again
it's a Google product so I don't really
need to even deal with code I'm just
going to select Google AdWords for
marketing okay so you could see GTM
integrates nicely with some of the other
Google products but let's just say you
have a Facebook pixel tracking code
you're going to choose custom and you're
going to put the code here so that's
part of the tag and then the trigger
again is there to get the tag to fire so
you're telling GTM when to fire the tag
and the variable is there to help you
make sure that that trigger and that tag
work together so that's how all three
kind of work together you need the tag
to put the code you need the trigger to
tell GTM when to fire the tag and code
and the variables there to help you
define when that tag and Trigger should
work or how it should work so again
review tags are they're just small codes
of JavaScript or tracking pixels on your
website and so tags are allowed to
manage events like scroll tracking
remarketing clicks downloads files play
buttons you name it even clicks on
external links for example let's just
say you have a click uh or a Facebook uh
icon on your site and when somebody
clicks on it they go to Facebook you
want to maybe track that you're going to
create a tag okay the trigger is there
because you need to tell GTM when to
fire that tag so it's a certain
condition whether it's you know fire the
tag if the URL equals facebook.com or
some other condition so the tag cannot
be created until the creation of the
corresponding trigger so tags and
triggers go together you can't just
create a tag and not have a trigger
otherwise your tag will never fire and
then the variable is there again it
stores the information when defining a
trigger or transferring data to tag so a
variable has a variety of data okay so
you pick and choose the variable you
want to use with that trigger okay so
you're making sure that by defining a
variable you're making sure that you're
telling GTM how that trigger should be
fired so let's take a look at another
example here of how all three play
together if I'm in this account I'm in
this container if I look down here I can
see Google optimize that's another
Google product so what I'm doing here is
I just chose Google optimize as my tag
it's already integrated so what does
that mean I don't even need to deal with
any code I'm just going to select
optimize well we have the tag Google
optimize but we need to tell GTM how to
fire that and so here we're going to
tell GTM to fire it on all pages so
that's basically a very simple example
because we're firing it on all pages so
if I want to look at something specific
again Facebook here's my tag here's my
code what's my trigger well my trigger
is it's gonna fire on specific Pages how
do I know that well if I look at the
trigger here I could see the trigger is
a page view but I'm telling it to fire
on this particular hostname so the tag
and Trigger go hand in hand
[Music]
so how to get started with tag manager
so first things first you have to create
that account so you're going to go to
tag manager.google.com or you can do a
search for Google tag manager and you're
going to create your account and then
when you create your account what's
going to happen is you're going to set
up a container and when you set up a
container you have choices so you could
set it up for your website for an app on
iOS or maybe Android or you can even set
it up for amp except an accelerated
mobile page so most people by default
are probably going to set up tag manager
for their website and so when you do
that when you actually select website
what's going to happen is you're going
to get some Google tag manager code in
return and so the whole idea here is
you're going to do a swap what you're
doing is basically you're saying Okay
Google I'm going to take this Google tag
manager code and I'm going to put it on
my website I'm going to put it on every
page in my website so notice tag manager
has two scripts one goes in the head as
high as possible the other goes into the
body tag as high as possible and so what
you're doing is you're making a deal
you're putting this tag manager code on
your website and in return every code
you deal with whether that be Facebook
or analytics or optimize or remarketing
or whatever it is is gonna go in GTM
okay it's gonna go into the Container
you created so you need the tag manager
code on your website in order for tag
manager to work okay so when you add
this code to your website then you're
free to start adding all sorts of tags
to your container but if you don't have
this tracking code on your website then
none of the tags you add to your
container are gonna work so that's the
idea behind the container and then one
thing I wanted to mention on the account
is it's a Google account so when you
create your account then make sure it's
the same account you use with say Google
analytics or some other Google product
that's a good best practice is always
use the same email address when you set
up your account so that it integrates
nicely across all the different
platforms meaning you can go from say
Google analytics right to Google tag
manager in one browser without having to
log out or log in okay so when you
create the account you're going to
create your container if you choose web
then you're going to be asked to place
code on your website and when you place
that code on your website then you are
free to start using tag manager and that
means you're free to start adding tags
so if you want to know more information
about installing Google tag manager then
what I would recommend is visit the
quick start guide website of GTM so
again if you're curious as to where that
code is located in Google tag manager
well when you create an account account
and you create a container that
container is going to have a specific ID
so if I click on that specific ID here's
where I can get my code okay so again
when I'm logged in to tag manager I'm
going to click on workspace but in the
top navigation I'm going to see my
unique GTM ID if I click on that that's
where my code is going to be located and
so again your code needs to go in the
header and there's another script that
needs to go in the body and if you're
not sure how to add the code to your
website well you can always click on the
quick start guide here okay and that'll
take you to a quick start guide page a
reference page related to Google tag
manager so let's talk about creating a
tag so once you get tag manager
installed I'm sure you're excited to get
going and create that first tag so let's
talk about how to create a tag in tag
manager so when you're in tag manager
all all you need to do is basically
you're looking at all your tags if you
click on tag in the left side navigation
you'll see all your tags and there's a
new button there so you just click new
and so basically what you're going to do
is you're going to create your first tag
and so what I would recommend once you
get tag manager installed on your
website I would recommend setting the
first tag up as Google analytics so that
will get you going with tracking page
views on your website when some when
somebody visits your website okay so
ideally that's what you want to do you
want to get Google analytics as your
first tag and tag manager so what I'm
going to do is because analytics is a
Google product it's already integrated
nicely with tag manager so I'm just
going to click on Google analytics it's
going to be a page view that's what I'm
tracking and now I have to set up a
variable and so what it's going to do
it's going to ask me to set a select a
variable and so what you're going to do
is you're going to select new variable
and what you're going to do is you're
actually going to go and add your
tracking ID here that's going to be your
variable so where do I get my tracking
ID and analytics well if I'm in
analytics I'm going to go to admin and
then under property settings I'm going
to see my tracking ID and all you need
to do then is go to tag manager and
paste copy first you got a copy over
that tracking ID then you're going to
get a tag manager I'm going to paste it
and then that's going to create a
variable for you and then when you
create that variable you're going to see
it in the drop down here so I've already
created it and basically that's your tag
with a variable then what are you going
to do you're going to set up a trigger
so see I have some triggers already set
up you're going to see a default trigger
already set up for you and that's going
to be all pages so ideally what you want
to do is you want to select all pages in
order for analytics to fire on all pages
so that's what we're doing we're setting
up a trigger we're basically telling tag
manager hey if I get a visitor to any
page on my website then I want you to
fire Google analytics so that's
basically in summary how to set up your
first tag and my recommendation is your
first tag should be Google analytics and
when you set up analytics you're going
to have to set up a variable for the
tracking ID and so you get the tracking
ID again from admin property settings
copy and paste that tracking ID over
save it you have your variable that
variable is going to be included in with
the tag then your trigger is going to be
all pages and there you go you have your
first tag you have your first variable
you have your first trigger so that's
basically what you want to do and once
you've added that tag once you've added
that trigger then the only thing you
need to do now is basically publish the
tag and so anytime you save a tag you're
going to go ahead and submit it so that
way it gets published so again what
you're going to do is let's take a step
back here you're going to choose new tag
you're going to choose analytics from
the drop down menu you're going to
choose page view then basically you're
going to add your tracking ID so you can
set up the variable and then basically
that's what you need to do okay you're
going to add that tracking ID and then
voila that's your tag with a variable
and then once you've done that then
you're going to click submit so when you
click submit you're basically saying Hey
I want this tag to go live now this tag
and Trigger and once you've done that
then analytics is ready to go and
anytime somebody goes to your website on
any page tag manager is going to fire
Google analytics so the great thing here
is you have something called Google tag
assistant and that's an extension that
works with chrome and so when you've
actually add a tag manager to your site
or or you have analytics running in tag
manager you can confirm if those tags
are firing properly so let's take a look
at how Google tag assistant works okay
so if you just do a search for Google
tag assistant you're going to see here
that it's basically just an extension
that works in Chrome and unfortunately
it only works in Chrome browser it
doesn't work in any other browser so go
ahead and install that extension into
Chrome and when you do that you're going
to see this nice icon here in your
browser and now if you go to any website
and I click on Google tag assistant and
I click on enable Okay so basically I'm
loading Google tag assistant and now
once I refresh the page I can see that
this particular site has Google tag
manager installed and not only does it
have tag manager installed I can see
that it's also has Google analytics
running I have also Google optimized
running and I have Google ads remarking
tag running and tag manager so that's
what tag assistant does it allows you to
see if one tag manager is on the site
and if it is great what other tags are
firing on this particular site so tag
assistance telling me I have these
particular tags firing on that site and
they're firing within tag manager so tag
assistant is a great way to confirm if
one tag manager is on the site and two
what other tags are firing on the site
now another way you could confirm if tag
manager is firing on the site is you can
go into preview mode so even before you
submit and publish your tag and Trigger
you can click on the preview mode so if
I click preview in tag manager so
basically that's going to put me in
preview mode and so what does that mean
well that means that now I'm free to go
to my website and see if those tags are
firing and so let's take a a look at
what that looks like so if I go to the
website and just click refresh then
what's going to happen is tag manager is
going to load in preview mode just as
you see here okay so that's going to
take a second couple seconds to load up
and now what can I see in preview mode I
could see that I have GTM firing but I
also have some other tax fine on this
page remarketing I have Google analytics
I have Google optimize I have some other
tags firing as well and so the preview
mode shows me what tags are firing on
any given page and I can also see what
tags did not fire okay so here I have a
number of tags already in GTM but they
didn't fire on this particular page so
let's just say I clicked on the Donate
Now button I'm still in preview mode so
I'm going to be able to see what tags
fired now I could see I have a couple of
tags that I've fired on this particular
page and then I can see what tags to not
fire on this page okay so that's the
preview mode you can use the preview
mode before you even submit a tag and
Trigger to see if it fires and that's
the great benefit of tag manager so if
you're not sure if something's going to
fire or not then you can always go into
preview mode um and if you are sure it's
gonna fire then you can go ahead and
submit it so you can leave preview mode
and just go ahead and submit that
particular tag and Trigger so here I'm
going to leave preview mode and now once
I'm done and I'm sure the tag is going
to fire and go ahead and submit all my
changes that I've worked on in terms of
setting up tags and triggers so that's
really GTM in a nutshell so I have my
tags okay my tags are just Snippets of
code that I'm going to put in whether
that be Facebook or vet tracking or any
other Google product like optimize or
page view then I have my triggers my
triggers are there to tell G GTM when to
fire that tag and the variables are
there to help those tags and triggers
work together so remember that
particular variable we set up for Google
analytics okay so here it is right here
because we want to tell GTM what
property to specifically fire in Google
analytics so that's why we set up that
variable but there are all sorts of
variables Google tag manager has built
in or variables already created for you
or you can specifically Define a
variable so variables are there to help
the tags and triggers work together so
when you set up a tag you set up a
trigger you use a variable you can
always go into preview mode preview it
by going to the website seeing if it
fires if it fires then voila you can go
ahead and click submit and that will
publish the tag and Trigger and you're
good to go that's pretty much how tag
manager works and again I can't stress
that there is an unlimited number of
tags you can add to tag manager there's
no limit so you got everything from
anything from Google to non-google to
event tracking okay to Facebook to
anything that you want to track you want
to be able to put into tag manager and
again there's versioning that's one of
the great benefits of tag manager so if
I want to go back to an older version I
can simply do that so here you can see
I'm on version 32. that's how tag
manager works and I can't stress that
you know tag manager is there to help
you track interactivity on the site
because if you have a site that's
interactive that has a video that has a
download button let's just say you know
you have all sorts of newsletter
sign-ons Facebook YouTube buttons on
your website just like this website does
and you won't be able to track how many
people click on that particular button
well you're gonna need tag manager and
when you have tag manager you're going
to be able able to track all of these
button clicks and interactivity on your
website with that tag manager it's going
to be hard to do that so that's an
introduction to tag manager today to get
started click the link in the
description box and embark on your
journey to the professional growth and
achievement hurry up spots are filling
up fast and so the first thing you'll
need is a Google account okay so if you
have a Google account if you're able to
get into analytics or Google ads then
you should be able to use that same
email address to get into Data studio
and all you really have to do is just go
to data studio.google.com or you could
just Google data studio and get the link
but if you're using your same email
address you should be able to get into
Data studio and when you're in data
Studio you'll be able to see some
templates at the top that you can work
with when you're setting up a report or
you'll be able to see some existing
reports that you have have either set up
or somebody has shared with you okay so
here if you just click on shared with me
I'll be able to see all the different
reports that have been shared with me in
the past okay so here if I click on
recent I can see all the reports that
have recently opened so let's just take
a sneak peek at one of those reports so
if I open up a report that I actually
created then what I'm going to be able
to do is look at some data over a period
of time just like I would if I was in
Google analytics okay so the great thing
about data Studio here is that it works
just like any Google Drive document
whether it be a Google sheet a Google
doc or a Google slide okay you could
share the document with anybody you
choose to anybody with a Google account
okay or if you just want to share a link
okay you could just click on can view or
edit copy the link and then you can mess
message that person or email that link
to whomever you want to see this report
okay if you want to invite somebody to
edit it or just view it you can
certainly just type in their name or
email address so that's the great thing
right off the bat with data studio is
it's shareable so if multiple people
have added access to the same report
then multiple people can go ahead and
edit that report even at the same time
so that's the great thing about data
Studio we're going to cover a lot of
different benefits to data Studio I
definitely like using data Studio over
analytics and since we're talking about
the comparing the two this in my opinion
replaces if I go to analytics and I go
to say customization and I go to
dashboards this replaces the old
dashboard reports and if you see here at
the top Google's even persuading you to
move over to data Studio because
dashboards and customer parts are very
limited in nature whereas data Studio
not limited at all okay you basically
are creating reports that suits your
needs so just continuing on with some of
the top level okay benefits to data
studio is if we like a report we see we
can easily just make a copy of it so all
I have to do is click on that copy and
I'm just going to copy over everything
over so I'm going to copy the data
sources or I can change the data source
and basically what we mean by data
source is where is Google pulling the
data from now keep in mind and I'll go
over this more specifically with data
Studio you can pull pretty much data
sources from anywhere in any Source
whether that be a spreadsheet a database
another Google product another platform
like Facebook you could certainly pull
it from analytics so you could pull data
from any data source so if you go ahead
and make a copy you just have to make
sure you know what data a source you're
pulling the data from because basically
all this is is a report with dimensions
and metrics and those metrics are data
points associated with that Dimension so
we could certainly refresh data okay
again we can get the report link just by
clicking on the report link and copying
it it's a bit of a shortener here I can
go ahead and schedule an email delivery
so if I want to go ahead and have this
report sent to somebody I can certainly
do that here and I can have it sent to
them either daily weekly or monthly and
then you can also download the reports
if you download the report okay I can
choose all pages or select specific
pages so in this report I have two pages
set up now in data Studio you can have
as many pages as you want okay so here I
could choose just one page okay some
additional options
um I can add a link back to the report I
can password protect the report okay I
can ignore the custom background color
if I wanted to I'm just going to go
ahead and download that and I'm going to
download it in PDF and so when it
downloads I'm going to be able to then
you know view this report or send it off
in PDF format and so those are some of
just the top level features that you
have available to you in data studio now
let's take a step back okay this is if
you're just viewing the report and you
want to share it or download it or send
a link to somebody what if you actually
want to create one so that's what I'm
going to walk through here I'm going to
go ahead and create one now remember we
can just go ahead and copy this if we
like it we can copy it we can choose
certainly choose different sources of
data so I'm going to go ahead and just
play around and choose different sources
of data I don't know exactly what those
sources are but I'm going to go ahead
and choose them anyway then I'm going to
go ahead copy that report so I copied it
and basically what it's going to give me
is a duplicate of that report except the
data is going to be different because as
I'm choosing different data sources okay
so now here we can see the report and
it's going to load up and it's going to
load up with different data sources now
if I don't see any data that means the
data sources I chose don't have any data
that align with those specific metrics
and dimensions and that's exactly what I
see here so what I'm going to have to do
is go ahead and choose different data
source so let me select a different data
source here I'm going to go ahead and
choose that one or I can go ahead and
create a new data source so let me just
do that so I'm going to click create new
data source and now if I don't want to
use one that I've used in the past I can
go ahead and choose from all these
different data sources available to me
so there's no limit on what we could
connect so you see bigquery SQL okay you
can see data from Google's marketing
platform display video 360. Google
analytics Google Sheets Google search
console okay keep scrolling down
basically what data Studio does is
partner with third-party products like
super metrics for example so that's
super metrics is the intermediary plot
program that pulls in for example
Facebook ads or Google my business pulls
it into Data studio for you here you can
see Adobe analytics okay you have all
sorts of connectors that you can connect
to so I could choose any one of these to
connect it now if I choose one let's say
super metrics I'm going to need that
super metrics account now if you choose
any one of these direct Google
connectors like I'm going to choose
Google analytics then you don't need a
third-party intermediary like super
metrics you can go ahead and based on
the login that you have set up or that
you're using to log into Data Studio
you're going to be able to see all the
other Google analytics accounts you have
access to so I'm just going to go ahead
and choose an account here I'm going to
choose a property and I'm going to
choose my view then I'm going to click
connect okay so that's how you basically
will connect a new data source now when
you actually connect that data source
what's going to happen is data studio is
going to give you the option and it's
going to give you an option to make
changes to all the dimensions available
dimensions are in green if I keep
scrolling down I can have the
opportunity to change any of the metrics
metrics in blue and I can change it to
the type of metric I'm getting whether
it be just a numeric or currency a
percent okay or I can change it to
aggregate Auto I can change it the
description of it okay that's making
changes to something I can even just
delete it or remove it or I can go ahead
and add my own metric or Dimension okay
just by clicking on add in a field and
so here I'm going to go ahead and choose
some available fields or put in my own
formula so this is kind of that first
step when you create your Source or your
second step if you will your first is
actually choosing the source in this
case we chose Google analytics the
second step is having the opportunity to
change out or edit or add dimensions and
metrics now if you're a novice or
beginner to data Studio then I would say
let's skip this step if you're not
comfortable editing or adding dimensions
and metrics and go ahead and just skip
it and click on this blue call to action
add to report okay so I'm going to add
it to the report and now that it's been
added now I'm still seeing no data why
am I seeing that area so if you copy
report you don't see any data chances
are it probably has a filter because I
copied it and here you can see I have a
filter so I'm just going to go ahead and
remove the filter and voila I see data
so that's something you need to be aware
of when you actually copy over an
existing report you have to choose the
data source but keep in mind when you
copy over an existing report you're also
copying over filters and segments so if
you're familiar with Google analytics
you know that in Google analytics if I
go back into analytics here and let's
just say I go to
acquisition and I go to
all traffic and I go to channels what do
I have the opportunity to do in these
standard reports well I have an
opportunity to add a segment I also have
an opportunity to add a table filter
you could do the same thing in data
Studio okay because I copied the report
basically I copied over all of those
filters table filters and segments that
go along with it and so you just need to
be cognizant of that as you're building
out this report now that's if I copied
it so you can see I copied it and
everything else that goes along with it
the the color scheme the the logo Etc
now this is if you not familiar data
Studio it's good to copy report play
around with it Etc that's probably what
I would recommend so again if you're not
familiar with day Studio you want to get
comfortable then go ahead and she even
choose one of the templates if you don't
have access to an existing report so
let's go ahead and just choose I'm going
to say one of these templates that data
Studio has provided okay you can see
looks pretty good layout looks pretty
clean I got all my important metrics in
here what's going to happen is if I want
to use it I'm going to to click use
template now same thing that occurred
when I copied a previous report I'm
gonna have to choose a data source so I
don't want to choose Google analytics
sampling of data or sample set of data
I'm going to choose some actual data so
I'm going to have to go in and choose an
existing I can choose an existing data
source here or I can connect to a new
data source okay so let's go ahead and
just choose one of these data sources I
already have access to and I'm going to
go ahead and copy this template so it
works in the the same way as if I copied
an existing report I'm just copying a
template okay so here you can see I'm
copying the template now okay the only
thing that's missing here is the ability
for me to edit the dimensions and
metrics so if you anytime you add a new
data source you're always going to be
prompted to have the ability to edit
demand mentions and metrics if you don't
if you're not comfortable with that then
just go ahead and add the data source
just like I've done here and so now I
could see basically the same report I
could just see it's just pulling in data
from a different data source that's all
now I'm in edit mode okay so if I want
to view the report just as anybody else
would view it if you gave them a link to
view it I'm going to click on this view
button here and so now I can see I have
some drop downs here and so this drop
down is basically allowing me to choose
my own analytics account if I wanted to
so I can go ahead and just choose any
one of these if I wanted to change the
data here I get another pull down and
this is my date range selector so I can
change the date range if I wanted to so
if I change the date range then the data
is going to change now if I want to edit
anything here in this report I'm going
to have to go back and click on the edit
mode so just click on the edit button
there and and now I'm going to be able
to go in and edit this existing template
now I've already established a data
source but I can change the data source
if I want to all I have to do is just go
here click on any one of these tables or
metrics and change out the data source
just by clicking on this icon here okay
where it says edit data source so I'm
going to have the ability to make
changes to any of the dimensions and
metrics or I can just get rid of that
data source and choose a new data source
now in data Studio you have the option
to change the layout you have the option
to change the theme so you can go from a
simple theme to say a simply Dark theme
you could change any aspect of the
report if you want to so just know that
anytime you click on any of the data
points you have the same options
available you have a chance to edit the
data or you have a chance to style it so
when we talk about styling you know you
can basically add labels you can hide
labels you can compact the numbers you
can style it any way you want based on
the particular table and so that's the
great thing about data studio is really
really customized to what you need so
for example here what are the top
countries by sessions well I don't have
to show Legend if I don't want so I'm
just going to get rid of the legend I
could change the font okay I can change
the color scheme on it I can go ahead
and do a lot of different things here so
once I've made changes after I view it
I'll be able to see those changes in
full effect okay so just know that in
data Studio whatever report you're
looking at that you have added access to
you have the ability to make changes to
anything in that report now here you can
see I see a lot of different data great
what I can actually do too is add a page
and so let let's go ahead and click on
add a page and now we have two pages to
our report and now I have a blank canvas
on page two so now what do I want to put
on page two well the best practice to me
is organizing your data okay so just
like in analytics analytics organizes
their data between audience acquisition
behavior and inversions as a best
practice that's probably what I would do
here maybe stick all your mobile on page
or your acquisition on one page all your
maybe your organic search on one page
now it's okay to have a summary page
just like we have on page one but if
you're gonna have multiple Pages then
perhaps think about organizing it based
on the multiple pages that you add so
here let's go to page two blank canvas
so the great thing about data Studio
again it's just very easy to start
populating okay so I'm gonna go ahead
and click add a chart okay what type of
chart do I want to add well and the
spirit of visualization you probably
always want to choose something visual
start with an easy pie chart here I'm
going to go ahead and select pie chart
and I'm going to place it to where I
want okay no I can go ahead and increase
the size if I want to make it smaller
make it bigger
Etc voila I have a pie chart now if I
want to edit this pie chart again I have
my options available I have my data and
I have my style so I know it's pulling
from this data source here okay I want
to change my Dimension Dimension is what
we're measuring so let's just maybe
change it to source and maybe I want to
go from page views to let's just say
goal conversions so I can just go in and
start typing in the metric and here I
can see gold conversion rate let's
choose that okay now I can see Source by
go conversion rate now if I don't want
Source let's change that back to default
Channel grouping so now my Dimension is
the Fault Channel grouping by goal
conversion rate so now if I'm looking at
my data I can see that referral has a
51.8 percent gold conversion rate
followed up by organic search with 19.5
okay so again it's very easy to edit the
data points on any chart now if I want
to style it I'm just going to click on
style here I can go with a single color
Dimension values okay I can slice it up
in different colors I could choose a
background color I can add a border
customization is really endless here I
can change it from 10 to say 12 slices
if it's available maybe go down to the
top three it's as easy as it gets I mean
it really is fairly intuitive to use you
just gotta learn what dimensions and
metrics you want to use now I have my
pie chart the great thing about data
studio just like PowerPoint for example
I can go ahead and just copy this this
pie chart command C then command V and
voila I now have a copy of it okay well
maybe I don't want to pie chart so let
me go ahead and change one so I can go
ahead my upper right here and go from
say a pie chart to let's just say a
trend line if it makes sense or maybe a
combo chart so I have my sessions along
my goal conversion rate now I can again
go ahead and change that I don't want
sessions maybe I want you know go
completions or something so let's go
ahead and add that in there go
completions so now I can see go
completions and then go conversion rate
by my default Channel grouping so again
I could style it you know if I don't
want red bars I can go ahead and choose
a different bar okay it's really that
simple now if you find you're running
out of real estate okay you can always
scroll down and change the height so if
I change it for 1200 to fall to 1800
pixels I can get more real estate state
to work with likewise on the width so
now I can make it really wide to work
with now when you make those changes to
the page you're probably going to see
the same effect happen on page one in
fact you will so back to page two okay
so if we go to page two here what we
could do is go ahead and add more charts
or we can copy and paste existing charts
and go ahead and change them up okay
just by command C and command V now what
you want to do if you create more pages
here is maybe add in your date range so
if I go click on my date range symbol
here I'm just going to drag and drop
that enlarge it a bit now I can make a
default date range I can say I want to
show data for this month so anytime
somebody goes to the page the data that
shows is going to be for the month the
month to date now again if you want to
customize it what you can do is you can
just copy and paste so Ctrl C or command
C go back to page two command V so this
gives you the ability to just start
customizing now the one drawback to data
Studio being a little bit nitpicky is in
PowerPoint if you're copying from slide
to slide it tends to paste it in the
same exact location I know it sounds a
little bit nitpicky but in data studio
and you copy and paste something it
doesn't necessarily always paste it the
exact location so I've noticed that uh
being the issue but it's a small issue
nonetheless so you have the ability to
copy an existing report you have the
ability to go ahead and choose an
existing template and like I said going
back to data Studio you have the ability
to just start with a blank canvas so
again just walking you through the steps
here blank report brand new canvas I
need to choose a data source so you can
see existing data sources if you don't
have existing data sources to choose
from you can always just click create
new data source okay when you create new
data source you're going to choose from
a list if you're new to data Studio
start with something easy like Google
analytics if you choose Google Sheets
then great you're going to be asked to
look for data in Google Sheets likewise
with Google ads if you choose Google ads
you're going to have to choose a Google
ads account so start easy start with
Google analytics okay I'm going to
choose analytics I'm going to choose my
account my property I'm going to choose
my view I'm going to go ahead and
connect because this is a new data
source I have the ability to go ahead
and edit my existing dimensions and
metrics if I want I don't have to then
I'm going to go ahead and click ads
report it's going to confirm the
connection to the data source now I have
my connection to my data source I am
free to start doing what I need to do to
the report whether that be get somebody
else involved immediately by sharing it
with them go ahead and start adding
pages and organizing it you know adding
my date range adding a logo adding a
logo simply just clicking on image
selecting my file where my images it's
the best practice anytime you create a
table I would go ahead and put a text
box above it maybe put a title so you
could say channel in this case Channel
by conversion rate okay so let's make
that a little bit bigger as a best
practice that's what I would do now it's
you free to do whatever you wanted data
Studio the whole point of data studio is
really to customize the report any way
you want and what I mean by customize is
adding the dimensions and metrics that
are important to you and so data Studio
gives you the opportunity to copy an
existing report or again you can use
existing template or start with a blank
report the options are all there for you
data state is fairly easy to use again
you could share it okay you can download
it you can schedule emails you you could
send a link to people okay there's
really no limit to what you can do with
data Studio okay again you can rearrange
things add pages organize them add
filters add segments I mean basically
anything you can do in analytics you can
do in data Studio a lot more features my
recommendation to get started you know
go ahead and choose that blank canvas
and just start playing just start
playing by adding Sharps okay once you
add Charts okay the data is going to
populate and again you're just then free
to start playing around with dimensions
and metrics so that's the way to get
started with data Studio practice makes
perfect once you get more comfortable
then you're gonna have full fledged
reports to work from just like I use for
my clients there's no limit on what you
can do and what you can see and again
customization makes your report look
good obviously the data and improved
data is going to make your report look
good as well so keep all those things in
mind apply some of the best practices
but more importantly play around get
comfortable and then eventually you're
going to start using data Studio as your
main source of data over Google
analytics day to get started click the
link in the description box and embark
on your journey to the professional
growth and achievement hurry up spots
are filling up fast welcome to sim
s YouTube channel and in today's video
we are going to be talking about
Facebook advertising
we're going to talk about how businesses
use Facebook advertising how the what
are the benefits they can get from it
we're going to show you with a demo on
how to set up your Facebook advertising
and we will close today's session with a
few do's and don'ts of Facebook
advertising but before we go into that
make sure that if you like today's video
or if you like the simply learned
Channel don't forget to subscribe to the
channel below and if you like the video
feel free to like it and share it with
your friends so let's get started
today's world has changed dramatically
when it comes to reaching your audiences
fact is that everybody is trying to get
the attention of the million of
prospects out there in the market
everybody is screaming try my product
try my product or try my product but
most businesses they now have to realize
that today's customer has changed yeah
today's customer is looking for instant
gratification they want a product now
wherever they are whatever their device
that they're using yeah and they can
prop they can Source their products from
everywhere in the world yeah but it is
your challenge to make sure that when
they are in the buying mode that you are
there to help them it's a new economy
out there it's a service driven economy
look at products like Uber or an Airbnb
where a whole new ecosystem has
developed of people offering their
products their services to a global
audience in marketing terms we're using
a term called solomo standing for social
local and mobile
yeah when you bring those three elements
together of social media local marketing
and mobile marketing you stand a really
good chance to connect with your
customers at the right time
Google has summarized this in what we
call Google moments on average people
have a couple of hundred moments during
a day where they grab their mobile phone
to do a search on their mobile phone
they maybe want to buy something they
want to book something they want to
share something they want to learn
something all those little moments or
opportunities for you to connect with
your customer or your prospect and
that's your opportunity but that's also
your challenge to make sure that you are
there
when your customers are having those
moments when they scream I want your
products and there are plenty of
channels that you can use to reach those
customers yeah we know about social
media we know about your website there's
things like influencer marketing there's
email marketing and there's more and
more competition out there that are
trying to use those channels to reach
your audience but fact is there is one
channel that really stands out of all
these channels and that is pay-per-click
advertising
pay-per-click advertising is a well
established part of what we call the
digital marketing Trifecta and this
Trifecta consists the word triceps of
three components owned paid and earned
yes so the owned is your own website or
your own social media profiles in your
social media pages
but owned is no longer enough you need
to supplement your own media with paid
media and this is what we call
pay-per-click advertising
and then the third element of the
digital marketing Trifecta is what we
call earned media and earned media is
where you can still use that powerful
um effects of public relations in an
online world or where you can work with
influencers to help you develop your
online presence and connect with your
audiences
but one of the best ways to start
getting to your audiences is to use
advertising
yeah and there are various platforms for
advertising there is
um Google yeah there is Google search
advertising Google display advertising
and there is Facebook advertising now to
put these two in the context Google did
about 210 billion dollars of Revenue in
advertising in 2021 Facebook is about
half of that 115 billion dollars in 2021
and the most powerful models for
advertising are search ads and display
ads yeah so with search ads is in the
Google search which is what Google the
offers the display ads and video ads are
offered by Google and by Facebook
and we call this pay per click
advertising which means you're not
paying for showing your ad but you're
paying when people click on your ads
okay so let's have a look between over
to this advertising in a bit more detail
you have Facebook advertising was
introduced on around 2007.
yeah so
um in 2007 it was launched by Facebook
yep so but it has grown drastically
since then in 2011 ads were being shown
in the news feed yeah Google a Facebook
called it sponsored stories in 2012 ads
came on the mobile yeah mobile ads are
now considered the most powerful
um forms of pay-per-click advertising in
2014 a Facebook introduced a three-level
advertising structure which was very
much introduced by Google as well where
you have campaigns you have ad sets and
you have your ads and when you go in
setup and you'll see that later your
your ads in Facebook you will have to go
through these three ad elements
campaigns ad sets and ads to set up your
advertising on Facebook
in 2016 in 26 sorry in 2016 Facebook
introduced chat Bots and ads in
messenger which became a whole new area
for advertising for Facebook yeah
connecting with
um customers on Facebook messenger and
offering that for advertising as well
and in 2018 there was a whole range of
AD formats available on Facebook from
videos stories messenger Carousel
slideshows collections so a whole range
of ads to choose from when you start
your face setting up your Facebook ads
now what is the future yeah what does
the future hold for Facebook advertising
as you may have read
um that both Facebook and Google are
having a lower Revenue in their
advertising given the whole world
economic uh situation we're slowly
moving towards a a recession even yeah
Facebook and Google and Microsoft all
the big Tech players are feeling the
impact in that yes so that is one
Element now one of the other reasons why
Facebook's Revenue has gone down in
advertising HD tracking capabilities and
a lot of businesses they track people
when they visit their website and then
you can Target them with ads we call
this retargeting in marketing terms now
Apple has announced
um earlier this year that on iOS people
can say which is on the iPhone people
can decide to not being tracked yep so
that has put a whole sort of kind of a
um a a a
a
different set of Dynamics in Facebook
advertising on the iPhone and it is not
as effective as it was before that
announcement from um from Apple
so the future of advertising is all
about security it's about privacy and of
course in the end it all comes down to
how good are your ads how what is the
quality of the content in your ads are
you able to stand out from the crowd
yeah so those are the big challenges in
Facebook advertising now you have to be
aware that Facebook advertising is
completely different than Google search
advertising
you have to put it into a context Google
search advertising is what we call
intent based yeah so when I have a
question or I'm looking for something or
I need a plumber I go to Google Search
yeah and I search for plumber near me
and Google will give me some ads with
plumbers near me
that is not the way Facebook advertising
Works Facebook advertising yeah is not
intent based it is basically it is your
challenge when you advertise on Facebook
is to stop the user from browsing and
click on your ads so it's more
interruptive you need to make sure that
they stop what they're doing which is
much more difficult
yeah so you'll see that Facebook is
therefore slightly more challenging to
actually generate leads yeah to get new
customers
Google advertising is much better for
that but Facebook advertising is much
better to reach a global audience very
targeted yeah and work on awareness
developing your proposition helping your
prospects to go through the buying cycle
yeah so Facebook ads they help spread
product and brand awareness in a news
feed or on Instagram or on messenger to
a very specific targeted audience
now another element which is important
to understand when it comes to Facebook
advertising is to do with Organic reach
when I have a Facebook post and I do oh
sorry when I have a Facebook page and I
do a post on my page the people that
will like my that have liked my page
will see my post on their news feed
that's how the theory
is
yeah of course not everybody will see
those posts because that wouldn't work
because then you would get way too much
advertising in your feed yeah so
Facebook is very selective in the number
of posts from advertising from
businesses or sorry from businesses that
will show on your news feed
yeah and in fact that percentage of
people that will see your post your
business posts on their personal news
feed is less than three percent so again
if you have a Facebook page let's say
with 10 000 followers and you do a post
on your Facebook page less than 300
people will see your post
now businesses are not happy with that
yeah they said hey Facebook why are you
doing that I want to reach my entire
audience and Facebook says well hey you
still can yeah but it's going to cost
you some money
and Facebook says you have to go and
advertise on Facebook to reach your
audiences so businesses Now understand
that Facebook is what we call pay to
play
you to reach your audiences you have to
supplement your organic reach with
advertising
and the beauty about Facebook
advertising is that it is a fantastic
way to reach your target audience
and that is the biggest benefit that
Facebook advertising can give you it's
all about the targeting there is so many
targeting options in Facebook and I'll
show you when we go into the short demo
on how to set up your ads so what are
the reasons why businesses go into
Facebook yeah what are the reasons what
are the benefits that they will get from
it and the first big benefit that they
get is that they get access to an
audience which is out there
yeah and it is not just a small audience
we're talking about Facebook at as of
today as close to 3 billion active
monthly users that is a massive numbers
and most of these people they check
their profiles at least once daily so it
is a huge audience to reach and there is
no better social media Network to reach
a global audience than on Facebook
yeah so that is one of the reasons why
you want to start advertising on
Facebook the second reason why you want
to start advertising on Facebook is that
Facebook gives you a fantastic platform
to advertise your products to People
based on their demographics based on
their interests based on their location
based on their
um their history of browsing based on so
many different segmentation factors
which means that you can make sure that
your ads reach the Right audience
which is a really good benefit that you
will get from Facebook advertising
the next benefit that you get from
Facebook advertising is that it is very
cost effective
yeah you can just start with a small
budget you can slowly increase your
budget you can relate your budget to the
returns that you're getting from it so
it helps you spend less and achieve more
it is one of the advertising platforms
with the highest return on investment of
your on your money so very cost
effective to advertise on Facebook
here are some other reasons why
businesses use advertising on Facebook
it really helps them with increasing
brand awareness as I said earlier the
difference with Google search
advertising Facebook is not intent based
people are not searching in Facebook
looking for Content which could include
your ads they are actually browsing on
Facebook and it is your challenge yeah
to
um to be creative enough to make them
stop browsing and pay attention to your
ads so it really helps in increasing
brand awareness it's let it's an
opportunity for you to Showcase your
brand and to help them add value to
their lives so by doing that you
establish trust you establish
credibility yeah and you provide recall
value for your brand so it is all about
taking the customer by the hand and
helping them
in going through the buying cycle
yes so when the buying cycle is about
awareness is about building interest
yeah then building that trust that
they've then will turn into buying your
product
the second big benefit that you're
getting from Facebook is to Target
people that have already expressed an
interest in your service we call this
retargeting you may also have heard
about pixel targeting or pixel marketing
it basically means that if somebody
visits your website
yeah you can then retarget those people
with an ads
from a technical element as a
perspective it means that you need to
put Facebook or give you a piece of code
that you need to put on your website
and then as soon as somebody visits that
website that triggers that code it
automatically connects with Facebook and
then Facebook will capture that user
data that you can then use to Target
them with a specific ads
so a big opportunity there for the
retargeting but things will be changing
here in the near future yeah Google has
announced that by 2023 24 it will stop
enabling third parties to leave cookies
on the um on on websites yeah to Target
people so that whole retargeting area
will go and will undergo some big
changes in the near future and then of
course Facebook advertising can really
help you increase Revenue as I said
earlier it is a fantastic way to to
connect with people and take them by the
hand through the buying cycle you can
educate your audiences about what your
product has to offer yeah and the more
people know about your products the more
likely they are prepared to make a
purchase and to share their experiences
so lots of benefits that you get now
let's dive a bit deeper into this and
let's look at the different type of ads
that Facebook has available so first
there is the single image ad
these are single ads single image ads
that have an option uh optional text on
the top and a link description that
links to your website and a call to
action that is very important to have a
good call to action in your ads the ad
images they need to be 1200 by 628
pixels
so that's where you have an opportunity
in the visual to stand out in the news
feed and make people stop and then click
on the link as you see here for instance
sign up
the next ads are the multi-product ads
they are usually carousels so it enables
you allow consumers to see all the
products or the services that you have
available they're very efficient they're
very Visual and they have lots of
creative options
um in them so they're very popular and
they're blocks being being used Lots by
by businesses so that's your
multi-product ads usually via a carousel
then of course you have your video ads
Now video ads are 30 seconds to two
minute ads and they are amongst
Facebook's most engaging most popular
ads they get about 10 to 30 percent more
views than other ads and not only views
also engagement why because people love
to engage with video when you engage
with video you have the opportunity to
touch emotions of people which is much
stronger in building trust building
relationships with your audience
and particularly video on mobile yeah
works really well so it's a high growth
area of video advertising and one area
that you definitely need to look at if
you want to be successful with Facebook
advertising
then you have the lead ads lead ads they
offer slightly different way to
advertise your products they let you get
usernames emails phone numbers actually
without leaving Facebook
yeah and that's what makes them really
powerful within Facebook advertising you
can actually create a sign up form or
you could even drive them through
Messenger and have a communication with
them to get their details through a
chatbot
so people don't leave Facebook you do
the whole process of lead generation and
lead capture within Facebook and it can
be easily synchronized with your
existing CRM system
then you have collection ads collection
ads blend video and product catalog
photos so they are really good if you
want to advertise multiple products at
once yeah if you want to do this so
collection ads work really well
okay so that's a short introduction of
Facebook advertising the benefits that
you get why people would use them why
businesses would use them and the
different type of ads so in the next
section let's go and have a look at how
do you create an ad what are the steps
to create a Facebook ads
so here you see I am on a Facebook page
and this is the page for Riyadh for
Russia which is a hotel in Marrakech and
I am the admin for this page
and what I'm going to show you on this
page is how to access the advertising
platform and how to set up your ads
yes so let me first before I do this
show you what Facebook is trying to do
everywhere whether it's your desktop or
your mobile to make sure that you go
into advertise creation mode yeah so
you'll see it everywhere promote
ad Center create ads create automated
ads boost post wherever you are you will
come to sections like boost post or go
please create an ad on the mobile it's
even more obvious yeah here is the same
page but then on the mobile device and
if I scroll down you see on the first
post immediately boost the post so
you'll see that Facebook is trying
everything to get you to advertise
yep and I think it is a bit annoying
yeah but it's also you need to be aware
that all the various places that
Facebook will try to to hook you into
advertising they lead to various
subsections of the advertising platform
yeah so if I click here on Boost the
post it will take me to a what I call a
quick and dirty boost advertising module
yeah so I say I'm gonna good morning
from our rooftop I'm going to turn that
post into an ad yeah it I can
immediately suicide what goal do I want
for my ad do I want to add a button what
is the URL yeah do I want to edit the
image who is my audience yeah and then
what is the budget what is the duration
where am I going to show these ads and
how am I going to pay Bang Bang
boost post now
yeah so it's looks very interesting and
very effective to do this but what you
see here is you will only get a
subsection of what Facebook advertising
can do for you
yeah and if you think hey if that's okay
with you that's fine but you're missing
90 of the other features to make your
ads as effective as possible
in other words my advice to you would be
don't click on the boost a post button
on your mobile yeah or your desktop
because again it leads you to a limited
functionality of the advertising module
and the advertising capabilities that
Facebook can offer you
so back to the desktop the same applies
here if I click here on Boost post
yeah there's nothing wrong with
advertising for a post you can take one
of your most successful posts or for a
video and you can create additional
reach for that post through advertising
but don't do it through the limited
advertising functionality again this is
a quick and dirty module everything on
one page and it will you can click boost
post now and it's an easy way to start
spending your money yes so that is
if you click the Boost post the same
applies if you go to the
create ads or create automated ads yeah
so let me show you the create automated
ads it takes you through a very
automated process of creating ads which
is great when you're a beginner
but again it'll only give you limited
functionality of what Facebook
advertising has to offer you
so again my advice would be don't go to
the automated ads click on create ads
that again gives you limited
functionality gives it all in one page
again you don't want to do that
yep and then you click on the add Center
that gives you again a summary of the
advertising slightly more tools
yeah but it's all to lure you into spend
money in a very quick way
so then where do I go for my advertising
the place where you go ish to the
Facebook or how they now called meta The
Meta business Suite The Meta business
Suite gives you everything you need for
your advertising it allows you to manage
multiple advertising accounts
yep and it gives you access to the full
functionality of what Facebook has to
offer you so let's go there The Meta
business Suite
oh
so here you see
everything you need for your advertising
yeah so here you see it's your weird for
Russia and it's not only for your
advertising you can manage your posts
here you can schedule your posts manage
your inbox your notification manage your
content manage your shop plan your post
now we'll cover all these areas in
future videos but for now we want to
focus on the advertising again even here
they have ads as a quick and dirty
method to create your ads again where I
want you to go click here on all tools
and now finally this is where you want
to go it gives you access to the full
advertising functionality to create your
ads to manage your ads to manage your
audiences to set up events when you want
to connect get data from your website
and where you can create your forms
this is where you want to go yeah so if
I click here on the ads manager
that takes me to the full advertising
platform
now here you see by the way turn off ad
blocker yeah which is important because
in your creation of your ads Facebook
will obviously
[Music]
simulate your your ads yeah but if you
have your ad blocker on the ads will not
show in the preview so it is important
that you switch off the ad blocker so
you create your browser environment
exactly as users will have in when they
they see your ads so let me go into
switching that off
which is more tools extensions you see
here my ad blocker is on so I'm going to
switch that off
yeah let me do a review
yes so here you have your account
overview you have your uh your desk is
your sort of your dashboard now you see
I haven't run any campaigns yeah so I'm
not gonna so there's not much to see
here in this and this this tool so let's
go here under my campaigns
yeah and this gives me the basic sort of
structure of your advertising on
Facebook
yeah and remember we talked about
campaigns ad sets and ads
yeah those are the three elements of
your
advertising campaign on Facebook you
create a campaign and I'll show you what
you need to set up in the campaigns then
within a campaign you can have multiple
ad sets and those ad sets within a
campaign inherit the settings of the
campaign
and then within ad sets you have ads
yep and Those ads they inherit the
settings of the ad sets and the settings
of the campaign
all right so you see here we have three
or two campaigns or three campaigns
there is a new leads campaign there is a
page likes and there is a traffic
campaign so now I'm not going to show
you these campaigns I'm actually going
to show you how to create a campaign
so let's go into that here is create
if you have experience with advertising
in pay-per-click advertising you will
recognize this approach Google ads has
it as well it is what we call guided
campaign creation
yeah so when you start your Facebook ads
and when you start your Google ads you
can select do you want an awareness
campaign
do you want a traffic engagement Leach
promote your apps or a sales campaign
yeah and basically once the campaign
objective that you select will
set a number of the settings yeah sort
of specifically for that campaign
objective so it makes it easier to align
it with your business goals and the
whole setup will be done easier
yeah so here you see an awareness
objective so that is too good for Rich
for brand awareness for video views yeah
so it's showing the ad to the month to
as many people as possible who are
likely to remember them
traffic is to send people to a
destination like your website this is
really good to get link clicks to get
views from a landing page or get people
get into conversations with people on
Messenger or Whatsapp engagement ads is
get more messages videos views post
engagements it's good for Instagram
first messaging apps good for video
views engagement on posts lead ads or
collect leads for your business or brand
they're good for instant forms on
messenger good for conversions and to
get calls here is to promote your apps
like in app installs app events and here
is sales that is for your catalog sales
for instance
yeah we're going to do a simple one I'm
going to set up a traffic I want to
drive people to a landing page
yeah so here I'm going to click on
traffic yeah and I'm going to click
continue
so now I'm going into the campaign
settings so here you see the three
structures again the new traffic
campaign new traffic ad set new traffic
ads that I'm going to use
okay so here is my traffic campaign I'm
going to create a name which is I'm
going to stick with new traffic campaign
am I going to use any ads are there any
AD categories yeah so is it about
elections is it about politics is it
about employment about social issues
yeah I remember a few years ago there
was this Scandal when there was brexit
and the Trump elections or the in 2018 I
believe it was there was a lot of data
being sold by this Cambridge analytica
that they data they took from Facebook
and they sold it to the campaign teams
of the U.S election and of the brexit
yeah that had a big impact on privacy on
Facebook and on
um advertising for for elections and
politics shown and now Facebook has set
some extra sort of security guidelines
for specific ad categories
now what are the campaign details
here you see by default it is set as an
auction pay-per-click works on an
auction base and this is not a
pay-per-click course but basically it
means you will do a bit on your ad how
much you're prepared to pay for a click
yeah and that will then go into an
auction and that will determine the
position of your ads we want to get more
traffic
do you want to do a b testing yes and we
want Facebook to do that yeah or you
switch that off and what is your budget
do you want to create distribute your
butt set across ad sets yeah if you want
to do that you can switch that on and
then you have your campaign budget so
we're going to set a daily budget of 20
pounds yes so go back to the
phone setting yeah and then what is your
campaign bit strategy I just want the
highest volume and there's more options
you can schedule your ads so you can set
it at specific times my advice is to run
the ads all the time yeah particularly
in the learning phase when Facebook
launches your campaign it goes into
learning mode and then Facebook will see
by itself when your audience will
[Music]
will will respond and they will adjust
the ad scheduling accordingly so there
is your traffic campaign
details then we're going to your traffic
ad set where do you want to drive your
traffic to your website to an app to
messenger we want to drive it to the
website
now Dynamic creative is an important one
yeah do you want to want Facebook to
create your ads or do you want to do it
yourself when you want Facebook to do it
you provide creative elements like
images and headlines and then Facebook
will automatically generate the best ads
for you yeah so I kind of like that yeah
so I always switch that on on here you
see the schedule when do you want to
start
yeah so do you want to send an end as
well so that would be then let's say
November the 22nd and then here is some
more options you can set ad spend limits
and here is where the real meaty
sort of stuff happens in Facebook
advertising this is where you can select
your audience you can save specific
audiences
in the audience manager yeah so you can
have a number of audience if you have an
office in one country or another country
you can just hear select select the
audience for that particular country or
you can just create a new audience
okay so you can exclude audiences you
can set a location you can set the age
location let's look at that if I click
here on edit people living in or
recently in this location
people living people recently people
traveling in this location so this is
really powerful if you want to Target
people who are visiting a uh an event
like a football match or what have you
and you can include and this is where
you can search location you can in
search by City let's say London
yeah so London England or I can say
let's do prisons reading in England
yeah and I can even say uh give me
yeah so I can search location give me uh
rg7 I can do my postcode yeah so I can
actually people doing in the reading
area by postcode and I really like this
so if I say for instance
rg76 yeah so here you can see how you
can Target a specific area yeah and this
is particularly for your local marketing
is very important
yep so that is the uh the local
targeting is really good so you can and
then by the way here you see your
estimated audience size and when your
audience get bigger you see estimated
daily results as well
and then you can do more you can search
by
um where was this you can search by
detailed targeting by demographics by
interests and behaviors yes if I want to
people who like reading
Football Club
yeah so here is the reading FC soccer
team yeah so here are I can now sent an
ad targeting specifically people in that
particular area who lie and we have the
UK as well yeah so uh in reading and
that particular area who like football
they will like Reading Football Club
yeah or I can
um other at other areas as well there's
also the suggestions if people like
reading they may also like these type of
things Neymar soccer or maybe they like
Manchester United yeah so this is just a
tip of the iceberg the whole
segmentation in Facebook advertising and
the targeting is extremely powerful
okay here are your placements for your
Facebook ads best is to let Facebook
decide where to place your ads but to
show you where your ads can be shown on
Facebook if you click on the manual
placements you see here they can show on
Facebook they can show on Instagram on
messenger and on the Audience Network
now what is the Audience Network Google
has said as well yeah in the display ads
which are ads that show on millions of
websites that Facebook has an agree or
that Google or in this case Facebook has
an agreement with so it shows your
Facebook ads outside Facebook
or millions of websites okay so that's
the Audience Network then if you look at
it here is the feeds where your ad can
she can show
your ads can show in stories and reels
your ad can show in stream videos
overlay and post Loop ads on reels on
Facebook search on messaging in article
apps inside so there is tons of places
where your ads can show but the best
thing is to let Facebook decide where
your ads are going to show
okay so these are your ad set settings
so let's now look at the ads
so here you see the Facebook page and in
our case it is the Riyadh for Russia
page
there you go yeah we'll make it you can
opt in for Branded content tools you can
look at the ad setup we can do manual
upload you can get data from your
product catalog and here you specify
what type of AD you want to show is it a
single image or a video or is it a
carousel
yep and then here you have your ads
creative
and your media and the select images
select videos and then here you have
your primary text headline description
your website URL this is where you can
do your url parameters when you want to
track your campaigns
yeah here you see the ad previewed at
preview is off and now it's on yeah but
of course I need to select media
so let's see
find images so here we're going to say
go to my website
and create an image for me approve
yeah so now it will actually show me
some images
select images yeah so here you see
images from my reacts
yeah that it picks up from my react or
from my website here's the website yeah
so let's take uh
let's take this image and we'll say
continue
yeah so
so selected destination link for your
ads let me see where we're going to put
that one
[Music]
there you go yes from now because I put
in the destination link you will see how
the ad start building but this is the
photo that I selected yeah now I'm not
going to show you the details of and I'm
not going to use as an example here I
just want you to show you the fields
where you can play and create your ads
yeah and then you see here in the ad
preview whether you see it in the feeds
there is a mobile preview as well
yep so you see here the feeds you see
here the stories and the reels how they
would look on Instagram the in stream
app and here in the search in article
and on apps
yes so there you have it that is your
traffic ads so we've now done our
campaign we've done our ad set we've
done our traffic ads and then basically
what you're going to do is you're going
to publish your ads
now when you're going to publish
yeah you can then go back to view the
details
and then you see that the ad is
um done and it is actually in review by
Facebook so if I now go back to my
campaigns
yeah let's close this one
you see here is the new traffic ads yeah
and you see here it's processing and
then here you see immediately the
details that you can get from your
campaign yes so you see the processing
you see the ad set name the bit strategy
the budget you see attribution setting
so basically attribution is how you
track the results of your ads
and then you see here the results in
number of Link clicks how many people
reached how many Impressions what is the
cost per result what is the quality
ranking the engagement ranking the
conversion ranking the higher these
rankings the better Facebook considers
your ads and the more and the better the
positions for your ads here you see your
amount spent and here you see the end
date of the campaign
yes so that is how you set up your
Facebook ads as a kind of introduction
to the Facebook advertising
yeah so if I now go back to all my
campaigns
campaigns yeah so you see here let me
see if I have some now you see there's
no none of these ads actually run or did
run in the past yes so I can't show you
the the results but we'll go into more
details at a later
um the later session on on Facebook
advertising for now this is I think the
best overview I can give you yeah and if
you want to get more than details then
we'll go in a more in-depth session of
the Facebook advertising
okay now that is all clear let's look at
the do's and don'ts of Facebook
advertising
what should you do and what shouldn't
you do with your ads
so there are various dues to first of
all make sure you continuously test your
ads
and the good thing is that Facebook will
do this for you yeah you can tell
Facebook please test my ads you can give
Facebook a collection of creative
materials a collection of headlines yeah
and it will actually mix and match those
headlines and it will use the ones that
will give the best
um the best conversions so it's very
important that you continuously look
yeah at your performance and see if
minor changes to your ads will lead to a
better performance
second make sure that your images and
that your videos are engaging remember
there is no intent in Facebook
advertising you have to be very creative
to stand out from the crowd and you can
only do that by making your ads
engagement or them by making your ads
engaging
in images and videos
so the not only the images or the videos
but it's also the messaging that you use
use a message that will stay with your
audience
yeah so it's the combination of the
visuals and the key message of your ad
that will make people stop if by looking
in a split second at your ad yeah they
get it
then they will stop and they will
click on the call to action so make sure
you use a message that is
powerful and effective
also keep it simple or we say kiss keep
it simple and stupid make sure that
people easily understand
the message that you're trying to convey
with your ads don't make it too
complicated don't use complicated
visuals don't use complicated messages
keep it simple
and make sure that you reach the Right
audience
yeah Facebook's biggest benefit is the
targeting you can Target micro or micro
level targeting people in very specific
areas
yeah so that is the dues and of course
there are don'ts as well so the first
thing is be sensible with your budget
don't spend your whole Budget on one
single campaign
yeah so start small and basically grow
your budget based on the results that
you're getting
yeah if you have to use visuals and
messages that are appealing then of
course don't make sure that you put too
much information in the ads again keep
your ads simple don't clutter them with
too much text and too many visuals
make sure that you proofread your ads
don't have typos in your ads there's not
a lot of text in your ad so please make
sure that you double check the quality
of the ads when it comes to the language
and the um the Cramer yeah so don't
forget to proofread your ads
be sensible in the activity level that
you have on your Facebook page yeah up
until a few years ago it was
it was actually promoted by Facebook to
do as many posts as you think are
relevant for your business people did
four or five posts a day nowadays it is
not about the quantity it is about the
quality so don't do too many posts on
your Facebook page be sensible think
from a customer perspective also when it
comes to your ads yeah so too many ads
or showing the same ads to the same
people all the time yeah may have an
adverse result
and then finally make sure that your
image relates to your product so don't
put up an image that doesn't relate to
the advertised product
so here you are the day to get started
click the link in the description box
and embark on your journey to the
professional growth and achievement
hurry up spots are filling up fast
Facebook has many options for e-commerce
you can set up a shop on your Facebook
page and tailor it to your own products
these products can be presented on your
page and you can advertise for them as
well and you can also add a catalog to
your shop which gives you the
opportunity to promote and Target your
product advertising more specifically
setting up your Facebook shop Facebook
allows you to set up shop on your
Facebook page by doing this you can
promote your products on Facebook and
offer prices for your product you can
also add a shop now button once people
click on the products it will take them
to their website where they can place
the order they want to buy directly into
the shopping trolley setting up a
Facebook shop has many advantages you
don't need an existing catalog so you
can add an unlimited number of products
you want to feature in your shop like
any shopping catalog Facebook allows you
to organize your products in collections
so people can easily find the products
they are looking for and by activating
the messaging button people can ask
questions or even place an order
to create your Facebook shop you have to
add a shop tab here on the left side
menu now the way to do that is to go to
the settings and then in the settings
you click on the templates and tabs and
then here you see you currently haven't
got the shop as a tab so you click add
tab
and that's where you have shop so you
simply click add tap and that means your
shop has been added and then you can
drag the shop to a higher level in the
tab menu
and then you can go to the settings of
the shop where you can switch it on and
off and where you can also copy the URL
of the shop but the main settings of the
shop are also within the tab when you
are on your page
so now that we've installed the tab for
shop you now see on your home page of
your Facebook page you will see as the
third item the shop click on the shop
and the first thing obviously you need
to do is to agree to the terms and
conditions for your shop you click
continue and then you're basically going
to set up all the details in your shop
now the first question you need to
answer yourself is how do you want
people to buy the products from your
shop they can either send you a message
to buy you can activate that or you can
drive them to your website for instance
where you have your online shop you can
just get them to the link of that
particular page
so for this demo sake let's click
message to buy and we'll click on
continue you select the currency and
then you click save and you're getting
to the next screen of your shop setup
where you're going to add products and
you can also add the description of what
you sell so when I click here on
describe what simply business sells I
have 200 characters to describe what my
business does so I can just add for
instance for the demo sake social media
training products and services and I
click save changes and then I'm going to
add products so if I click on ADD
product you're going to add visuals for
your product you can add a video of your
product you can add name the price
whether the product is on sale a
description of the product whether you
want to share this product on your
Facebook page you can give the inventory
information they difference options
about your product like sizes and colors
and how you want it to show up on your
page and who do you want to be able to
see the the product so let's add some
products so here we're going to go to
the photos that were dragging from the
the desktop so let's say that is product
one
and we're going to use that this is
social media book and the price is 10
pounds and the description
how to attract
date and love your
customers on social media I'm just going
to leave these as standard options and I
click save and now I have my first
product added
and I can add more products here you see
how the product features in the product
list I can add my next product
and add a photo select the files here
I'm going to product number two
and this is social
media training and we'll say that is 50
pounds description introduction
[Music]
to social media keeping those setting
standards that's product two
and then I'm going to add product three
product three is let's say a LinkedIn
training
and I'm going to say again LinkedIn
training the price is 50 pounds I'm
clicking save and then the fourth
product that I will be adding
this product for and that would be the
Facebook training
and that would be let's say 50 pounds as
well intro
[Music]
duction to
Facebook
and I'm clicking save
yeah if I now do a refresh of the page
you will see that all the products show
up now there is another area where you
can actually put products in different
collections so for instance if I want to
do the Facebook training and the
LinkedIn training in a collection I can
then click here add collection yeah so
these are the products that are
currently in the catalog but if I'm
going to add a collection I'm going to
say training products
yep and then I can add the products to
the collection the one I wanted was
Facebook training and Linkedin training
I've now added two products to this
collection and I can then click save
and if I now go back to my shop
so let's go to the page
and I'll go to the shop you now see that
I have two collections that I can sort
of scan and browse through and I have my
different products
so I can now start promoting my shop
through Facebook advertising or by
sharing particular products from my shop
on my timeline
here you see an example of a Facebook
shop you can see the desktop and the
mobile version of it on the desktop you
can see the shop tab on the left you can
decide what position the shop takes in
the tap listing you can do this in the
settings and you can see the products by
category and also you see the shop now
button and the send message on the
mobile you can show the product specs a
photo the price the details and the link
to the website in the shop setup you can
manage all aspects of running your
Facebook shop you can add products you
can add collections you can get an
overview of the orders and the pending
orders the Facebook shop also allows you
to tag products you can tag up to 30
products and links in your shop you tag
these in your page posts when people see
your product tags in your posts they can
then click on the tag to shop for the
tagged product finally it is important
to connect your Facebook page with a
payment engine you can set up your
payment within your Facebook page so
people can buy your products directly on
your page but this only works in the US
for those shops outside the US you need
to integrate your Facebook shop with
e-commerce platforms like Shopify
fortunately many online store Builders
who have e-commerce engines can
integrate your existing products on
their store with your Facebook page this
means that you can connect your existing
online shop with Facebook and your
existing products will automatically be
uploaded in your new Facebook shop
creating your Facebook catalog to expand
the capabilities of your Facebook shop
you should use or set up a Facebook
catalog consider this catalog as a
folder with all the products you want to
promote and advertise once you've set up
your Facebook catalog you can Target
people with specific product ads based
on their browsing behavior in your shop
for example when somebody clicked on a
specific product in your shop you can
Target them with an ad for that product
the next time they are on Facebook
thank you foreign
you can Target people who visit your
shop or your online shop on your website
through setting up a Facebook catalog
now in order to set up a Facebook
catalog you have to be in the ads
manager and when you click here on the
ads manager you go down on their assets
and that's where you see catalogs
because we've created the catalog when
we set up our shop it will automatically
show up here in your list of catalogs
when you click on the catalog you get to
the screen where you can select
different type of ads that you want to
run for the particular products you can
see what products do we have in our
catalog what product sets do we have in
our catalog and what are the data
sources for the catalog that we're using
and there is the settings for your
catalog as well like what's the name of
your catalog what notification settings
Etc so back to the Diagnostics area of
your catalog this is where you are going
to decide what type of AD you're going
to use for your catalog so you can have
generic ads or you can have Dynamic ads
generic ads is basically where you can
feature an ad for a specific product in
your catalog or when you do a dynamic ad
you can actually retarget people who see
specific products on your website and
they can then receive an ad with that
particular product that they saw on your
website but then on their Facebook just
as a little reminder that may push them
to buy the product so if I click on the
add to drive traffic it will ask you
which accounts do you want to use and
then it takes you to the admin manager
where you go through the standard
process of your campaign settings your
ad account settings your ad set and the
creation of the ad itself now I'm not
going to show you all the details of how
to create an ad we've done that in other
demos but in very important section that
you have here is that you can create an
instant experience
which is a much more multimedia type ad
that you can select within your catalog
for instance you can select which
products do we want to select for the ad
how do you want to order the product
like dynamically or you can even specify
in order Are there specific sort of
collections that you want to use for
this ad whether you want to use a cover
video or recover image and then what is
the call to action button that you want
on your ad
and once you're done with that you're
going back into the ad set creation
where you are looking into the traffic
for the ad and the or the in
segmentation and then you follow the
process of developing your ads
using Facebook Dynamic ads here are a
few more details about the Facebook
Dynamic ads they promote products from
your catalog to people who are more
likely to respond to them because they
have seen that particular product before
in your shop or in your app or they have
shown an interest in the category for
instance if people are browsing hotels
on your website but don't make a
reservation you can then Target them
with specific product ads from your
catalog based on their travel
preferences finally it is important that
you promote your Facebook shop there are
many ways you can do that you can
promote your products by making them
stand out through videos and really good
photography and another effective way of
promoting your shop is by enabling
ratings and reviews often people look at
customer reviews before making a buying
decision and if you have a physical
store it will also help if you add all
your shop details like the address and
the opening times and it goes without
saying that when people message you with
questions or even an order make sure you
respond instantly day to get started
click the link in the description box
and embark on your journey to the
professional growth and achievement
hurry up spots are filling up fast why
is it a good idea well if you haven't
been on YouTube of late you should check
it out youtube.com and just take a look
at the vastness of videos that are on
YouTube now YouTube is a video platform
but if it was a search engine it'd be
the second largest search engine in the
world only behind its parent company
Google so it's a very big platform with
a lot of videos and hence there's some
good search functionality on YouTube so
you can look at it as a search engine
there's 1.9 billion and growing logged
in visitors on a monthly basis so you
have a lot of people that go to YouTube
and watch videos on a daily basis okay
it has local versions and more than 91
countries so if you're an Advertiser
who's focusing on a specific Market or
you're in a different Market with a
different language you have 91 different
options to hone in on okay so a little
bit more about YouTube here and why is
advertising on YouTube a good idea well
most YouTube users are on mobile almost
70 percent almost three quarters of
those that you use YouTube use it from
their mobile device ice which is
staggering but not so staggering
considering most people in the world now
have mobile phones or mobile devices and
most people use their mobile devices for
multiple reasons and watching videos is
one of those reasons so mobile
advertisements receive viewer attention
83 percent of the time so what do we
mean by that well on YouTube we have the
opportunity to get your ad in front of
people who are watching those videos so
if a lot of people are engaged in
watching a video on YouTube and you're
advertising on that particular video
well then you're going to get some
attention and so that attention has to
be in the 80 percentile okay so a lot of
people are going to you know pay
somewhat attention to your ad and it's
their secret video ads have proven to be
more effective and engaging creating
greater impact and and that's just not
on YouTube I mean that's that's on
Facebook that's on other platforms like
Twitter Instagram so video is an
engaging way to communicate it's a lot
better than traditional text it's a lot
better than say a display Banner because
it's engaging people are going to watch
what you have to say and if they like it
they're going to share they're gonna
comment on it they're gonna subscribe
there's a lot of things that people can
do when it comes to video advertising so
video helps expand your digital reach so
basically if you are running those text
ads and display ads well having video
kind of adds some more Arsenal to your
advertising portfolio so to speak so if
you're running just those textiles and
swipe banners that's fine that's great
because you can reach a lot of people
but having video just adds another piece
of the element and because video is so
engaging you might find that even for
yourself if you're advertising different
types of ads video display or text
you'll find that you know video does
have really really expansive reach to a
particular audience and the other thing
here about YouTube is YouTube helps to
find a relevant audience for your ads
using Advanced targeting so just like
anything else that we've talked about
here at simply learn when it comes to
advertising whether that be Facebook or
Instagram or Google ads we can really
hone in on our audience here and that's
really important and we'll get to that
later because when you're advertising
you want to make sure your ad is in
front of the right people and if we're
talking about video and we're talking
about high engagement if you have your
video in front of a really relevant
audience then chances of that audience
engaging are going to be even greater
and then YouTube and video ads
themselves provide a provides a
situation that can be customized to
fulfill your marketing goals and so what
do we mean by that so basically YouTube
allows us some additional features where
we can customize our ads so meaning if
our marketing goal is to just get our ad
in front of millions of people well
that's not a problem if our marketing
goals get people who you know we want to
convert well we can customize our
marketing goal towards that as well so
just like on Facebook and some of these
other platforms we've talked about
YouTube is no different and so we could
set specific marketing goals uh for our
video ads some other good pointers to to
talk about here with YouTube so with
YouTube just like on Google ads we can
enable running cost-effective campaigns
and what do I mean by cost effective
well meaning we can really watch our
budget we can measure how how much it
cost for 1 000 people to watch our video
we can measure how much it costs for
somebody to click on our video ad we can
measure the cost of when somebody clicks
on our video ad and converts how much
does that costing us so you can really
run cost-effective campaigns even on
YouTube and YouTube helps determine how
successful you're at ads with Advanced
analytics so not only do we have
analytics on the YouTube side of the
house but we also have analytics on
Google ads and so we can really hone in
and use both platforms to really figure
out exactly how our ads are performing
and then ads that I've reported a 500
growth in views of the Channel's other
videos so basically you can see growth
in views just by advertising on YouTube
so let's get in now to what are the
types of ads you can run on YouTube so
we discussed all the benefits of YouTube
we can go on for another two or three
hours because there are plenty of
benefits but I think you get the point
of you know YouTube being a place where
you can grow measure and reach a custom
audience so you're already sold on
YouTube now let's talk about those types
of ads you want to run on YouTube so
depending on what goal you want to
achieve with your ads there are
different types of ad for formats
available on YouTube so our first set of
ads evolve around building brand
awareness and app recalls so if you're
in the business of promoting your
product or your brand or your service
then these are the type of ads you want
to run on YouTube building brand
awareness and AD recalls because what it
does is it's really going to get your ad
out there in front of thousands and
millions of people lots of eyeballs lots
of Impressions impressions are the
number of times your ad was seen so add
centered around brand awareness are
really ads that are going to put you out
there in front of a large number of
people with the goal of potentially
attracting new customers and ensuring
your brand is on top of their mind so
top of funnel brand awareness is always
introducing the brand getting people
familiar with the brand and getting them
to your website so that you can
introduce them to your brand and service
and product so that's the whole idea
behind the ads we're going to introduce
behind the goal building brand awareness
and AD recalls so let's take a look at
what those are so we can build brand
awareness and add recalls so we call
these these types of ads true view for
reach okay so when we say true view
meaning our ads go into pair in front of
a video and we want to make sure that
that adds in front of a lot of people so
skippable ads that will enable your
brand to reach as many people in your
target audience as possible at the most
efficient price so the whole idea is
we're trying to build brand awareness
then we could set it up on YouTube so
there are ad appears before other videos
and that's going to ensure that our ad
is going to show up in a lot of places
based on the audience we Target and if
we can get our ad in front of them a lot
of people oh a lot of targeted people at
an efficient price then how can you say
no to that so these ads are skippable
have an open video length and their
bidding is based on cost per 1000
Impressions so cost per 1000 Impressions
CPM means that you're paying YouTube for
every 1 000 people that looked at your
ad okay so that's what cost per 1000
Impressions or CPM means that you're
paying YouTube not when somebody clicks
on your ad but one one thousand
impressions are current an oppression is
when somebody looks at your ad and so
that's what you're going to be paying
YouTube you're going to be paying for 1
000 views or Impressions basically okay
so the ads are skippable but they have
an open video length and it's based on
eyeballs so that's the whole goal there
when it comes to Brand awareness you
want to go with a CPM model that ensures
you're getting your ads in front of lots
of people to accumulate Impressions and
paid by Impressions so this is what the
ad looks like and now we're going to
talk about the type 2 ad that you can
run on YouTube and we call these bumper
ads so they're non-skippable ads with
which you can share your Brand's message
in six seconds to drive reach and impact
so we've all seen these videos before
and I'm going to share an example with
you here when you're on YouTube you
really can't get to that video that you
really want to watch until you watch a
few seconds of that video ad and so
that's what these bumper ads are they
allow you to really make sure that your
ad is in front of that target audience
still it's still pay by Impressions but
you know that your ad is going to run
for a few seconds and the idea behind
that is really you want to get your
message out there and it really does
help to drive reach and impact and so
let's take an ex look at an example on
YouTube of what a bumper ad looks like
so here's an example of a bumper ad on
YouTube again it's only six seconds but
this example is pretty popular on
YouTube it's uh been viewed a lot and
we're just gonna take a quick look at
this video here this video has six
seconds but the whole point is to really
look at the ads purpose and so if we hit
play
[Music]
so that was it that was the ad six
seconds long it appears in in front of
other videos as an advertisement and the
whole point of these bumper ads is
really you have to get your message out
there quickly because the video is going
to start and you want to really make
sure that your message is being
delivered and you want to keep in this
case maybe keep users guessing as to
what it is and so this is why it's a
highly effective ad you know you got a
diver jumping off a diving board into a
pool that is basically drying up over a
period of time and so for curiosity the
old saying is curiosity killed the cat a
lot of people are probably going to
click on that ad to figure out what is
the subject what are we all talking
about here and really the point of the
the video was to bring awareness about
global warming but that's it that's a
six second bumper at example and you
really if you're gonna run bumper ads
you want to make sure that you your
message out there so it has to have
really high impact okay so again they're
non-skippable they have to be of six
seconds and their bidding is based on
again cost per 1000 Impressions so it
gives you an a chance to get that ad out
there in front of a lot of people again
you're paying on a CPM model you're
paying Google for every 1 000
Impressions okay so that's could be 1
000 different eyeballs looking at that
ad so if it's high impact you know if
it's non-skippable then chances are you
can get you know some clicks some some
eyeballs over to your YouTube channel or
to your landing page on your website so
let's take a look at this one from
Alaska Airlines better yeah let's take a
look at this example from Airbnb I found
it to be a little bit more impactful
than the Alaska Air ones so let's take a
look at this example actually so we went
on vacation with a toe different and
left with a cannonballer
okay so high impact ad great ad by
Airbnb really impactful we went on a
vacation kids playing you have your logo
on the bottom right corner of the video
and you know it gets people excited
about travel so similar to the Alaska
Airlines which we didn't look at this
one is just as good high impactful you
know getting people to you know react
within six seconds isn't exactly a very
easy thing to do so you got to make sure
these videos really resonate within the
time frame that you have so let's take a
look at type 3 here so we're talking
about reservation of 15 to 20 seconds so
these particular ads can span up to 20
seconds to increase reach and make a
last impression so unlike the bumper ads
which are six seconds long these
reservation ads tend to run a few
seconds longer up to 20 seconds okay so
they're also non-skippable and like I
said it can be up to 20 seconds
embedding is based on a fixed CPM and
what do we mean by fixed CPM well if
you're bidding on a regular CPM model
meaning that you're paying Google for
every 1000 Impressions that number could
be variable what you pay Google in this
case the fixed CPM is fixed at a certain
rate it could be you know ten dollars
for every one thousand Impressions
twenty dollars it really depends on
where you're advertising and who else is
advertising so let's take a look at some
examples of a reservation ad on YouTube
up to 15 to 20 seconds long so here is
an example of a 15 second ad you know
also called a true view ad so you can
see this ad is going to run for about 15
seconds before the video actually plays
it's non-skippable and so let's just
play this ad
who can paint the corners is known as a
rembrand GMC we get that
everyone loves that kind of precision
this is GMC okay so you could see the ad
itself uh ran a little bit longer than
your traditional or your six second
non-skippable version and the 15 second
you know allows you to get you know more
the message out there still high
impactful but allows us to get the
message out there
um with a little bit longer of a video
and that's non-skippable so it's so
going to run for its entirety up to 15
20 seconds before the video actually
starts playing so let's now turn our
attention to the fourth type of AD you
can run on YouTube and that four type is
an outstream video app and so these ads
are going to reach users wherever
they're watching regardless of the site
or application it's the whole point of
the outstream we want to be able to get
our ads out there regardless of the site
or application okay so these ads are
also non-skippable and they could be 15
to 20 seconds long and their bidding is
based on on viewable cost per 1000
Impressions and so what do we mean by
viewable cost per 1000 Impressions what
we mean by viewable cost per 1000
Impressions is basically if you're
paying for ad Impressions measured as
viewable you you can use this model and
basically what that means that an ad is
counted as viewable when 50 of your ad
shows on screen for one second or longer
or plays continuously for two seconds or
longer so there's some criteria about
the viewable but you're definitely
paying for Impressions you're just
paying when those Impressions showcase
the ad 50 or longer or for one second or
longer for you know other type of video
ads or it plays continuously for two
seconds or longer for video ads so if a
play is in short if it plays for longer
than two seconds then you're going to
pay for that impression and so that's
going to count as an impression and
that's viewable for 1 000 Impressions so
if you get your basically your ad to
show for two seconds or longer then then
that's going to count as an impression
so for example with the viewable CPM for
example if you bid um 1000 viewable
Impressions and you pay for Impressions
that are measured as viewable and add is
counted as viewable again when 50 of
your ad shows on the screen for one
second or longer for display ads and two
seconds or longer for video edits so uh
so that's basically what it's about so
really the key number here with viewable
CPM is two seconds or longer that's the
difference between regular 1000
Impressions CPM and viewable 1000
Impressions vcpm so let's talk about the
next type of AD format you can run on
YouTube and the next one is Masthead and
so Masthead is unique in that basically
they only run for 24 hours okay so and
they run on YouTube's homepage so you
can imagine the amount of reach that you
can have by advertising on YouTube's
homepage so they're highly visible okay
they can run on multiple devices desktop
app mobile and basically these ads sit
at the top of YouTube's homepage so
their fixed cost per day pricing
involved and so the best thing to do is
to contact YouTube if you're interested
in advertising on YouTube's homepage so
that's the Masthead advertising and
basically these ads are non-skippable
they have an open length and again their
bidding is based on fixed price per day
so here's an example of what the
Masthead looks like on the home page so
you can see here this is that GMC ad
okay you can see that they have video
supported with a banner and you know
call call to action out there and so
what YouTube is actually experimenting
with are you know different ways for
advertisers to buy Masthead ads okay so
it's you know these ads are very
prominent so it's it's basically YouTube
is now offering the option uh to buy
Masthead ads on a cost per 1000
impression basis so they're playing
around with that cost format so just
keep in mind that this is a recent
change by YouTube so traditionally it's
cost per day but now they're actually
offering the option for advertisers to
buy a Masthead ad on a CPM basis so just
keep that in mind you do you do have the
option here so at the end of the day if
you're interested in Mouse has ads and
having your ads show up on YouTube's
homepage for 24 hours I would still
contact Google and ask them about hey I
want to pay cost more 1000 Impressions
so YouTube is actually offering up that
option on pricey model so so the second
set of ads we're going to focus in on
are centered around this strategy of
growth consideration and interest and
the whole idea behind growth
consideration and interest is really we
want to get our ads in front of people
who could be potential customers but we
want to influence them okay we want to
influence them at a point in time when
they when we think they're going to be
most receptive to our message so that
really means getting our ad out in front
of the Right audience at the right time
because the message we put out there is
going to be centered around you know
getting them to not only take notice of
our brand potentially take action so
it's moving our audience a little
further down that funnel so really
growth consideration and interest it's
all about placing your ad your message
in front of that potential customer when
you think they're going to be most
receptive to the messaging you're
putting out so that's what growth
consideration and interest is so let's
go back and look at let's talk a little
bit more about those true view ads so
trueview ads are one of the most popular
ways of advertising on YouTube so if
you're interested in you know getting
growth getting leads getting conversions
you might want to think about some true
view ads because basically these ads can
run before during or after videos on
YouTube or you can run them on video
partner sites and applications again if
you're interested in driving not just
brand awareness but you know clicks to
your site so if you're interested in
driving impact for your brand of
products you might want to focus on the
true View and stream ads again these are
the traditional ads you've probably seen
before on YouTube that run before during
or after a video and these ads are
skippable so you're likely to have seen
the skip ad uh call to action button
they have an open video length and
they're video is based on cost per view
so you're paying when somebody views
your ad and so what what's what does
that mean cost per view well let's break
that down cost per view bidding is the
default way to set the amount you'll pay
for a true view video ad so when are you
actually paying well you're paying when
somebody views your video and but
there's a threshold here so a view is
counted on YouTube when someone watches
30 at least 30 seconds of your video ad
or if it's shorter than 30 seconds and
let's just say it's 20 seconds then
that's going to be considered a view so
30 seconds is the number here you need
to be concerned about when you're
running a cost per view model so if you
have a video that's one minute long and
they watch 30 seconds it's considered a
view and that's what you're going to pay
you're going to pay cost per view so
that's what the cost per view model is
and that's the really the default model
with trueview ads whether that be before
the video during the video or after the
video it's it's cost per view so let's
talk about the other type of trueview AD
and that's the true view Discovery and
so basically What trueview discovery is
is your ads are placed in YouTube search
results next to related videos or on the
YouTube homepage so you're getting your
ad discovered more or less you know
throughout YouTube and including the
YouTube homepage so here's an example of
what that looks for looks like and so
let's jump over to YouTube and take a
look at that so if I do type in let's
just say surfing I may scroll down and I
may see some ads I may not see some ads
so basically if you see an ad it's going
to have ADD next to it and so that's
when you know your ad is being
discovered on YouTube and so here in
this example we don't see any ads
showing up here so remember those true
review Discovery ads are going to have
something with the ad next to them that
way you know it's an advertisement and
they're going to be found in the search
results on YouTube's homepage or any
page where you're actually searching
okay third set of AD types center around
driving action and so the whole point of
driving action is getting that potential
customer to actually take action on the
ad that they see so in the case of
videos we're going to have some call to
action stronger call to action to get
these folks over to the website to
purchase or download or you know sign up
for a newsletter or do something you
want them to do in terms of your
business model so if your business model
is selling a product then the whole
point of driving action on your ad is
getting in to buy your product we want
so the whole point of driving action is
making it easier for customers to take
meaningful actions that you can measure
so the ads we're going to introduce are
centered around getting potential
customers to take action okay so that's
what driving action is further down the
funnel and getting folks to react to
your ad so that they can take the action
that's aligned with your business
talking about true view ads now and so
again these ads Discovery can show up on
search results on YouTube's home page uh
you have your traditional in-stream
trueview ads where they show up before
during or after and then here you have
true view for action and so these true
refer action ads are video ads to drive
any action that's important to your
business so again it goes back to that
marketing strategy so the ads we looked
at on early on were about Impressions so
a lot of the cost models for a lot of
the ad types were cost per 1000
Impressions and notice now that you know
it's it's now cost per view for trueview
ads and you want to be on a different
model when your marketing strategy is
more aligned with getting people to take
action that's important to your business
for example shopping or buying something
or getting a quote or or downloading
something so if that's your marketing
goal you want to go with a true view for
Action if that's what's important your
business because these ads are intended
to get users to interact with a
clickable button that leads to your site
so that's the whole idea behind trueview
for Action type ads okay so these are
skippable they have an open video length
and their bidding is based on cost per
acquisition so CPA different cost model
so let's now talk about what CPA is so
the cost per acquisition model is in
this case since we're trying to drive
action we're going to pay when somebody
actually takes that action so somebody
actually does shop and they spend twenty
dollars then basically you're gonna pay
for that acquisition so basically if
it's to download something whatever it
costs for you to get that person over
and they actually download that's what
you're going to pay so cost per
acquisition is really a model based on
action so when somebody actually
performs that action that's when you're
actually going to pay Google so that's
what CPA is and that's what the YouTube
trueview for Action ads are all about
trying to drive action so let's talk
about the universal app campaign for
video and so this is all about driving
action as well so these ads promote your
app on YouTube so where your ads are
more likely to be clicked and your app
downloaded so again targeting an
audience and really it's about you know
getting people to look at your
application your mobile app so that's
what these ads are all about they're
about promoting your mobile app on
YouTube okay so these ads are skippable
okay they haven't open video length Okay
meaning you can make them as long as you
want and again their bidding is cost per
acquisition but you also have some
additional models as well so we already
talked about what cost per acquisition
is because this is a actional based ad
so we want people to do something like
download our app but you also have
another cost model here cost per install
and you only pay when that person who
watches or sees that ad clicks on it and
actually does install the app okay you
also have another model that you can
apply here and that's the return on ad
spend and a return on ad spend basically
is you're asking Google hey I want to
make sure that if I'm going to run this
type of AD I'm getting my return on
investment meaning if I spend a hundred
dollars am I getting a hundred and one
dollars back so that's the return on ad
spend that's a cost per install and a
cost per acquisition so you have three
models here for the univ Verso App
campaign about some important metric for
YouTube so we've thrown around a lot of
different cost models when we talked
about the different types of advertising
you can do on YouTube and so with that
there's a lot of metrics so let's go
through some of these metrics here you
have views clicks you have view rate so
you have all these different types of
metrics and for some of you it could be
confusing so what am I need to look like
look at what do I need to measure so it
really does come down to you know what's
important to your business that's always
first and foremost but here we listed
some of the most common metrics
available to you with YouTube Okay so
let's go through some of these and
basically a view is just it shows the
number of times people watched or
engaged with your video ad so a view
rate is basically the number of views or
engagement your ad receives and the
number times your ad is shown okay so
divided by the number of times your ad
was shown into the number of engagements
so if your ad was shown a hundred times
and you had one like or one click for
example then that would be one percent
so average cost per view is the average
amount you pay whenever your watch is 30
seconds of your video so remember when
you're on a cost per view model remember
30 seconds is the magic number so if
your video is only 25 seconds then
remember that's going to be the view so
it's got to be minimum or maximum 30
seconds if your video is under 30
seconds it's 25 seconds or 20 as an
example then it's still going to count
as a view if it's a minute and somebody
watched at least 30 seconds of it then
that's going to count as a view so just
keep in mind 30 seconds is the magic
number here for the view so somebody
watches at least 30 seconds of your
video or engages with your video that
would be a cost per view so that's the
average amount you're going to pay and
watch time is basically it measured the
total amount of time people watched your
video ads shown in seconds okay so it's
the total amount of time so it gives you
an idea of how many minutes total your
video is run so it's focus on clicks so
clicks is a common metric across the
board it shows the number of times
people actually clicked on your video
not to be confused The View so view is
the number of times your video was
actually watched a click is something
also measurable and it's when somebody
actually clicked on it so it's an
indicator for how well your ads are
doing with those who see it and so you
know we want people to click on our ads
if we're running you know actionable
type video ads if we're running those
action at type ads or Universal app ads
we're going to want people to take
action okay if you're running ads just
for Impressions that's one thing so
clicks is an important metric depending
on the type of video ad you're running
so click the rate is the number of
clicks you you receive from your ad
divided by the number of times the ad
was shown so my ad was shown a hundred
times and I received one click then
that's one percent click-through rate so
let's talk about engagement and
engagement is the number of clicks on
interactive elements such as icons in
your video ad okay so that's what an
engagement is here the number of clicks
on interactive elements and then if we
look at engagement rate then any clicks
on an interactive element that we
receive is going to be divided by the
number of times the out of a show so
that's why we have engagement rate as
well so we want people to engage with
our video is there something that
they're doing on the video if so then
what's the rate at which they're
engaging earned views sets a number of
views who have seen subsequent videos on
your Channel or watch Pages after seeing
your ads so watch Pages or videos on
your channel if you've seen those after
seeing your ad then that's going to be
calling earned view so somebody seen
your ad and was impacted by what they
saw if we look back at the examples
we've shown earlier on with the global
warming or the GMC or the Airbnb ads you
know if I saw those ads and I said man
that's really a cool ad or that's really
a good message I'm going to go over to
that that watch page or I'm going to go
over to that channel and see what other
videos they have when you do that that's
an earned View and then if you can get
an earned view you're probably going to
get an earned subscriber because it's
the number of viewers who subscribe to
your channel after seeing your ad so
again going back to any of the ads that
you've ever seen if you've ever gone
over to their Channel and then subscribe
to the channel that's an earned
subscriber so your video ad is doing
something for you it's in this case it's
getting you a subscriber so let's talk
about how to create a YouTube ad so this
is going to require some access to
Google ads and we'll go over that in a
few minutes here but first we need to
think about setting up a campaign and
setting up a campaign goal okay what's
the goal of our campaign to get eyeballs
you know we want to pay costs for 1000
Impressions or we want to run some
actionable type ads to get people over
to our website so that really is step
one we need to identify what the goal of
our campaign is then we need to create
the ad so we want to be able to create a
video ad here that is going to show on
YouTube and to our target audience so or
whether it be a bumper ad that's only
gonna be six seconds long we need to be
able to figure out what type of AD we
want to run so here I am in Google ads
if we're going to run a campaign on
YouTube we need to make sure that we're
choosing a display campaign and so
remember the first step is you know
setting up that campaign setting up that
campaign goal so we're going to go ahead
and select a new campaign here we're
going to run a new campaign pen and so
what's the goal of our campaign so if
we're just out to generate brand
awareness and reach that's certainly
fine if it's all about sales or if it's
all about leads then you know the type
of video run is going to be a little bit
different so if we select Grant
awareness and reach okay here we're
going to select the campaign type and so
if we select video basically what we're
doing is we're going to tell Google we
want to go ahead and set up some video
ads on YouTube and so here you can see
the different types of video ads we
discussed today you know we got your
bumper ads you got your skippable
in-stream non-skippable so the
difference being that if it's
non-skippable somebody has to watch the
entirety up to 15 seconds okay so we
have our out stream which is basically
our viewable CPM model so we're gonna go
ahead and you know check one of these
types of campaign types or ad types so
we're going to click continue and then
once we do that you know we're going to
get prompted to you know move forward
with selecting our ad so you can see
here after I set up my campaign now I'm
just going to go through some of the
settings for my ad and I'm going to give
it a campaign name a budget okay when it
starts or ends the bidding strategy so
again we're going to focus on cost per
1000 Impressions and then here's the
network so this is an important
selection here so we're dealing with
YouTube videos so we also have the
option to select video Partners on the
Display Network so that means that if
you want your video to show on websites
that want to host ads in video format
then you can select this option here
notice you also have this option
available if you're running certain
types of ads on YouTube we're running
those bumper ads so bumper ads aren't
available on search results so I'm going
to stick with the video Partners okay
YouTube videos and here we can get into
some other specifics like language
country the type of inventory so here
you can see the default is standard
inventory so that means that this is
what Google recommends we want to show
our ads on content that's appropriate
for most ads okay so we can go expanded
or limited so we're going with the
recommended here okay and then when we
go down we're going to have an ad group
so when you create an a campaign you can
have an ad group so with an ad group
that means that we can have a more or
less a video in every ad group we have
but we have to have at least one ad
group so we're going to go ahead and set
up you know this ad group here and
here's where it gets interesting and
important because here is where we can
start targeting our audience so here we
got demographics okay so we can choose
gender age parental status household
income okay we can focus in on audiences
if we want to so we can we can choose a
specific audience that we've set up we
can get some ideas or browse specific
audiences we could also choose a
specific placement so here you have
YouTube videos or we can go with YouTube
specific channels okay or we can even be
on apps okay we have to set a bid for
our Target CPM and once we do that
basically it's all up to now for us to
add our video ad and so remember in this
example we're going to Bumper ads and
we're looking at about six seconds and
once we do that then that's pretty much
the campaign but I just want to stress
here that when you're setting it up
ahead of time you want to make sure you
identify what the campaign goal is and
then that's going to align with the type
of video you're going to run and then
once you choose that type of video then
it just comes down to where you want
that ad to be and who you're targeting
so it's really crucial here that you go
through these steps and these options
very closely so because you want your
video to show in front of the Right
audience on the right placement so let's
talk about how you can optimize your
YouTube ads so once you get your
campaign set up once you select your
Channel or the type of videos where you
want your ad to be and you select your
target audience and you're off and
running with your video ad well we're
going to give you some tips here that
you can focus on for optimizing Those
ads and so going back to what I was just
saying on the setup you want to
carefully Define your metrics and goals
okay so that's step one so when you're
setting up the campaign remember you
have that option to choose the type of
goal for your campaign that can be brand
awareness it could be a sale it could be
a lead so to me that's the you know a
very critical step one so you want to
make sure you align your goal with your
video and then the second is track low
performing ad placements so if we just
ask Google to place our video ads
anywhere they want then it's up to us
then to go through and choose the ad
placements and remove them okay so let
me show you an example of what that
means so if I'm back in Google I'm going
to go to my campaign and I'm going to
select placements and here I could see
placements but then I'm going to select
where my ads show and so this is
important you want to be able to scan
the list of placements where the ad was
shown so if you don't like one of the
placements on YouTube you can always
select it edit it and exclude it from
the campaign or editor so that's really
the key is you want to be able to manage
your placements properly and when we say
low performing ad placements we mean
really what what's your goal if your
goal is to get sales or leads if you're
that placement is not converting sales
or leads then you need to remove or
exclude that placement so it's all done
within the Google ads platform and then
you know you can also use a custom
thumbnail image in your ad as well it's
always helpful in terms of optimization
so a couple of other pointers here to
help you optimize okay you want to drive
people to perform a particular action
with the appropriate CTA so again
depending on the ad type you know if
it's a true view ad 20 seconds long you
want to have a call to action you want
to maybe even have your domain name at
the end of the video so at least
somebody knows where to go so you always
want to have a call to action with your
video ad you want to use negative
targeting specify who gets to see your
ad and who doesn't Okay so that goes
back to your settings so you can pick
and choose who your target audience is
you can pick and choose who you don't
want your audience to be okay as an
other setting you can use closed
captioning in your ads to make it more
interactive so that way people can
actually see or read what the ads all
about just to make it a bit more
interactive okay you can always perform
a B test testing on your ads so if you
have one ad version you can create
another one just to see what it which
one performs better testing is always a
positive okay so if you're paying too
much maybe think about reducing your
bids so if you remember we said a 10 CPM
bid that may be too much maybe we don't
need to pay ten dollars so we can always
reduce our bids at the ad group level so
reduced bids and areas where you see
lower performance so in other words you
don't want to pay a lot for poor
performance you can also use remarketing
to re-engage with customers so if
somebody views your ads and doesn't take
action you can always retarget that
person uh to show your ad another even
another ad format it could be text ads
or display ads but if somebody looked at
your video and they didn't take the
action you preferred them to take then
you can always retarget them with
another ad so that's a good way to
optimize okay so we want to to make sure
the ad has content that what viewers
would find relevant okay that really you
want to make sure that your ad is you
know is with the end viewer you don't
want to put out an ad that isn't going
to give somebody you know a good feeling
after they've watched it okay so you
want to make sure viewers find the
content relevant so if they don't find
it relevant then that means your
engagement rate and your engagement is
probably going to be low so you want to
take a look at those metrics that we
viewed earlier engagement rate
engagement and if they're low then you
probably need to look at the content of
the ad so try to make sure your ad
conveys your Brand's message in the
first six seconds so that's why bumper
ads to me are so critical because you've
got to get the entirety of the ad and
make it impactful and so with any AD you
run any video ad you're on you really
want to make sure that that message is
conveyed at the very beginning early as
possible otherwise is you know people
are going to be turned off or not
engaged and just going to go ahead and
skip it anyway so you want to make sure
you get the purpose of it right up front
and out of the way okay you can also
include Visual and auditory components
in your ad that can make it more
memorable to the viewers okay meaning
music or other cool visuals okay so
again you want to be able to play around
and test different ads and you want to
be able to you know measure the ad
Performance Based on the metrics we
discussed I mean click-through rate
engagement rate all of those are
indicators whether the ad is of good
quality or not with the end user and
when I say good quality I mean do they
find it engaging do they find it
interesting or so they're going to click
and if you don't have good click-through
rates or good engagement rates then you
definitely want to try doing something
different to the ad like adding those
audio components or other visuals that
could be appealing to the end user so go
ahead and and test some of those out
with a B testing because you have
nothing to lose but higher or lower
engagement rates or lower click-through
rates so you want to be able to improve
those metrics improving those metrics
means trying some different components
on different ads so let's take a look at
a case study if you will and let's focus
on super dry so they're a good success
story on YouTube so super dry leaned on
some YouTube advertising to help lift
one of their products so in September
last year 2018 super dry if you're not
familiar with the brand they're you know
centered some Asian markets European
markets and they focus in on clothing
all different styles and sizes and
genders from jackets to jeans to
t-shirts and so they're a global brand
they really wanted to take a different
approach here and their approach was
they wanted to focus in on sales they
wanted to see if video can help lift
them with sales and so what they've done
is they set up some campaigns on YouTube
and their focus here was on jackets and
jackets to specific ages across the
board all genders and interests and so
what they did was they wanted once take
advantage of all the different ad types
that YouTube had to offer and let's take
a look at one of those ads here so if we
go to YouTube and let's just take a look
at this one minute ad here 53 second ad
by super dry I'm ready now super dry
page
this is the jacket the jacket you're
raving the jacket you're waiting the
jacket you're pulling the jacket You'll
Play how I'm posing you'll take five in
this jacket you'll wanna find this
jacket I washed a jacket
3am plates catch your breath not your
death in this jacket it's the jacket
your premium
it's a jacket you're hiding you're
vibing love live and Friday
this is the jacket the jacket that will
get you through
so that's the video that's super dry ran
you could see that you know it was it
had some particular goals there and so
super dry is pretty well known so it
probably wasn't built around brand
awareness per se it was probably growth
consideration and interest and also
driving action okay it's a pretty cool
video it was definitely not a bumper ad
because bumper ads are six seconds so it
was definitely a true view probably take
action and so whatever ads they actually
did run specifically they did see a lift
and so we kept pulse on superdry's
account and these videos actually had
you know 4.8 million views and so cool
video ran for 53 seconds not a long time
not a short time was able to you know
Target Their audience a younger crowd
you noticed in the ad they had different
jackets both female and male different
gender types so they were messaging a
very broad audience of gender some
younger people is who they were
targeting so younger people tend to
slant on YouTube and so they were able
to get some nice views out of it 4.8
million but the more important thing is
because these videos were to drive
action and so they were able to see a
four to one ratio on return on
investment and as a result these jackets
saw a hundred and thirty eight percent
increase in brand lip I mean the jacket
ad so it was a pretty successful
campaign see as well choreographed good
audio good video just well
professionally done and they probably
were able to now get a few more loyal
customers under their belt because of
this at alone so that's the power of
video okay so you're able to know who
your target audience is you can go out
and Target them with a cool video and
given that YouTube is vast then you can
really take advantage of a lot of their
ads so what they probably did again was
those true view in stream ads with a
cost per view through a skippable video
ad format may they also use the
shoppable ad format so that is another
option on YouTube so they took advantage
of all YouTube had to offer in terms of
who they were trying to Target the
length of the ad and given that their
product or selling a product or
promoting a product they will take
advantage of the trueview shoppable ad
format which basically lists your
products alongside the actual video app
and so this is just a good case study
you super dry we'll probably do this
again a based on the numbers that
they're reporting and so basically
that's the power of YouTube getting out
in front of your audience with a really
good video ad targeting an audience
taking advantage of different formats
day to get started click the link in the
description box and embark on your
journey to the professional growth and
achievement how do you up spots are
filling up fast if you think about how
bookmarking has traditionally worked in
the world of the web it's text-based you
know if you use the bookmarks or the
favorites that are built into your
browser you tend to end up with big long
lists and folders of just all sorts of
text links that we really don't go back
and end up using that much later down
the line because a lot of times we don't
take the time to customize those
descriptions and becomes kind of
difficult to remember why we might have
even put them in there in the first
place now with Pinterest on the other
hand because everything has a visual
context to it there's a much higher
level of recall it's much easier to say
you know not just I'm looking for that
corn fritter recipe but here's the
specific corn fritter recipe I'm looking
at because I remember that image behind
it or when you're looking for
inspiration of what you might want to
have as an outdoor project this year or
maybe you're looking for that
infographic that had that data you
needed for your presentation it's much
easier to go back in and find it
visually than it is to go through again
the tradition text-based bookmarks that
most of us are used to working with it's
also a place to go for inspiration and
to gather new ideas not just to save the
ideas that you found other places on the
web but to browse through specific
topics and to spot those little pieces
of information that you say hey this has
value to me I want to save that and
categorize that as well finding
inspiration on those topics that you
enjoy and that you're interested in
to that extent it's made a lot of
changes in the way that we do idea
searching online and in fact we've even
started to see a little bit of changes
in the way Google and Bing start to
present some of their information
because of the influence that we see
Pinterest having on how people search so
if you think about going to Google or
going to Bing and running a search say
for Blackberry coddler
the results that you get back may have a
couple ads here and there they may have
some images but for the most part
they're going to be text-based
descriptions that have maybe the added
credibility of a website you recognize
but you don't really know what you're
going to get on the other end until you
click that link go through to the site
and actually look on it now when you run
that same search on Pinterest you're
instantly getting a visual
representation of the content and if
you're looking for a specific type of
blackberry cobbler becomes a lot easier
to take a look and say oh wow that one
sounds wonderful but you're also reading
curated descriptions that are added by
human beings rather than the metadata or
the relevant content off the page that's
pulled by a search engine algorithm and
plugged into that space now Pinterest
also makes it very easy for you to
refine your searches you can see across
the top maybe you want an easy
blackberry cobbler recipe or maybe you
want a blackberry cobbler recipe with
oats they can take the user data and the
way they the information is saved and
collected within Pinterest and help you
refine those searches further so it also
has a heavy impact again on the way that
people are now doing Discovery for
different ideas and Concepts
so it's important to be able to look at
Pinterest
in sort of the broader context of what
we're used to with social media so if
for example Pinterest is one of the
newer channels to you but maybe you're
familiar with Facebook because Facebook
is sort of the Behemoth of all things
social media having a little bit of side
by side comparison can be a helpful way
to put Pinterest under perspective
so when we look at monthly usage data
for the two sites
the average person spends about seven
hours a month on Facebook and about 90
minutes a month on Pinterest now at its
surface that would seem like people are
way more invested in Facebook than they
are in Pinterest and to an extent that's
true again it has a higher usage rate it
has more frequent visit rate but it's
also important to understand the context
of how we use these two sites because
Facebook is a place that is a
destination rather than a starting point
we go to Facebook to participate in
conversations to see what people are
interested in and talking about and to a
great extent to have that conversation
and engagement on Facebook itself
Pinterest on the other hand is sort of a
strange hybrid of say a search engine
and a social media site because it's a
starting point it's the place that we go
to either build our collection to look
at other people's collections or for
inspiration so we're spending as much
time off-site as we are on site again
the same way that you might go to Google
20 times a day but not spend more than
10 or 15 minutes total during the day on
the site because you're using the site
to get yourself to another location
so where Facebook becomes that place
where you're engaging with your fans
Pinterest is the place where you're
attracting your fans researching them
and what their likes and what their
interests are so again Facebook is a
place where we're going and we're trying
to get people to stay and engage and
interact with us and sort of spread
things around but with Pinterest there's
sort of an understanding that you're
getting a touch point in front of them
and you're getting an interest point in
front of them but ideally they're
finding their way into your site into
your content again it's a launch Point
rather than the actual engagement
location there's still a lot of
misconceptions about the site who uses
it how they use it whether or not it's a
good fit for a particular business or
brand so I want to clear up some of the
misconceptions that a lot of marketers
and a lot of business owners still have
a lot of people still look at Pinterest
as sort of the way it originally
launched which was mostly about women
either planning their wedding or ones
who wish they were still planning their
wedding because suddenly they had all
these great ideas there's a little bit
of designers and Foodies mixed in and
maybe some men you know hiding in the
very very corners and edges of the
Pinterest universe but for the most part
Pinterest was originally all fashion
makeup Beauty food and Home Design now
we've seen a lot of changes in the
demographics over the last couple years
in fact there really is sort of a new
reality and we're seeing a continued
creep towards this new reality
So currently nearly a third of Pinterest
users are actually men 71 percent are
Women 29 are men
that accounts for about 13 of the male
internet population now having a
Pinterest account whereas 42 percent of
female internet users have an account
now when we look a little bit beyond
sort of just the male female demographic
the financial numbers they're pretty
good 64 nearly two-thirds of them make
more than 50 000 a year and a pretty
good percentage of them also make more
than a hundred thousand dollars a year
now one of the areas that Pinterest does
differ from some of the other channels
like Twitter is that it's a very
non-urban environment so if we look at a
channel like Twitter we see a very high
Urban population much higher adoption
rates there but with Pinterest we see a
lot more suburban and even way more
rural than we see on some of the other
channels again it's just a different
demographic that's checking in here so
it becomes a unique place to go and
reach some of the people that you might
have a more difficult type reaching on
some of the other platforms and channels
2014 was really a banner year for men on
Pinterest and we really by the end of
that year saw a lot of very significant
changes they accounted for 33 of all the
new signups coming in and if you go
outside of the United States that's
roughly 50 percent of this signups that
are happening so we saw a 73 percent
year-over-year growth in men registering
for the site I think women will probably
always be the dominant demographic
that's on the site but I think we're
going to continue to see the number of
men increase a little bit more until we
sort of reach a leveling off now an
important thing to note again when you
think about how you're getting in front
of your audience and whether or not it's
a worthwhile place to check out it's
very important to realize more men Now
read Pinterest each month than Sports
Illustrated and GQ combined so again
we're getting really good depth of
insight now when we look at Emerging
Markets Korea India China the numbers
are even better men make up half of all
users not half of sign ups you know not
half of growth it's literally a 50 50
split when we look at some of those
Emerging Markets so if you're doing a
lot of international marketing or if
you're primarily focused in
international marketing it becomes even
more important to look at Pinterest and
how you might work it into your Outreach
efforts now some of the top categories
for men because most people are very
familiar with which ones perform best
for women you know food home design you
know gardening fashion all of those
perform really well for women when we
look at the categories for men geek
tends to be the number one category so
anything you know technology geeky
oriented does really well cars and
motorcycles men's fashion does extremely
well gardening performs very well for
men architecture humor and health and
fitness tend to really be the places
where there's the most activity going on
but in this day and age you can also go
into foodie you can go into Outdoors
travel you can go into a variety of
different boards and you're still going
to see a lot of active pinning and
engagement and interaction by men now
with all of this discovery and with
growing demographics coming into the
site it also means that Pinterest has
some pretty impressive traffic potential
looking at some of the stats that have
come out pakora has done a great job of
sort of tracking to see how do people
engage with Pinterest you know what's
going on with the site we find that the
average pin drives two visits and six
page views it's also worth an average of
about 78 cents in sales now when we look
at this in terms of sort of virality we
see that the average pin also receives
11 repins now if you're a big Twitter
user you're familiar with the idea of
retweets so to give you a little
perspective on that
that makes the average pen roughly 100
times more viral than the average tweet
which receives what about 0.1 percent
repens or 0.01 percent repins so again
when we look at the potential for things
to spread and move around at a faster
Pace Pinterest has a lot of potential
but one of the other interesting things
about Pinterest is the latent nature of
traffic and purchases that come in from
it it's not uncommon for a PIN to go up
have a really big traffic Spike then it
sort of dies off and then someone else
discovers it you know because they're
running a search or they're looking
somewhere they pin it it gets back into
the feed nice and fresh traffic spikes
again or people pin content without
having visited the site to read it and
then they go back and review it later so
roughly half of all visits that come in
from Pinterest occur three months after
the original pin was released or the
original pin was made and about half of
all orders occur two months after which
again if people are researching
Christmas lists maybe putting together
other potential purchase lists for
things they're going to buy for their
house or for themselves it makes sense
that they would do their research do
their Gathering and then go back at a
later point to kind of dig in a little
bit more and make that final purchase
decision now Pinterest also has some
true e-commerce potential it's not just
about driving traffic we've also found
that Pinterest is very effective at
getting those actual conversions
so looking at some of the Pinterest
shopping stats 47 of online Shoppers
have made a purchase based on a
Pinterest recommendation and when we
look at e-commerce social sharing no not
social sharing in general but sharing of
products things you intend to buy
Pinterest holds 41 of e-commerce social
sharing now Facebook sits at 37 to give
you a little bit of perspective so again
far more e-commerce social sharing
taking place on the Pinterest platform
and then when we look at purchases
coming in you know I mentioned 78 cents
per pin is sort of the average but when
people actually do come in and convert
and buy we see an average purchase
amount of 179 dollars coming off of a
Pinterest referral if we compare that to
Facebook we get eighty dollars at
Facebook and 69 at Twitter so if we want
to do the math to put this in a little
more perspective that means that
Pinterest generates on average 27
percent more Revenue per click than
Facebook does and that it generates
roughly 400 percent more Revenue per
click than Twitter now this makes a lot
of sense if you think about it because
when people are on Twitter they're
usually checking to see what's the news
what's sort of the trending topics what
are people talking about they're not
necessarily in a shopping mindset when
they're on Facebook they're catching up
with friends and with the new sources
that they follow and kind of seeing you
know just what's the word what's
happening online but when people are on
Pinterest they're in that sort of
you know small child going to McDonald's
to get the latest Happy Meal toy you
know collect them all mode they're in
that mindset already of gathering and
acquiring and collecting and a lot of
times they're using it specifically as
part of their purchasing decisions so
they're already in a mental state or
mental mindset when they come into your
website to be prepared for purchase
they're also going to be more apt to use
something like Pinterest or research
higher ticket items so whether that's
you know your wedding dress instead of
maybe the you know the little favors
that you're going to buy from Michael's
or maybe it's you know the leather couch
that you're going to put in your living
room instead of the pillow that you're
going to pick up at Target it's a higher
end product that they're saving and
collecting so again you're going to have
a higher dollar amount when they
actually do come through and make that
purchase now I also want to touch on the
idea of Pinterest and how it has changed
the value of images because everyone
knows image marketing over the last
several years it's become really hot
there's a lot of focus on it and
Pinterest has really played a big role
in the development of that now if we
think back several years ago to the
earlier days of social media to YouTube
and how YouTube changed video marketing
what happened with YouTube is that we
had this explosion of consumer generated
content and that content was very well
received in fact when we looked at data
in way back in 2012 we could see that
user generated content and
professionally produced content that was
paired with user-generated content
performed far better across the board
than professionally produced only
content in other words when it looked
like it came from a quote real person
rather than an advertising agency people
tend to relate to it better share it
more and have a more positive response
the trust factor is higher and that
became a really great thing for
businesses of All Size because you
didn't necessarily have to pour as much
you know money in planning and skill set
into every video you produced there's
still a place for professionally
produced video but it also meant it was
a little more acceptable to not be at
that rate so for small businesses in
particular this was like a godsend in
the marketing world now unfortunately
we've sort of seen the exact opposite
thing happen with Pinterest because with
Pinterest we see the quality of images
going up exponentially and thus we see a
need for that quality of images and
again when you think about the visual
context why we go to Pinterest what
we're looking for this makes sense very
quickly if you're going to Pinterest
because you're looking for a little
dinner inspiration what are you going to
make for dinner and you run across a
picture like this
you're not really going to be in a hurry
to run home and make that because what
is it and why would I want to eat it but
when you pair it the same recipe with a
good quality image that lets you see oh
well you know that's an egg tart or it's
a frittata okay well that actually that
looks a little better that looks tastier
and this is what we're seeing happen
with Pinterest is we're seeing all of
these bloggers and all of these websites
that are producing amazing content an
amazing video you take a site like
Smitten Kitchen
she's operating out of a 42 square foot
Kitchen in New York City she doesn't
have staff there's no Production Studio
there she's not a trained chef but she
puts up the recipes that she makes and
she pairs it with gorgeous photos that
she takes herself and she's pulling in
millions of page views every single week
and probably a nice Chunk in advertising
Revenue as well but the same way that we
saw sort of amateurs dramatically change
the nature of video marketing by using
more amateurish content again we've seen
the exact opposite happen with images
because in an environment that you need
things to be so visually stimulating to
stand out on that Pinterest page the
best quality content is what's going to
rain Supreme and as you have people who
are willing to put the time and effort
in and who are creating better content
that's helping the bar for everyone else
so what it has meant for a lot of Brands
big and small is that relying so heavily
on stock photography like they used to
in the past it doesn't work so well
anymore not when you're competing with
really unique original relevant images
that people are taking of what they're
producing you know they're putting up
not just a blog post but a blog post
that has 20 amazing images to go with it
and so we've seen this sort of across
the board level of expectation that no
matter what size company you are you
need to learn how to properly operate a
camera how to put some good good
Lighting in there and to really great
get some great imagery again Enterprise
or small business it's irrelevant at
this point the quality of your pictures
must go up on your website if you want
to reap the benefits and the rewards
that come from the increased traffic
from a service like Pinterest so before
we get into the next couple sets of
videos for this series I really want to
sort of go back and kind of summarize
this idea of why Pinterest is worth
looking at if you're not already
Marketing in it or why you might want to
put some consideration into some of the
different ways you might be able to
leverage it really at its core Pinterest
is probably the strongest site online in
the social media World playing off the
impact of imagery photos weigh
incredibly heavily they are the currency
of Pinterest but that allows for really
fast concept digestion so unlike on a
Twitter or unlike on a Facebook where
there's a lot of reading as you're
scrolling through to figure out is this
something I'm interested in we can react
to and process images very quickly so so
having the opportunity to get your
content into that environment gives you
a much better chance to really capture
someone's eyes and get them to stop and
take the time to read the description
and potentially click through to the
site there's also a really low barrier
to entry it Rivals Twitter in terms of
how quickly you can get in there and set
things up for a base level Pinterest
account you know even getting your
website verified you're looking at five
to ten minutes to set up now if you're
going to go a little heavier Duty with
things like Rich pins which we'll talk
about a little later in this series
there's going to be a little bit more
effort there but it basically has a
really simple interface with minimal
management there's not a lot to it that
is going to take up a ton of time and
effort management wise
there's also the ability to look at this
as a chance for curation versus creation
and we're going to talk a little more in
depth about that idea later in the
series as well but it basically gives
you the opportunity to have a channel
that you can play in without necessarily
having to create all original content
there are some very successful and
strategic ways to leverage Pinterest
with other people's content rather than
your own
and then finally the ability to have
content segmentation which is another
idea that will dig a little deeper into
gives you the chance to really Target
your consumers in a way that you can't
do on any other social media channel
because the idea that people can choose
which areas of your content they want to
follow that allows you to curate much
deeper into a topic than you would
normally be able to now there's tons of
potential here for big Brands we see big
companies Enterprise level businesses
really leveraging it very creatively one
of the examples that I've used almost
from the start with Pinterest is Chobani
because they have non-stop done an
amazing job of marketing and one of the
things that you know they've said is it
has really allowed them to show
different sides of their personality
again that idea of the content
segmentation and being able to dig a
Little Deeper it really lets people see
more about what the brand of Chobani is
and all the different ways that people
are using their products so whether
Chobani is leveraging it to find recipes
that they might want to send to their
Test Kitchen to see about you know
leveraging on their own blogs research
to see how customers are using their
product and from their end while they're
Gathering a lot of
insight and data again there's minimal
engagement and management going on
they're not usually in there commenting
they don't have to read through a lot of
comments and respond to them they're
mostly just curating and liking and
re-pinning content now for small Brands
we see the same things there's been a
lot of companies that have done a really
great job of leveraging Pinterest to get
exposure and artifact Uprising is a
great example of this one of those
companies that was a small teeny tiny
startup literally working out of
someone's basement and they had a single
product pin that generated almost 50 000
visitors into their site and in 18
months they went from basement startup
to multi-million dollar sales just
because they got the right pin in front
of the right person and got some really
great exposure so they've been using it
to do a lot of a b testing of products
that they're looking to launch before
they actually get them launched just to
see what the response is and what people
seem to be interested in and that's
really given them as a small company the
ability to gather a lot of really unique
can creative data that otherwise might
have cost them a lot of money to hire a
market research firm to put together so
there's lots of different ways the
companies of all sizes are really
working to leverage Pinterest so coming
up in the next part of our series we're
going to talk a little bit about setting
up a Pinterest account you know personal
accounts versus business accounts we'll
look at the various types of pin boards
understanding what they are and how to
use them and we're going to talk a
little more in depth about this idea of
content segmentation and the value
associated with that so if you've
watched part one of this series and you
don't already have a Pinterest account
and you're finding yourself saying okay
let's give this a try let's get set up
the question becomes how do you go in
and actually do it well the first
question you have to ask yourself is
whether or not it's in your best
interest to set up a business account or
a personal account and a lot of that's
going to depend on the size of your
company and what your goals are if
you're an interior designer or a
marketing consultant or someone that
really sort of is your own business
setting up is personal may make sense if
you or a company of any size or
Enterprise clearly you're going to want
to set up as a business if you're
setting up is personal when you go to
pinterest.com they're going to let you
sync it to your Facebook or set up an
email address and a password but if
you're a business or if you're an
individual who wants to set up as a
business you need to go to
business.pinterest.com and keep in mind
even if you are sort of a solopreneur or
you know a blogger someone like that you
probably want to give serious
consideration to setting up an account
is a business and not just as an
individual that's because as a business
you're going to have access to more
marketing tools to more options than you
would just going in through your
personal account now if on the other
hand you have already set up account but
you haven't really figured out how to
leverage it maybe you set up a personal
account way back when and you've never
done much with it it's important to note
that on the business account page you do
have an option to convert an existing
account from a personal account into a
business account
so you're going to want to make sure you
go with that option rather than just
setting up a duplicate so when you're
creating your business account it's
going to be fairly standard same thing
you'd do anyplace else you're going to
put in an email address and a password
and the name of the business and then
they're going to take you into sort of
your starting point and that's where
you're going to have the option to go in
and do a couple different things you
might want to create your first board
and start building some of those out you
might want to install the pin it button
or the follow me button on your blog now
we're going to talk about each of those
a little bit further down the line the
one I want to focus on first because the
one that I think it is most essential
for everyone to do when they're setting
up a business account is to take a
couple moments to verify your website
with Pinterest so that's going to be the
last option on the right there and when
you choose verify your website they're
going to give you a piece of code that
you basically take back to your website
and you're going to plug into the header
code so if you're someone that has
access to the site you can go do this in
a matter of a minute or two if not this
is just going to be a snippet of code
that you're going to need to send over
to your developer your website person
and say this needs to go into the header
section once you've done that you're
going to be able to go back over to the
site and you'll notice underneath your
profile you'll see a little red check
that shows up next to your url now what
that basically does is it tells
Pinterest that this is a website that
you do actually own you're not just
trying to associate yourself with it and
that's going to give you access down the
road to things like Pinterest analytics
and some promoted pins and some
additional marketing opportunities that
you won't have if you don't take the
time to make sure you put that
verification in order so you want to
make sure that you do that is part of
your business setup on Pinterest now
there's a couple things to note about
getting started with your account even
Beyond you know simple verification or
setting up your first boards one of
those is the knowledge that unlike a lot
of other social media channels you're
not currently going to have the ability
to sync all of your other social media
channels up and that's because on
Pinterest the only way to link over to
Facebook and sync up with Facebook is to
sync with your personal account so again
if you're going in as a business you're
probably not going to want to link
Pinterest to your Facebook because
there's not currently an option in place
to just enter the URL for your business
account on Facebook to let people jump
straight into that now you can sync up
your Twitter properly because you just
need to enter your Twitter username and
password but again because Facebook
tends to be associated with a personal
account that then has access to go into
business accounts it does not do the
sync very well at all
you're also going to want to plan to
clean out your news feed Pinterest will
not let you set up an account without
picking a certain number of topics that
you're interested in and then they sort
of Auto follow people on your behalf so
chances are when you first log in
there's going to be a lot of content in
your news feed that you might not
actually be interested in so you're
unfortunately either going to have to
learn to ignore it or take the time to
click into those boards and unfollow
those Pinterest users and those boards
so you can just clean it up a little bit
and then you want to take the time to
create just a handful of boards to start
you don't need to go in and create every
board for every topic you think you're
going to use it's far better in my
opinion to start with three to five
boards and flush them out with good
quality content first and then start to
see where your interests lie what seems
to be getting a response and start to
add inboards from there you've got
plenty of time to go broader and deeper
now there's four different types of
boards you need to know about some of
them can sort of be used in conjunction
with each other some of them there's a
little bit of nuances too so the primary
type of board is what's called a
category board so when you set up a
board on Pinterest and super simple to
do you're just clicking an add a board
button you're going to be asked to enter
a name for the board and a description
for the board and then there's going to
be a drop down option to choose a
category and that's again a category
board so whether it's related to health
and fitness or food or party planning
you're basically saying to Pinterest the
content that I put on this board has to
do with this specific topic so it's a
generalized board that's going to be
synced up with pinterest's existing
categories that means it's viewable to
all users people can choose to follow it
or not follow it and the content that
you put into that board has the
opportunity to be selected by Pinterest
is part of their broader category feeds
now there's another type of board that's
called a secret board and a secret board
functions in much the same way that a
category board does except for the fact
that it's not visible to anyone except
the board owner and approved Pinterest
users and by approved Pinterest users I
mean you have added those users to the
board and given them the right to also
post their content into it so it's
basically just a way to leverage
Pinterest and all the benefits of a
Pinterest board in an environment that
you have a little bit more control over
and we'll talk a little more in depth
later in the series about different ways
to leverage secret boards both for
marketing and content research and even
for things like PR and Pitch Outreach
now the next type of board is a places
board now you can have a category board
that's a places board you can also have
a secret board that's a places board so
again there's a little bit of
opportunity for overlap there and what a
places board does is it syncs up the
board itself with a map and it allows
you to put a geographical location in
for each of the pins that you put up now
that may be because you're literally
pinning locations in places or it may be
that you're making the choice to tie a
location to an image or to a concept or
to an idea that you've put in place but
when people click in to look at these
boards they're always going to see that
map associated with it they're going to
see the pins that are in the board
showing up on the map itself so they can
take a look and see sort of how things
are laid out geographically
and then the final type of board I want
to talk about today is a group board so
I mentioned this briefly on the secret
board page but it's basically a
collaborative board it allows you to
invite other Pinterest users by name to
come in and participate now you can have
a category board that is a group board
you can have a secret board that's a
group board you can have a secret places
board that's a group board again there's
a lot of opportunity for overlap here
and really all this does is allow you to
work in a collaborative manner with
people so that you're not the only
person that's putting pins in now
there's some challenges here because you
want to make sure you don't just add
anyone because again once you add them
you're giving them the ability to pin as
well so from the business perspective
you want to be a little bit careful on
this and who you put in and who you give
some editing access to because it's not
uncommon to see these types of boards
potentially get spammed by a new user so
again you want to make sure that these
are people that you're actually familiar
familiar with that you have a measure of
trust in before you add them into a
group board so now that we have a basic
idea of what the different types of pin
boards are
it's good to get a walk through of what
it actually looks like to go through
that process of setting those up so when
you go into your Pinterest page sort of
your Pinterest profile you're always
going to see a create a board option
that shows up towards the top and on the
left so clicking that create board
option is going to launch a window that
allows you to do things like enter the
name of the board that you're putting
together write up a description of what
it is choose a category these are all
things that we've talked about doing you
know saying there here's the category in
the topic that I want it to be
associated with but then you also have
the opportunity to turn it into a places
board by adding a map or leaving the map
option turned off which will make it
just a regular standard board now you
can at any point in the future turn
something into a places board without a
problem
now you also have the option to make it
a secret board or not so for this
instance I have turned it into a secret
board because it's planning for a future
event it's important to note you can
take a board that has been made secret
and make it public but you cannot take a
public board and make it secret once
it's public it has to stay public so if
you think this is something that you may
want to be a secret board but maybe open
up later it's a good idea by default to
start with it a secret otherwise you'll
have to go back and build a new board
from scratch and re-pin everything into
that board
and then once you've decided if you're
going to make it a places board if
you're going to make it a secret board
you also have the option to type in
names and when you start typing those
names in they're going to pull up a list
of the fellow penners people with
accounts that match that name and you
have the ability to add
virtually as many people as you want
into the mix but you can say these are
the people that I want to have access
and click that create board button and
then you're going to see that option
show up now it's important to note the
people that you invite into the mix they
won't immediately show up it's not until
they have accepted your invitation that
they'll actually show up so just in case
you set a board up and you're trying to
figure out why everyone else isn't
showing up there now from that point you
can click add a pin and you can start
uploading pins or you can go out and use
Pinterest as you normally would you know
either clicking the repin button or
using the pin it button on a website and
this new board is going to show up as
one of your drop down options for
actually pinning content and getting it
online
now when we look at things like category
selection it's important to remember
that category selection is an important
part of what actually gets your content
out there into the mix so when you take
that original pin that you first put up
if it isn't associated with a category
if you pin it into a board that's not
associated with a category it's only
going to go out to your existing
followers so in this instance it was a
post by Kendall Jackson wines so they
have a little less than 2 000 followers
so it's going to broadcast out to some
of those 2000 followers based on the
algorithm and you're basically going to
get limited repens you know limited
opportunity for exposure
now when we look at
putting things into the category
now we have the opportunity that again
Pinterest may take that pin and
broadcast it out into the category area
which means you're not just getting the
exposure to the people who have opted to
follow your board but to the millions of
category viewers which means lots of
increased exposure cyclical repins and
the chance for your content to go much
further than it would have originally
now something else that's important to
understand when we look at things like
categories and you know we mentioned the
idea of getting our content out into
categories or even into home pages with
people who have chosen to follow your
content is that Pinterest has put
together an algorithm in much the same
way that Facebook has the news feed
algorithm or that Google has you know
their search engine algorithm so
Pinterest has what's known as the smart
feed and there's sort of three key
Concepts that go into the idea of the
smart feed and how Pinterest decides
what content is going to show up
originally when Pinterest was put
together it worked much like Twitter
does that content just showed up in the
order that it was pinned and if you had
good timing for logging in or for
getting your pins up there you were
going to show up in front of people but
now Pinterest is looking at mixing
different sources of pins together at
different rates so instead of having one
brand be able to come in and maybe take
over your news feed because they've
pinned you know 57
different versions of putting together
an outdoor patio now Pinterest is saying
well let's maybe pick the best of that
content and let's pair it with some of
the other content that maybe showed up a
couple hours ago but you know still new
since the last time they logged in
so the idea is that some pins should be
shown now while some are shown later so
there's a mix here that's a little
different from what we might see on
Facebook or on a search engine that
Pinterest isn't necessarily saying we're
going to take the Top Value and put
those in front of you now and toss the
rest out they're actively saying look we
know that a lot of activity around pins
is latent it doesn't always happen
immediately so if we take that pin that
someone you follow put up and we don't
show it to you for a week or two you're
probably still going to be interested in
it so there's a little bit of nuances
there in terms of understanding that
just because it doesn't show up
originally doesn't necessarily mean it
won't show up at all
but there's also the idea here that pins
have different value based on the source
in the topic so Pinterest is going to be
looking at the type of content that
you're pinning and putting together
they're going to look at the quality of
the pins and how other people have
responded to them they're going to use
that information to figure out which one
is going to be approved and actually
show up for you versus which ones might
not be the best fit and there's just no
reason to have it show up in your news
feed so it's going to take a lot of time
for this to really get sort of reverse
engineered and better understood today
to get started click the link in the
description box and embark on your
journey to the professional growth and
achievement hurry up spots are filling
up fast
social media the there is
what's it influencer marketing there is
advertising you name it so they had to
enrich their services yep and you will
see that when we go into MailChimp that
there is now a whole range of additional
Services even down to developing your
own website that MailChimp can offer you
but at the core of
MailChimp is its email system so let's
go and have a look into how to use
MailChimp and how to set up your first
email campaign so if you go to
mailchimp.com
yeah you can see here a little overview
of what it does yeah then again we're
going to go into automations I'm going
to show you some of the analytics I'm
going to show you how you can segment
with um with MailChimp and how you can
synchronize with other applications in
MailChimp as well so lots of stuff that
you can do here is a little promotional
video and here is the pricing so you can
see that a free version gives you
limited functionality but it does give
you all the functionality you need to
send emails to up to 500 contacts per
month
yep and then it goes up to 11.70 and
then the premium version gives you all
the Full Features 299 dollars but let's
focus on the free version again that's
what I kind of like often of MailChimp
so let's go into my account yes so I go
on to
let's have a look I'm logged in yeah so
here is my
audience
so here you see the features that
MailChimp has to offer
so first of all there is create you can
create campaigns
yeah that is where you run your email
campaigns and where you create your
marketing campaigns a very important
part of your MailChimp is your contacts
or your audience
of course if you don't have any emails
in your database if it were then yeah
then there's not many people that you
can send stuff to so contacts are very
important that you get an email list
that you can connect with your campaigns
there are automations that you can do
which basically means you can send
emails automatically there is analytics
there is website you can create your own
website and modules of it there is
content so that is sort of your library
of assets and then there are different
Integrations that you can do here you
see kind of your dashboard of the
campaigns and this is your audience
dashboard
so the very first thing of course that
you need to do when you are starting on
MailChimp that is create an audience
yeah and that's where you go into your
contacts so there is your audience
dashboard as you see here you can have
all an overview of all your contacts you
can create signup forms that you can add
to your website to capture people's
email addresses there are tags that you
can set to content so you can group your
content into segments and you can do
surveys and there is your inbox if
people send you messages
yeah so lots of functionality but your
first challenge will be
how to get your emails there's lots of
ways to do that first of all there may
be your existing customer database or
your existing customer list you probably
have them in a spreadsheet
yeah so what I'm going to show you in a
minute is how you can enter or import
that spreadsheet into
MailChimp yeah so that is one way second
you can actually set up on your website
a form that people can fill in to sign
up for your newsletter for instance
or you can run a campaign where people
go to a landing page and if they
download a certain piece of
documentation then they need to give you
their their email address yeah so
there's lots of ways another really
effective way if you're at an exhibition
for instance have a little box on your
your counter where people can leave
their ear their
um their business cards
yeah and then you can take all of that
information and put them in your your
MailChimp so the question here then is
of course how do I bring contacts into
my
MailChimp audience so let's go to all
contacts
yep and then you see I already have two
contacts in my my co
that's the name of my audience
yeah so I'm going to add additional
contacts I can get an overview of my
contacts I can add contacts manually I
can add a subscriber
yeah and then I can just put in the name
yeah so that is Mark at
uh simplylearn.com and then it's Mark
there is
simply learn don't have to put in a
dress I can get phone number I can get
birthday I can get company name that
would be simply learn
I can add a tag so that would be
training
add or create a tag
yeah that could be training
there's my tag now very important what
SIM what the MailChimp wants to know
that you people that you have in your
database
that you that they gave you permission
to email them yeah they're a very strict
requirements these days for people yeah
that you need to respect your privacy
you need to have permission before you
send them an email
yeah but there's different ways that you
can ask that permission you can ask it
on the website before they fill in a
form you can ask it in your newsletter
yeah so make sure that you have those
permissions because if people get
unsolicited email through a commercial
email campaign yeah in principle that is
not allowed and you may be subject to a
fine the you may have heard of the gdprs
regulations in in Europe and there is
also regulations in the United States
there's regulations in Asia yeah that's
a real tightening of those privacy
regulations when it comes to email
marketing if this person for some reason
is already in my audience then I can
update it will update their profile so
let's click subscribe
let's see
there's probably one
field I ever got
phone number that is 075
yeah shoulders phone number was a
required item as well yeah and then I
click subscribe
so if I now go back to all contacts you
will see that Mark at simplylearn.com is
now has been added to my database so
that is one way to get emails in your
audience list
the next way is if you go to add
contacts you can import contacts
there are three ways how you can import
contacts you can import contacts from
another surface
there's a way you connect with another
piece of software you can upload a CSV
file or a text file and you can even
copy and paste
yeah so if I import from another service
you can see you can import for
Salesforce from Squarespace from Shopify
and there's probably a lot more
Integrations that you can have
if you want to upload a file it will
then basically ask you to upload your
file so what we need to do we need to
create a spreadsheet that we save as a
CSV file so if I go to
Google Drive
and I'm going to actually I already have
a file here
yeah so let's open this file
so you see
that I have these names in there I'm
going to take them out very important
that you add first name last name
company email and all the fields that
are relevant for you yeah so let's say
telephone as well so then we're going to
say the first name is uh Jacob
last name is Jones
company
is Biko
and email is Jacob jones.com
telephone number is oh one two three
four five six seven
yep then the second name is
um Anne-Marie
Carol
and that is Carol
dot com
and that is n
at Carol dot prom and that is 987654
telephone number okay let's take out
that dollar sign
right yes so now I have the file and
this name is MailChimp or whatever
MailChimp one
so the first thing I'm going to do of
course is to save this I am going to
download this file as a comma separated
values file which is a CSV file
and MailChimp wants me to upload this
CSV file into
this field yeah so that's how I can
upload my contacts so I'm going to my uh
YouTube
downloads here is my MailChimp CSV file
yep so there it is I'm going to continue
to organize now the first thing that
MailChimp is going to do now if I'm
wearing any
existing context they will be updated
the first thing I can add a tag yes so
I'm going to let's say a member
and I'm going to continue to match that
is what MailChimp is going to do now
remember the first line of our
spreadsheet was sort of the field names
first name last name company name and
telephone
MailChimp is going to match those
MailChimp things that the first line was
first name the second name was last name
so these are correct company it has
picked up it doesn't know what to do
with telephone yeah so what I can do I
can edit this column yeah and I can look
at the fields that they have
yes so is telephone in here
I don't hear phone number yeah and I'm
going to link it with phone number
so now it is okay and I can now see here
five columns will be imported and I'm
going to say finalize Imports
yep so now it has added two contacts to
the list so I'm going to say complete
Imports
and if I now want to view my contacts
you will see that my contacts have been
added to my email list
yeah so now I have two additional
contacts in my list
I could also
add a subscriber actually have done a
copy and paste
go back
add contacts import contacts I could do
a copy and paste
so I'll show you how that works continue
yeah so but I go back to the spreadsheet
and I would copy these just copy it
command copy
going back to my MailChimp and I can now
just paste them here just like this and
now
MailChimp is going to analyze this yeah
and it says okay this is what I think it
is and it goes back into that same stage
that we saw in when we when we imported
the spreadsheet
yeah you see here first name last name
company name and then the telephone
yep now I'm not going to import this
again because we've already imported
these contacts but this is how you
import your contacts
okay
now a few tips on your database
yes very important
are you sure you want to exit this okay
yes so you may build up a list of a
couple of hundred contacts in your in
your MailChimp and that is fantastic
yeah the bigger your list the more value
that you will get from it a very
important aspect of this is to make sure
that your database is clean
yeah people may ask to be removed from
your database people change businesses
yeah make sure your database is clean
when you run a campaign
and you use your email list and there
are a lot of emails that cannot be sent
because there are a lot of wrong emails
in your list
yeah you will have what we call a high
bounce rate
and if you have a continuous high bounce
rate
MailChimp may come back to you and say
hey why do you have such a high bound
rate
and if you can't explain why you have a
high bound rate MailChimp may actually
block your account
because MailChimp wants you to work with
a clean database that is also the risk
if you buy an email list that you don't
know the source from
and if you import it and then run your
first campaign if you get a whole lot of
bounces on your emails yeah then uh
MailChimp May block your account so be
very careful make sure that your emails
are correct that your bounce rate is low
and never buy
email lists because you don't know what
the quality is of the list
make sure that you segment your mailing
list and then you can within one mailing
list you can send it to your different
segments it could be customers could be
prospects could be
suppliers or what have you
yeah constantly work on growing your
database make sure you don't spam people
always get
um people's approval yeah that they are
happy for you to send them
um emails and of course honor
unsubscribes as well if people ask you
to unsubscribe them from the mailing
list make sure you do that
okay just a few tips when it comes to
managing your database
so now that you have your email audience
set up your contacts setup let's look at
a campaign
let's
when you go into the campaigns here you
have an overview of all the campaigns
that you've run now we haven't run any
campaigns here is a draft campaign yeah
but what you're gonna do you're going to
create a campaign
yes when you click here on the top right
on the create campaign button you have
then the different types of campaigns
that you can or can create you can do a
regular email
you can actually create a landing page
or you can also create an embedded form
yeah that helps you in capturing context
that could be part of your landing page
campaign
but what we're going to look at is
regular emails
yeah so when I click on email I can just
side click here design email
yeah then there is a new email Builder
that you can use and since you're
probably new to Simply learn a new to
um to MailChimp I click straight onto
the new Builder because that is a lot
easier to work with
yeah so here you see it's time to design
your email
yeah I put this little icon already in
yesterday yeah so there's different ways
of doing that here you see sort of your
editor for your email here you can
preview the email here you see your
editing building blocks the layout The
Heading paragraph button Etc here you
can specify Styles and here you can
specify templates for your emails so
here you see an whole range of email
templates
yeah if you click on the creative
assistant that is beautiful but it will
drive you to a premium
account yeah so I'm not going to show
that I want to show you the free
features of MailChimp so let's say we're
going to go for a little design here
we're going to go for this one we could
do preview that's how it will look like
yeah and then we're going to click apply
continue with start with a clean
template
yes so this is how it will look like so
what you can then do start optimizing
the text and the images
so let's do that so here few decimal in
your browser that is always good to have
you can change your image
yeah so if I click on that
you see here replace logo yeah so if I
click on replays logo I can then
go to the content studio and I can just
upload different files here and this is
the image that I picked yeah so let's
stick with this particular image here
then I can add a photo so I can say add
a photo I can say upload an image
yeah so if I go to my YouTube I go to uh
thought I had an image somewhere videos
Banner
yeah so here I've added a banner as an
image I can align it left center right
full
yeah I can just line to the right I can
align it to the center left I'm going to
do a full alignment okay and then here
you see my text it's time to design your
email so here I can say
um welcome
to this week's newsletter
in this newsletter
oops and in this newsletter
we will
be talking
about
and then blah blah blah blah okay then
here you see a button and I've added
that I can then just click here first I
click done yeah so the buttons I can
bring in here through my
um
my
built units yeah and here I can change
the button text so I here is book now
for instance
so here I have my social media buttons
yeah and I can there put my own social
media onto that
yeah I can do the same with my Instagram
and I can do the same for my Twitter
I can add another social link I'm going
to leave it at like that here's my logo
again then here this will be picked up
automatically every email
will at the bottom have details about
your company about your address how can
people unsubscribe yeah and because
you're using the free version there is
this item grow your business with
MailChimp yeah that is a little bit of
MailChimp branding that will be added to
your email if you're using the free
version so keep that in mind
okay so then you click preview this is
how your email will look like
yep and then you're gonna exit preach
remote and if you're happy with this
you're going to save and exit
now here you kind of have your admin
screen for your campaign
yeah so you see here the name so I need
to type in the name
so I'm going to name it is MailChimp
demo for instance and I'm clicking save
then here I have selected all the
contacts so I can just go to my audience
I pick the audience that I've created I
can then have all my subscribers or I
can pick certain segments or tags in my
subscriber base I can personalize the
two Fields yeah and then I click save
here is the from so that is it's from me
or you can edit that have it from send
from somebody else you can add a subject
now your subject line of course is very
important in email marketing because in
the subject line people will when they
read the subject line people will decide
whether or not they will open the email
yes so the subject line always has to be
catchy so when it could be five reasons
why you shoot read our latest
email a newsletter
newsletter
yeah or any other subject line but they
are they need to be short and sweet yeah
you could use emojis you need to in that
one line you need to give people the
reason why they shoot open this email
preview text appears in the inbox after
the subject line yeah so in today's
newsletter
we will talk
about
social media
and email marketing
for instance and you click save
so that is your subject that is your
content
yep and then here is part of your
contact you can send yourself a test
email
that is always useful to send it to
yourself and check it on your desktop
and check it on your mobile so I send
myself a test email send a test to any
email yeah so let me quickly check here
my Gmail
that is uh
to me
that is tube for Mark
okay so I'm going to send that email to
tube for Mark okay I can send it to
multiple people and I'm going to click
send test
email has been sent
so let's check the email so here we see
the email test five reasons why you
should read our latest newsletter
and then here you see the email and then
you check it on typos you check it on
the links that are in there yeah make
sure that your social media buttons work
etc
and if you're then happy with your email
you can then publish it
yeah and there's two ways of publishing
it you can schedule it
when you schedule it you can set a
delivery date and a specific delivery
time but in order to use that feature
you need to upgrade to Premium
okay so you can send it directly
so when you click Send it will go
straight away
yep so very important or you can say
finish later if you don't want to share
your campaign you see here the link for
the campaign
yeah and you could change that
your default campaign URL yes your
MailChimp generate randomly five reasons
why you should read our email if you
upgrade to premium you can turn this
MailChimp into your own URL
okay good and then you can track your
your campaign your email campaigns but
um we'll printable usually we'll cover
that in a in the next video on on
MailChimp when we go into more advanced
features okay so I'm just gonna click
finish later
and if we're now having our list of
campaigns then here you see we have our
MailChimp demo as a draft ready to be
published
so that is the so that is the campaigns
how to create a campaign on MailChimp
right now let's have a look at a few
more things so first of all a new
feature in MailChimp is the analytics
when you send out an email campaign you
will get basic analytics here in your
campaigns dashboard as well but
MailChimp now also has an analytics
dashboard
and here you see the type of data that
you will get in MailChimp and it is
using sample data so we can explore the
dashboard so here you see number of
emails sent whether it's up or down you
see the number of people or the
percentage of people that opened the
email
and very important the actual percentage
of people that clicked on the email or
clicked on the link in the email and
that is very important yeah so that's
where you can really follow through on
your email campaigns yeah on who opened
it who clicked it to the form the
phrases that needed to be filled in so
very useful information that you can get
out of your campaign and you can see
that from various periods yeah you can
even actually in the other reports you
can actually see who are the people in
my
mailing list in my audience who actually
clicked on the email and who are the
people who opened the clicked on the
link
and then you can approach them
separately
yeah so here you see engagements
email sent and the click rate
yep so here you see by email the number
of recipients the open rate The Click
rate the revenue that you made
if you had that set up so lots of data
that you can get on your email campaigns
open rates are very important and they
differ by industry yeah and general and
the open rate
anywhere between up to 15 and higher are
usually good open rates
okay so that is the analytics that you
can get and then finally what I really
like in MailChimp is that you can use
MailChimp to create landing pages so if
I'm going back to my campaigns
and I'm going to click create campaign
then I can also decide to create a
landing page
name of the landing page is Michael
select an audience Michael and I'm going
to click begin
yeah and here you see
a number of templates that I can use for
my landing page
yeah so very simple templates so let's
take this template
except
I'm going into the editor
yeah so here is the editor for the
landing pages I can add text I can do
box text I can add dividers images I can
change the text
yeah you see here band mates that is the
logo I can change the logo
yeah so I can replace the logo and I can
edit a logo and what hit you I'm just
going to stick with this text for the
time being and here is my email address
form yeah and the beauty about it when
people fill in their email address in
this form it will automatically be added
to my mailing list
in MailChimp so that is a very powerful
feature I can also create this as a
separate form
Okay so
so here you see the available fields
that I have email I can add first name
if I want to yeah I can add last name
and I can add phone number as well
yep I can then go to the settings
I can do the style different styles that
I can have so this is my sign up form
yeah the button text is subscribe I can
then also send visitors to a
confirmation message
I can preview the confirmation message
success you've been added to the
audience
yeah exit preview
yep and that is my sign up form and
again it will automatically be added to
my campaign email list and I click save
and close
yep and here is the full campaign
yeah and when I'm happy with it
I can click save and close
so here is my landing page
and it's now
here I have the page title and site icon
here's the social share preview here is
the URL of mic and my landing page here
is the contents
and I can then get my
finish it later or I can publish it and
as soon as I publish it
this URL will be live
yeah so click publish
so this landing page is now live
so if I now go to this landing page
yeah so here you see email address I'm
saying uh
Sherry
oh
Cherry at henry.com
com and that is
cherry
and I'd say subscribe
so now let's check the litmus test if I
go to my contacts and I'm going to all
my contacts
and here we have cherry Henry the famous
Arsenal football player who has just
joined my mailing list so that is the
power of MailChimp day to get started
click the link in the description box
and embark on your journey to the
professional growth and achievement
hurry up sports are filling up fast
designing something is one of the most
difficult tasks especially when you are
not an artist but you don't have to be a
designer to get a designer look for your
designs you can do this with the help of
tools in the digital era design is one
of the most important aspects of content
marketing the first impression is half
the deal if your content is not able to
catch the interest of your audience at
first glance then they might not be
clicking on it there are many tools and
services out there that allow you to
create great graphics and designer sets
but in this video we will explore canva
one of the most efficient and easy to
use tools out there when it comes to
designing hey everyone I am tusha
bariwal welcome to Simply learns YouTube
channel but before we begin if you enjoy
watching Tech related content consider
subscribing to our YouTube channel and
hitting that Bell icon to stay tuned
without further Ado let's move on to
today's session agenda we will start off
the session with an overview of canva
what is canva used for and why it's
gaining popularity next we will discuss
some of its best features moving forward
we will discuss the pricing of canva and
then we will end this session by
learning how to use canva what is can
canva is a simple design tool that
allows anyone to create great looking
graphics and Designs it is available on
the web and as a mobile app with this
tool you can create social media post
invitations websites presentations and
many more it is a great for small
businesses that cannot afford a graphic
designer and don't have the time to
learn how to create their own Graphics
the best part is that anyone can create
a great looking design without needing
to download any software or even a
design skill anyone can create a
professional looking design by dragging
and dropping next let's discuss what is
canva used for canva is not just limited
to social media post it has other uses
as well with this tool you can create so
many things let's discuss some of that
app mockups mock-ups are detailed
representations of your app design this
includes all the final UI elements like
typography copy colors and visuals you
can also create amazing graphs mind maps
business proposals and prototypes in the
later part of of the video we will see
how we can get pre-made templates of the
following things in canva so now that we
understand what is canva and its usage
now let's understand what makes canvas
so popular the platform is free to use
to create professional designs you don't
need to spend much money on tools
however for additional features you have
to pay you don't need prior experience
or to be a graphic designer to use canva
best for small business owners online
entrepreneurs and marketers who want to
design things quickly now let's discuss
the best features of canva there are a
lot of features available when it comes
to creating different designs with canva
but we will discuss some of its best
features we will also cover a complete
guide on how to use canva in the later
part of this video but before we do let
us discuss some of its best features
produce different types of content canva
will give you the Liberty to create
different types of content like social
media post videos ppts and many more the
next best feature is pre-made templates
canva has a pre-made template so you
don't need to create designs from stats
you can make changes to that template
and create amazing designs the next best
feature is drag and drop feature canva
doesn't require any coding to design
simply drag and drop to get your work
done
another best feature of canva is stock
images icons and fonts you will get a
lot of stock stuff like images videos
sound effects in the canva itself you
don't need to go any another website to
get stock stuff this makes it one stop
solution to create amazing visuals
feature you want to work as a team for
example you have five designers one
designer has created a design for your
next Facebook ads and you want another
designer to do an addition to that
Facebook ad design you can do this by
using a team features moreover if you
want Advanced features as a team you can
purchase canva subscription and again
that makes canva affordable because as a
team the cost of canva is divided among
the team let's discuss the last feature
in our list which is video transition in
2022 many companies are focusing on
video advertising canva gives you the
power to create amazing video ads for
your brand
how much does canva cost to understand
the pricing of canva we will go to the
website and see what are the different
plans available in canva to go to canva
website you just need to Simply type on
Google canva.com once you search this
canva.com on Google you will find the
first website as canva.com just simply
click on it and you will be redirected
to the official website of canva here
you can see there is a pricing section
plans and pricing let's check so
basically there are three Plans free Pro
and Enterprise what are these three
plans let's have a look by clicking on
this compare pricing button once you
click on this compare pricing button you
will be redirected to the page where
they have compared free plan Pro Plan
and Enterprise plan so basically this
free plan can be used by any Indies
versus companies or anything who wants
to use canva for free but but for the
additional features you have to go for
the canva Pro
and if you are a or if you want a
Enterprise some big company you have a
large team then you can go with the
Enterprise plan now let's take a look at
each of them so basically this canva
plan is for people from one to five
uh if you see uh this free plan gives
you 2 lakh 50 000 plus free templates
100 plus design types like social media
post presentation letters and more
hundreds of thousands of free photos and
Graphics invite members to your team so
in free plan also you can invite the
members and create your own team you can
collaborate and comment in real time so
collaboration is also possible in the
free plan you will get 5gb of cloud
storage so what are the changes in Pro
Plan like why we should go with the Pro
Plan if you see everything free has plus
so this simply means everything you see
here is included in the Pro Plan now
let's discuss what additional Pro Plan
offers so 100 Plus premium stock photos
videos Audi deals and Graphics so you
will get some stock stuff premium stock
stuffs which is not available in the
free plan okay if you see six lakh 10
000 Plus premium and free templates with
new designs daily so so every day there
will be new uh designs added and uh you
can say updated easily save and apply
your brand or campaigns color logo font
100 plus brand kits uh there is a very
good feature which Pro offers that is
remove image backgrounds so suppose if
you want a PNG image you want to remove
the your background so you just need to
click uh on the remove background button
and and in just one click uh your
background will be removed
resize option also it will give so that
also a good option if you see in the
free plan we'll only get 5gb of cloud
storage
but in the Pro Plan you will get 100 GB
of cloud storage the last feature of
this canva Pro Plan is scheduled social
media content to eight platforms so
there are a lot of social media
platforms available out there so you can
simply schedule your social media posts
if you see all the Enterprise plan uh
everything pro has plus so this this
simply means everything uh that you will
see in the Pro Plan is there in
Enterprise and these are the additional
things which Enterprise offers like
control your team's access to apps
Graphics colors logos ETC control team
uploads into canva storage is unlimited
if you see in the canva Pro 100 GB
storage is there in Free plan 5gb
storage is there but in Enterprise level
if you purchase this one then you will
get unlimited storage that is also a
good feature if you have a good team
members like 25 plus of team in your
company want to use canva then it's the
best plan for you you can contact sales
so this if you click on that this you
will be redirected to the sales person
of the canva and they will offer you a
customized price so summarizing free
plan you will get at zero rupees uh if
you are someone who if you see on
monthly basis how how much it will
charge so how 499 per month is the
charges for the Pro Plan okay and uh 2
200 per month per person is the charges
for Enterprise level if you see on this
Pro Plan this 499 is uh if you purchase
this 499 plan five people can use this
one but if you see on the Enterprise
2200 per month will cost you for one
person so if you want a detailed
comparison you can scroll down and there
is a button compare plans you can simply
compare your plans this comparison is
based on design and Publishing
collaboration brand management Storage
security and support so that's how you
can compare the plants so as we
discussed a lot of things related to
canva in this session finally let's see
how to use canva we will go to the canva
website and see how we can create
designs in canva we will also check out
the different different categories that
are available in canva so now as you can
see we are into the canva website so
let's discuss how we can create
different different designs on canva
simply go to canva.com and the easiest
way to uh create any piece of content is
simply go to the search box and type
anything which you want to create for
example I want to create an Instagram
post right so I'll just search this and
I can select this option so if you see
there is a option of Instagram post
simply click on that
and you will be able to find different
different templates which you can use so
there are free templates available as
well as premium templates are also
available if you see there is a icon of
canva pro so all the templates which
have this particular sign
is comes under the premium
so you can explore and whichever
template you like you can simply go into
that and create that so before jumping
into creating and editing any piece of
content I firstly let's have a look uh
on the different different categories
that are available on canva so I'm going
to the home of canva and we will explore
what are the different different
categories we have at canva what are the
different types of things we can design
in canva simply go to the templates
option if we go on the templates option
you you can get lot of templates of
different different things we will see
that so there are categories available
business category social media video
marketing custom prints cards and
invitation education so if you click on
this business category you can see there
are a lot of things we can design if you
see in in this video also we have
discussed the Mind map graph
so all these things you can create
suppose if you want to create a resume
or invoice or some business report some
business proposal mind map presentation
all of these things you can get from
here for example if I click on this
presentation option
I can get lot of presentation templates
which I can use and edit it for example
if I click on this one uh for example uh
I like this one this template right so I
click on this
I can customize this template
right and
if you see we have redirected to the
canva editor right here we can simply
drag and drop and we can edit anything
we can change the size of the font and
everything so let's design something
right so suppose if I want to add some
element right
uh if I want to add some shape so I can
simply click on this right and I can
create this one
okay if I walk I can also change the
color of this
I'm just showing you uh if I want that
this design so what I can do right
so like this we can add a shape if I can
change the shape color as well so
suppose if I want this to be in yellow
so we can get this company profile text
background and this particular shape
background yellow we can also increase
the font size from here okay so we have
I hope you understand the how we can use
the shape option you can check out the
different different things which are
available here on elements you will get
lot of things like tables you can add
tables Graphics photos videos audios
charts frames and collection so if I
want to add some graphic to this
particular
a design so how I can do this so I have
searched this skill
uh in the search bar so I'll get the
graphics which is related to skills so
uh let me just choose one image so that
we can add it here I have choose this
image
right so we can
add this image anywhere in this
particular design
we can resize as well right with this
option
we can animate as well if you want to
animate right so like this you can do
so there are multiple options are
available so you can explode this one
right that's how you can do different
different
uh Element Animations you can add if you
want to add please animation then you
can go to this option and you can see
page animations also you can do from
this
so that's how you will add graphics you
can seem like the same process will be
there uh for adding the videos and for
adding the
audio files right and same thing for the
photos as well suppose if you want to
add some photos from your personal
computer then in that case you need to
go to this upload option and you can
also upload images from your own
computer or desktop or your laptop right
so you can upload anything from here
you can also upload any videos and
audios and there is also one option
available you can record yours as well
so that is also very good option
available in canva so from your if you
want to upload something from your own
PC or system then you can select this
upload option otherwise if you want some
stock stuff then you can go to the
element option and search any keyword
which is related to the thing which you
want to add in your design and you will
get the results and you can add anything
from this element option suppose if you
want to add some text in the text case
you can go to this text option so there
are you can add a heading add a sub
heading add a little bit body of text so
all these three types of things you can
add on your design so and there there
are font combinations available so that
directly you can use so suppose if I
like this one right so I can apply this
one and I can customize this right
suppose I want to write this as a game I
am just taking it as an example right I
can also customize this
with this option
and you can move this anywhere
wherever I want this I can add simply uh
drag and drop you can do that's how
canva works so there are different
different font combinations available
which you can use some are free so if
you see these four are free and then
here these font combination will come in
the Pro Plan and the Enterprise plan
there are some more option if you go to
this more section you can find different
different uh options available simply
explore that then you will get a better
idea but I hope you got a better idea on
how we can edit the edit things or edit
design in canva so these uh thing we
have added on the presentation right
let's go back to the home the same thing
you can do for the Instagram post and
anything like for LinkedIn post Carousel
post for resume the same process will be
there I am going again to this template
option so that we will explode the other
categories as well so previously we have
taken the exam we have gone to this
business category and then we have
clicked on the presentation and we have
see how we edit on canva right the same
process will be there for everything
right you can edit anything for example
if you click on this mind map you will
find different different templates for
mind map
you can simply choose any of these
templates and you can customize
according to your needs let's see what
are other things available in business
if you see there are resume invoice
proposal reports are available the next
category of canvas social media on
social media you will find different
different templates for Instagram for
Facebook for tick tock LinkedIn
for Twitter right then again uh there is
a video category where you can create
video ads as well or if you want to post
somewhere on their social media then you
can create videos with with the help of
this uh video section you will get
different different templates then there
is a marketing category so you can
create your logo suppose if you want to
create a website low so you can do that
as well broker you can create newsletter
infographics you can create right or if
you want to use some infographics on
your website that also you can create
custom prints so t-shirt mugs sticker
photo book labels hoodie Banner
certificate so certificate also you can
create right if you go to this custom
prints then you can edit certificate as
well cards and invitation is the next
category in which you can find templates
of invitation card postcard and the last
category is education
on education you can get educational
presentation uh in the business category
you will get the business presentation
right uh but in the educational category
you will get educational presentation
educational video education infographic
online whiteboard so there are a lot of
things available right then uh there are
after the category there is a style
option on canva so you can choose these
as well there are themes available so
for example in companies we generally
brainstorm on something right so if you
explore this brainstorm so you will get
these types of themes right so you can
select the category right whichever you
want right you can select anything
whichever template you want then you can
select the style whichever style you you
like you can select that and then you
can select the theme so according to
that you will get the templates then you
can also there is a filter option of
free or Pro so suppose if you don't have
a Pro Plan right then I would suggest
you or I would recommend you to select
this free option so that you will get
the free templates so directly so all
these templates are free so you can
simply click any of them and you can add
it for example if I I like this template
right I can customize this template
the same procedure will be there uh the
same thing that we did for the
presentation the same thing will be
there for this one as well the editor
will be same but uh there is one
different that is the content piece is
different so I can edit this according
to my needs or if I want to add
something to this one then I I show you
previously as well on elements we can
add anything right on the text suppose I
want to add some text here so that also
I can do I don't want these font
combination I want some simple right so
I can select this heading option from
here
once I click on this heading option I
can customize this for example I'll just
write my name
I just increase the size
and I'll just put it here
so I can change the font of this
particular uh name uh it's my name
Tushar so I can change the font so for
example I want open sense then I can
choose this font I can increase the size
of the font decrease the size of the
font I can change the color okay if I
want this to be in bold then I can do
this from by clicking on this I can
change the alignment from this option I
want something in pointers or less then
I can use this if I want some spacing
Suppose there are multiple lines you
have written some paragraph so on that
lines how much spacing you need so that
also you can do from this option effects
this is also good option I like this
left effect if you see
there is something change in the design
so if I click on this none option you
see there is a different design right
and if I click on this left background
will be little bit Shadow or something
like that intensity I can control from
here so suppose I want to increase some
the intensity then I can do that as well
so that's how you will edit things on
canva ready to get started click the
link in the description box and embark
on your journey to the professional
growth and achievement hurry up spots
are filling up fast greetings everyone
this is Rob Sanders and thank you for
joining me today we're going to talk
about SEO tools so let's get started so
if you're doing SEO and you're doing on
page and off-page SEO for an
organization or website you're going to
need some tools to help you so you can't
go at it alone you can't do anything
manually you have to lean on tools to
help you work more efficiently help you
gain an advantage and so if you're doing
SEO you're going to need tools for
keyword research you're going to need
tools to help you with the technical
aspects related to SEO you're going to
have to use some tools for off-page SEO
including backlink monitoring and
Analysis and then there's tools for
helping you track where your keywords
and Pages rank so there's tools for
every element of SEO and today we're
going to take a look at some of the best
tools out there on the market to help
you do your job better so let's start
with the keyword research so with
keyword research tools you can do your
job a lot more efficiently finding the
right relevant keywords I mean that's
really key to SEO is finding keywords
that are relevant to your business
product or service that you want to rank
for so you want to be able to choose
keywords with high search volume and low
competition so where do you get those
numbers you get those from certain tools
you also want to get forecasts for
certain targeted keywords you want to be
able to generate a list of latent cement
index and type keywords keywords close
to the keyword you're trying to Target
you want to be able to select primary
and secondary keywords wisely so having
a list of keywords or certain data
points will help you do that and you
want to be able to identify the keywords
that your competitors are also ranking
for so good keyword research tool will
help you do all of those things so what
are some of the the tools out there well
look no further than some of the free
ones that Google offers like Google
Trends so Google Trends is a good tool
that you can lean on if so if we look at
Google Trends all you need to do is
trends.google.com you can type in a
keyword I can look at the volume or
interest of that keyword over time here
I'm looking at football versus American
football and I could see how it's
trending then I can see you know how it
Trends in specific regions of say the
United States as my market I can also
look at other related queries similar to
football or American football and so
Google trend is a good tool helps you
look at the volume helps you look at
what specific regions helped you look at
other keywords you know if you want you
can simply just do a keyword search or
you can actually just see what's
trending just by looking at the latest
stories and insights so we could see
International women's day you know
started to pick up steam is picking up
more steam Etc so it's certain keywords
that tend to Trend well and you can pick
up on what those keywords are using
Google Trends now you could also use
another Google tool called Google
Keyword Planner the only difference is
this one's paid you need a Google ads
account so if we go into Google ads hey
you'll need to go to tools and you'll
need a Keyword Planner but when you're
in Keyword Planner you can find new
keywords so if I type in for example you
know online marketing and click get
started what the keyword tool is going
to do is give me the data that I need to
do appropriate keyword research it's
going to give me my keyword and similar
keywords it's going to give me the
average month and volume and the great
thing here is I can actually see the
trend for that keyword over time just by
clicking on this little bar graph so for
digital marketing I could see what the
trend is over time I could see what the
competition is I could see you know if
I'm going to bid on this keyword I could
see what the bidding range is so more
important I could see the volume and I
can see the competition here's my volume
for this keyword over the last 12 months
on average and here's my competition so
Google's Keyword Planner gives you the
necessary information you need to choose
relevant keywords wisely now there are
other tools out there that are paid that
help you look for Relevant keywords like
sem rush or keyword finder that's a
freemium tool so there are plenty of
tools available to you you know another
tool I use that's not listed here is Moz
so if you just type a keyword let's just
type in the same keyword like online
marketing for example okay so what Moz
is going to do is going to give me some
volume it's going to give me some other
keyword suggestions okay it's going to
tell me how difficult that keyword is
and it's going to tell me who else is
ranking for that keyword so it gives me
again all the relative information I
need including competitive information
so you can use these two these keyword
tools moz's freemium summer paint some
are free there's plenty of tools out
there but these are the ones I would
recommend for keyword research now let's
turn our attention to technical SEO so
for technical SEO you're going to need
to use some tools there's no getting
around that because you want to be able
to monitor how your website is
performing I mean is it loading slow for
example does it have a lot of uh issues
with the website in terms of server side
rendering for example or server response
time what about four or fours and
redirects so you want to be able to
gather a lot of the technical
information that could Aid or prohibit
your site from ranking so you want to be
able to also you know look at what the
Bots are saying and how they're viewing
your website so if Google goes to crawl
your site are they experiencing you know
a slow server response time were they
experiencing Pages not found you also
want to see if you have a site map you
know what's the site map are these Bots
crawling your site or getting the pages
from a sitemap and again you want to be
able to lean on some of these tools to
help you fix errors that you may
encounter like meta tags or four fours
or canonicals so you need a good tool to
help you manage all that and so I'm
going to go back to mods starting out so
if we go back to Moz Moz is a good tool
it's an all-in-one it's a great SEO
platform so if I go to Moz and I log
into an account I can just go to site
crawl and so what Moz is going to do
it's gonna give me a lot of information
about how Moz is bot is seeing my site
okay so if I go to the site crawl I can
look at all the particular critical uh
issues that I've experienced so I can
see four or four errors okay redirects
related to that that I could see Meta
descriptions missing meta descriptions
duplicate content so there's a lot of
different issues that Moz is detecting
for this particular site and the great
thing about Moz and this is why I use
Moz as my SEO platform I don't work for
mods I've just used them a long time is
if you do have issues then they give you
ways to fix it the how to fix it section
so if I see missing description here if
I just click on review and get a more
in-depth analysis as to what the issues
are here but I can also click on the why
and how to fix okay and they're going to
give you some information about how this
is impacting SEO and what you could do
to fix the issue they lay out the issues
pretty prominently here you can see for
all the metadata issues I have I have
you know 142 total metadata issues I
have 10 title tag two Longs I have 122
missing meta descriptions so they lay it
out nicely here up the top so you can
kind of get a sense of what to work on
and again they prioritize it based on
the severity of the issue and then they
break it down into several categories
for example I just looked at metadata
issues you can see if I click on content
issues I have some duplicate content
that Moz is recognizing or missing or
valid H tags so Mazda does a really
really great job blend on all the issues
out for you to recognize okay there's
another tool that I like to use called
screaming frog it's a pay tool so if we
go look here great thing I like about a
screaming frog it will crawl your site
and it will give you some list of issues
just like Mazdas of you know what it
sees in your site is experiencing four
fours broken links are there any
redirects it's picking up duplicate
content site Maps you know they're
JavaScript issues how is it see the site
architecture so it really does take a
deep look at everything that could
impact hacked your website from ranking
okay there are other tools out there
like you know deep crawl or woo rank
they're both paid and so pay tools are
really great as well it just depends on
you know your pricing structure what
your budget is but really when it comes
to all these tools they all more or less
overlap and do the same thing you just
need to rely on one of them to make sure
that you're able to see what the issues
are now there's nothing wrong with using
two of them just as a second reference
point to see if both are picking up the
same issue and of course I like to use
search console I always like to lean on
Google search console because that is
the source so search console will also
you know give you some feedback on how
Google's bot is crawling your site so
that's under the crawl error section
here so you can also you know use search
console to upload a site map so that's a
key to SEO you want Google to be able to
find your web pages quickly so you can
simply just signify to Google way your
site map is located so the search
console does a lot more gives you some
HTML improvements gives you some
backlinking uh and then the process of
updating the search console user
interface so there's a new user
interface that you can use with Google
search console the great thing is it's
free and it has everything you need to
know about your website and how it's
affected by SEO organic search the only
thing you have to do with search console
is verify the site but once you verify
it it has all the relevant information
you need so let's talk about backlink
monitoring and Analysis okay so this is
related to off-page SEO so you're going
to need a good tool to help you monitor
your website backlinks and backlinks are
simply just links from external sites
pointing to your site and you need to
keep an eye on what sites are linking to
yours are they spammy related sites are
they good at relevant sites or anything
in between so you need to really be able
to analyze what the good lengths are and
what the bad links are pointing to your
website you want to identify and disavow
Port backlinks okay so you want to be
able to recognize which sites are
linking to yours that's actually hurting
you from an SEO standpoint and you want
to be able to do something about that
okay you want to measure citation flow
and Trust flow you want to check the
ratio of Link distribution in terms of
is it internal or external or you know
what kind of sites are linking to my
site are they you know social related
are they pure content related and then
you want to be able to track the number
of do follow and no followings you know
how many links pointing to our site are
actually telling Google and other Bots
not to follow the link or how many are
actually allowing the Bots to follow
that link if a bot follows a link it's
going to pass what we call link juice so
you're going to get credit for the
backlink if it's a no follow you're not
going to get credit for the backlink and
we want to be able to measure that and
so we want to have tools that will help
us do that so what are some of those
tools well well hrefs is a good tool
it's a pain toll Majestic is a freemium
tool Moz again Moz is the tool I use sem
rush and then again I gotta mention
Google search console so let's take a
look at some of these tools in terms of
backlink monitoring and Analysis so
let's start with Google search console
again it's free you just have to verify
your site and so if I go to Google
Search console I can look at links and I
could see what external links I have
pointing to my site okay so I could see
I have 17 000 in this example pointing
to the home page of this particular site
okay so if I click on that I can see all
the the top sites pointing to my home
page now from an off-page SEO
perspective do you want every backlink
or external link pointing to your home
page no so you want links pointing to
internal pages so you want to be able to
measure that so I could see with the top
linking sites are and I can also see
what the anchor text is so do I want my
anchor text oh always to be my brand
name no I want it to be you know keyword
we're trying to Target search console
also gives you some internal links okay
what are the top link Pages for internal
links so from an SEO perspective you
always want to have a nice balance of
internal linking so this report helps
you understand what pages are getting
links and are the links evenly spread so
this is Google search console this is
the links report this is totally free
this is provided by Google all you have
to do is verify your site now if we go
over to Moz we type in a domain any
domain so I just typed in simple and
learn okay Moz has some metrics that are
important to off-page SEO including
domain Authority so the higher your
domain Authority the better off you are
and so what helps a domain Authority
grow is how many quality links are
pointing to that domain and so here we
could see over
7500 linking domains to Simply learn so
what's important is we just don't want
any site we want quality relevant sites
pointed okay so we could see how many
total inbound links and then how many
ranking keywords we have okay so here
Moz is going to give me kind of an idea
of what my domain Authority has been
over time they're going to tell me the
top fault links to the site so they can
tell me you know what are those links
pointing to my site and what's the page
authority of those sites okay here I can
get a nice graphical breakdown of the
linking domains by domain Authority so
you want pages with high domain
Authority pointing to your site so here
I could see 69 linking domains between
91 and 100 so that's really good we want
High relevant domains linking to our
site so just like search console I could
see the top anchor text being used okay
and I can see the top pages that have
you know good page Authority on the site
I could see following versus no follow
on internal and external links so this
is just the overview so my has really
really does break down for you you know
what those pages and linking domains are
so if I just click on linking domains
now I could get a detailed look for my
home page what domains are pointing to
our domain so I can see microsoft.com
has a domain authority of 100. YouTube
99 and so not only does Moz provide you
with the domains it also provides you
with your domain Authority score and
spam score so you want to keep an eye on
any particular site that has a high spam
score so having a site with a high spam
score and a low domain Authority will
hurt your domain and Page Authority for
that page so Mazda does a great job of
breaking it out and this is for any page
it doesn't necessarily have to be the
home page okay if I take a look look at
another example here Majestic so
Majestic again I can use a free version
of the tool they have their own metrics
citation flow trust flow so when they
say trust flow what's the link quality
all about okay site flow what's the link
volume and they can get an idea of how
many external backlinks are pointing to
the site and what's the trend on that
referring domains so Majestic does a
really good job again some of the same
metrics that we could see here except
they go into detail about languages as
well so this is majestic and you got
search console you got a lot of other
tools and then I'm going to just revert
back to Moz because you want to be able
to compare link profiles if you're in a
competitive space and you're doing
off-page SEO you know Moz will help you
compare how your site stands against
maybe another competitive side or
relevant site so just doing this
analysis I can compare my domain
Authority spam score how many total
links you know how many external file
links or external no follow links a
breakdown of linking domains so it does
a nice job of comparing one site versus
another that's going back to Moz and
that's what you want you want to go good
tool that's going to help you do that I
mean there's other tools out there not
listed like bright Edge that will also
help you compare linking profiles so at
the end of the day if you're doing off
page SEO you want to get a sense of what
sites are linking to yours are they
quality sites are they spammy what
anchor text are they using are they no
follow are they do follow you know are
they top domains how do you compare
against your competitors I mean all
these metrics are related to off-page
seos you want a good tool that's going
to help you measure this okay so let's
talk about rank tracking so when we do
keyword research we're looking for
Relevant keywords we find our relevant
keywords we sign primary and secondary
keywords to Pages we optimize those
pages we do off-page SEO and we do an
all this work for SEO okay we want to be
able to measure the fruits of our labor
we want to be able to measure how we
perform for on and off page SEO for the
keywords we covet in the pages they're
related to and so that's where rank
tracking comes into play so we want to
be able to track our website's ranking
and not just our website all the pages
we've optimized we want to be able to
measure our click-through rates and
Impressions we want to be able to track
the ranking for both desktop and mobile
for specific locations and we want to
identify top performing gaining and
losing keywords so in other words we
want to look at Trends is a keyword
ranking is it going up and ranking is it
going down and ranking if it's going
down and ranking then you need to take
action so you need a tool a good tool
for rank tracking so we can look no
further than again Google search console
it's free it's right from the source so
let's take a look at what Google search
console has to offer in terms of rank
tracking so if I go to this Google
Search console and I put in a URL what
it's going to do is it's going to give
me and this is the search queries report
it's going to give me what queries
people have used to actually type into
google.com and it's going to be able to
tell me how many times my pages show
Pages showed up for that query it could
be more than one page so that's an
impression and if I did receive an
impression meaning did my page show up
in the organic listing then did I get a
click as a result and so in this case if
I got 68 Impressions and 10 clicks for
keywords somebody typed in that's a 14.7
percent click through rate and so with
search console we'll also do is say hey
look for that particular keyword you
appeared on average in position 4.1 so
it gives you really good insight as to
you know what people are typing in and
how you're being found for those
keywords it breaks it down by Pages it
breaks it down by country breaks it down
by device so I could see you know mobile
I've had
899 Impressions over the last three
months on mobile and I received 33
clicks as a result my average position
on mobile is 2.6 so search console does
a really good job again this is free
information uh providing you the actual
keyword somebody's using on Google
search as a query and how many
Impressions you're receiving for that
keyword how many clicks click the rate
and then average position so in theory
the higher you are positioned on Google
the more clicks you're going to receive
so if I'm not positioned properly for
keyword let's say page two then I'm
probably not going to receive as many
clicks as I would like so that's search
console there are other tools out there
like hrefs again does a good job of
tracking AMZ tracker we look at wincher
so there's some good tools out there I'm
just going to show you another one again
I'm going to go back to Moz for example
so Moz has a tool called so if I go back
into the account so Moz has a rankings
tool that you can look at to see where
your keywords are ranking so if you've
already chosen keywords and optimized
Pages for those keywords then you want
to be able to load those keywords into
Moz and so Moz allows you to do that and
so what Moz does they do a crawl once a
week and they'll be able to tell you
where you rank for all your keywords are
we moving up in the rankings are we
moving down how many keywords do we have
ranked between positions one and three
eleven through twenty four through ten
twenty one through fifty so we'll be
able to see where our keywords Rank and
so it gives you a breakdown here of
nationally in the United States where
this keyword is ranked and if it's moved
up or down and for what URL is it ranked
for and so you can label soak the
keywords and and this is what you want
to look for in a good tool you want to
be able to organize your keywords and
label them so for all our brand keywords
we want to be able to label them branded
because ideally you don't want to
optimize for your brand keywords so
maybe we want to exclude our brand
keywords and look at our non-brand
keywords in terms of ranking and so you
can certainly add locations and look at
specific locations the whole idea
between a good ranking tool is to be
able to measure you know if a keyword is
trending up or down okay so I can simply
look at a particular keyword and I can
see the trend of that keyword and then
you know if a keyword is not ranking
then we want to wonder why it's not
ranking well is it difficult is it not
ranking because of its difficulty or can
we do a better job of optimizing for
that keyword and so Moz also has a page
optimization tool so if you're not
ranking for keyword you can flip over
the page optimization tool then put in
the keyword put in the URL and mods will
give you some idea as to what you can
further do to optimize the page okay so
that's Moz you know this is hrefs so you
can see ahrefs does the same thing it
provides you some visibility average
position how much traffic you know where
you're ranking in terms of positions one
through three four through ten eleven
through fifty and so you want to be able
to get a sense of where my track
keywords are trending are they training
up are they trending down and the whole
idea again be on a ranking tool is if
you're trending down you want to be able
to address why it's trending down so you
want to start with on-page SEO can we do
a better job of optimizing or off page
does that page need more backlinks so
that's why you need a backlink tool to
support your ranking and ahrefs does
offer up some competitor information as
well so you can see how your competitors
are performing so these are some good
examples of ranking tools that you could
take advantage of now there are also a
few important SEO tools that can be
helpful in different ways for example if
you're doing video so there are some
tools to help you measure how you're
performing via video for example vid IQ
so let's take a look at vid IQ so if I
load in say video in YouTube in this
example how to rank YouTube videos I
have Avid IQ extension loaded into my
browser in Chrome and so now I can get a
good eye sense of how many views the
duration the engagement rate the like
ratio go how many people shared it on
Reddit but further I can look at how the
video was optimized so they're telling
me the title's too long here maybe
shorten it up but we have tags we have
descriptions we have cards we have end
screens it's been shared on Facebook it
hasn't been shared on Twitter okay it is
public we do have pinned comments and we
do have hearted comments and so this
gives me an idea of how we did in terms
of optimizing this particular video okay
so if we wanted to tweak it we could
tweak the title tag make it a little bit
shorter to help it rank better on
YouTube so you want to be able to use a
tool like this because if you have
videos then you want those videos to
rank and so you can certainly watch this
video on how to rank your YouTube videos
and in that video we do allude to vid IQ
so you want to be able to use a tool
like this because you know YouTube it is
a video portal but it's the second
largest search engine behind Google so
if you do have videos you want want to
be able to rank for them and you want a
tool that's going to help you measure
and help you understand if you are
ranking if you're not ranking why are
you not ranking now for Content
optimization there are tools you can use
like SCS site checkup or site analyzer
are some good tools if you already have
Moz as an example just going back to Moz
as you already know I use Mozilla so
they have a page optimization so you
could check the content and how you're
optimized your content so it's going to
give me some good feedback on you know
is your page title meta description are
they in line okay so it's going to give
you some good feedback on that you also
have again I have to allude to search
console you can always look at a
particular page in search console and
see if it has any errors as well so is
it duplicated meta description is it a
duplicated title tag is it any Pages
missing title tags your meta
descriptions so when it comes to content
you can look at search console you can
lean on Mars or you can lean on some of
these other paid versions like site
analyzer when it comes to traffic and
metrics look no further than Google
analytics there is a free version of
Google analytics as well as a paid
version so if I go into Google analytics
it's going to tell me all of my website
Behavior okay who's coming to my site
how they got to my site how they behaved
once they went to my site and are they
achieving the goals I set out for them
to achieve via conversions and so you
want to look at first in Google
analytics how much traffic you're
getting so if I go to Google analytics
if I go to acquisition all traffic
channels I should be able to see how
much traffic organic search is driving
over a period of time so I could see how
many users how many sessions then if I
click on landing pages I can see what
landing page they went to so I could see
the home page over a particular time I
had over a thousand sessions I can also
see engagement from organic search are
they bouncing how many pages are they
looking at in this session after they
landed on a particular page are they
staying on the site a long time what's
their duration or are they achieving any
goals so analytics will provide me all
that information about how organic
search as a channel is performing the
other thing about Google analytics I
like and that goes back to the technical
aspect of SEO and that site speed so if
you go to behavior and you go to site
speed overview you'll be able to see how
my pages are loading what's the average
load time so they'll break it down for
you by browser by country and by
specific page so if I look at page
timings I'll be able to see what page is
loading slow what page is loading quick
compared to site average and so the
great thing about analytics is if I have
a page that's loading slow compared to
site average they'll actually provide me
with some suggestions so if I go to site
speed then speed suggestions what
they're going to do is they're going to
have a link in the report that's going
to allow me to click on it and I'm going
to be able to see what suggestions they
can provide so when this report loads
I'll be able to see what the speed
suggestions are for my pages so here I
could see the page I could see what the
average load time is of that page so for
example this particular page is loading
at six seconds ideally we want to have
you know three seconds or under maximum
so if I just click on this link here
they're giving me six page speed
suggestions so if I click on that I'm
going to go to another Google tool
called page speed insights and then page
speed insights is going to run for both
mobile and desktop for this particular
page and then this page speed insights
report is going to give me feedback as
to what I need to do to speed up the
load time of that page so here you can
see for desktop and mobile they're going
to give me some suggestions and
opportunities ready to get started click
the link in the description box and
embark on your journey to the
professional growth and achievement
hurry up spot are filling up fast in the
age of digital marketing it is very easy
to get lost in the sea of information if
you are a beginner you will probably
spend a lot of time reading and
researching even if you are an expert
you will still need to keep up to date
and know what's going on in the
marketing world but how do you find the
time to do that how do you find the time
to stay on top of Trends and Innovations
we have compiled a list of 20 plus
digital marketing tools to help you make
your life easier
some of these tools might sound familiar
to you and some might sound new and
interesting we believe all of them have
some value in your life and can assist
you in staying on top of trends hey
everyone I am tusha bariwal welcome to
Simply learns YouTube channel in this
video we will understand 20 plus digital
marketing tools to grow your business in
2022 but before we begin if you enjoy
watching Tech related content consider
subscribing to our YouTube channel and
hitting that Bell icon to stay tuned
so without any further delay let's get
started with the plan for today's
session first we will look at the
research part next we will explore tools
to build or host the website content is
king So next we will have a look at some
of the best content creation tools to
grow your business
moving forward we will discuss designing
and Graphics tools once designing is
done it's time to promote and hence we
will look at the best promotional tools
after that we will discuss some great
email marketing tools user behavior and
competitor analysis tools and finally we
will end the session by understanding
the communication tools that will help
your business operate smoothly
research research is one of the most
essential parts of getting your business
to the next level it's what turns an
idea into a real business however it is
hard to do research without the right
tools luckily there are many tools out
there that do the job perfectly here are
just few that you need to know about
Uber suggest Uber suggest is a free tool
that produces fresh keyword ideas it is
among the best free tools available on
the market however it has a Premium plan
for advanced features but it is best if
you are starting out and it has some
good features like you will get the
search volume for free keyword ideas and
content ideas
Keyword Planner it is one of the best
free tools and the best part is that
it's a Google product so that the data
can be trusted you can use Google
Keyword Planner to do keyword research
Google Keyword Planner will show you the
monthly search volume of keywords and
phrases the average cost per click in
your selected country and how difficult
it is to rank for the keywords some of
the best features are you will get the
custom time based keyword data and get
to know the competition on that keyword
hrefs hrefs is one of the most advanced
tool available for keyword research it
is also used for competitor analysis
rank tracking and site auditing href's
main features are geared towards
marketer but you can also use it to find
keywords for Google YouTube and Amazon
the tool is paid but suitable for
businesses looking for in-depth
information it has some features like
rank tracker that will help you know
your existing website ranking and the
second one is alert you will get
important information or stats by mail
after doing the research part you need a
website for your business let's have a
look at how to do that the first step in
creating a website is to find a place to
host it there are many options out there
and depending on what your site will be
used for you may need different tools
web hosting tools have evolved to meet
the online communities need better it
can be challenging to select the right
one through many options here are the
few of the best tools available on the
market
WordPress it will help you create your
website by just drag and dropping no
coding is required also it has a lot of
plugins that can be used according to
your website needs blogger you can
create a beautiful blog using blogger
for free and it is also has free themes
which you can use
still it is always recommended that you
use tools like WordPress to build your
website because businesses need a
website with lot of functionalities and
WordPress makes this process easier
the website requires hosting as the next
tool we have is hostinger you need to
purchase a domain and hosting to host a
website there are other companies also
available that you can use to host your
site such as GoDaddy HostGator Etc
hosting job provides automatic backups
that will ensure that your website data
is secured it allows you to create
unlimited subdomain which is also
necessary for a business website
for free hosting and free domains you
can use Infinity free but for a business
website it is always recommended to go
with the paid hosting because this will
give your customer a good experience
when they visit your website but for
beginner just wanting to learn how
website hosting works you can use
Infinity free every Business website and
its social media platform need content
and content is the oxygen of the
internet there is no surviving without
it but meeting the demand of a Content
hungry World often means that you are
forced to pull your hair out only to
throw more into the fire
from research to Creation to
distribution content is now 24x7 job
requiring many internal resources or
costly outsourced help if you are
looking to cut down the cost and
streamline your efforts here are some
content creation tools to take your
business to the next level
headline it is an AI tool that will
create a landing page automatically no
writing designing and coding is required
you need to give information about the
product and it is also has built-in
templates to use it became famous
because of this feature but now it is
upgraded and you will see a lot of other
features that will help you create
excellent content it is a paid tool but
you can try its free version
pepper type it is a One-Stop AI solution
tool for all content needs and the best
part is you will get 10 000 word limit
to try out this fantastic tool the
specialty of this tool is that it allows
you to create content for specific
social media platforms and long form
content
grammarly grammarly is a free online
tool that find mistakes in your writing
and suggest improvements as you write
grammarly will underline any mistakes
you have made and offer suggestions on
how to fix them
additionally it has a plagiarism Checker
and a punctuation checker
however for additional features you need
to go with grammarly premium
the best way to create excellent content
is to have good visuals this is why we
have listed the best designing tools
that you can use to get stock images and
videos canva you can design your website
using canva for free it is the best tool
to make your website content more
engaging
it is a simple drag and drop tool that
allows you to create beautiful Graphics
Flyers infographics social media post
and more you can also use it to create
more engaging images for your posts
furthermore it gives you free templates
and allows you to collaborate with your
business team using team functionality
pixabay pixabay is a free website or a
creative community that shares copyright
free photos illustrations music and
videos
all picks up a Content are licensed
under the pixaby license you can use
them without asking for permission or
crediting the artist even for commercial
purposes
you can download these stock images
videos musics and illustration without
signing up
Shutterstock although it also comes with
the same feature the key difference is
that it is paid you might wonder why to
use this shutter stock since we already
have a free tool like pixabay well it
depends on your business needs there are
some images and stock footage that you
will only find on certain stock in
addition such a stock has powerful
editing tools and custom size options
that attract people
now we have a better understanding of
the content part in order to attract
more visitors the content needs to be
promoted the following tools will help
you promote your business Drive traffic
to your website convert visitors into
leads build brand awareness Etc
Google ads Google ads are a powerful
tool that can help you reach your target
audience it is small but significant
step towards online Success Through many
people believe that Google ads are not
as effective as they used to be there
are still more benefits than drawbacks
the only thing you need to know how to
use it your website can be advertised
via Google ads and your product and
services can be promoted on YouTube it
has an excellent feature lead form
extension that allow user to provide
their contact details directly through
the ad without visiting your landing
page additionally Live Events targeting
for example graduating from a college is
also a great feature since it helps you
reach the correct type of audience
Facebook ads manager it allows you to
run Facebook and Instagram ads and it's
an excellent way to promote your
business a feature like Facebook
analytics will give you a good grasp of
data feature like audience Insight will
better understand who is interested in
your product and services
Google ads and Facebook ads require you
to spend money on ads by setting up a
daily or a custom budgets
basumo is a Content marketing tool to
help you find the best ways of engaging
creating and spreading content across
social and search channels two of the
best feature is finding an influencer
that will help you to find the right
influencer and a Content Discovery
feature which will help you to discover
new content ideas
email marketing tools are the most
effective means to stay in touch with
your customers you can nurture leads
rearrange with your audience and build a
subscriber base through email businesses
today recognize the importance of email
and marketers are investing heavily in
email marketing tools however in the
overwhelming sea of email marketing
tools finding the right fit can be
tricky we have selected some of the best
email marketing tools to help your
business get started and grow through
MailChimp MailChimp is a comprehensive
marketing platform that lets you keep
track of and communicate with your
clients customers and other interested
parties but it is popular because of its
email Services there is a free plan of
MailChimp the free plan is often more
than enough for small businesses up to
2000 subscribers can be added and 12 000
emails can be sent a month it supports
multiple integration to integrate other
third-party softwares and MailChimp also
allows you to update or remove the
subscriber profiles which is also one of
the best feature of MailChimp send in
blue it is very similar to MailChimp
both have excellent and similar features
when it comes to email Services one
unique feature of sending blue is that
it has the option of a drag and drop
Builder that is accessible by mobile
analysis and optimization businesses
need to analyze and optimize their
processes to grow furthermore you should
analyze the data to develop a solution
to the problems in your industry several
tools can be beneficial here let's
discuss that
Google search console this tool will
help you understand how your website
performs on Google searches by ranking
on top you will have higher chances of
attracting more visitors the index
coverage report will help you understand
which web page have problems moreover it
has a very useful URL inspection tool
which gives information about Google's
indexed page version
with IQ many YouTubers majorly use it to
analyze their performance on YouTube and
optimize their Channel if you are
looking to rank your video on YouTube
you need to optimize the title
description and tags this tool helps you
to do that
the tool includes a thumbnail generator
that lets you create customized
thumbnails that generate good views and
it has Trend alerts which will notify
you by email of popular content
Google analytics using Google analytics
you can track the traffic on your
website and find out where your visitors
are coming from it also allows you to
track your sales performance and traffic
sources
Google analytics is a tool that will let
you know if your website is performing
well and also if you need to make some
changes to improve its performance
it has outstanding features like funnel
analysis and smart goals a funnel is a
method for determining which steps are
necessary to achieve the desired
outcomes and with smart goals you can
identify and count the most engaged
users on your website user Behavior user
Behavior tools help you understand user
behavior on the website user Behavior
tools are very effective tools used in
digital marketing to track the behavior
of visitors and make the business more
effective
below are the sum of the user Behavior
tools used in digital marketing
hot job hotja is an inside tool that
lets you analyze your customer behavior
and get feedback to understand them
better and come up with new business
strategies to grow your business
this tool gives you visual feedback
which you won't find in other tools and
it also offers surveys which is also a
unique feature of our jaw smart look it
is mostly similar to hot jaw but it has
some additional features like
customizable dashboard and conversion
funnel which means the visualization of
how people follow the path
competitor analysis many businesses
start their competitive study when
planning the digital marketing strategy
and then abandon it
it is essential to make adjustments
after competitor analysis and use great
tools here are some of the best
the tool is completely paid you can use
this tool to improve your PPC campaign
as it gives you insight into what your
competitors are doing keywords can also
be imported as well as downloaded
socialblade it is used for social media
monitoring and influencer tracking for
example you can get lot of information
about the performance of other
competitors and how they are doing on
YouTube and other social media channels
the best part is that many features are
available in the free plan
similar web it is also an excellent tool
to analyze competitors website traffic
and you can also get the Google Play and
Apple App Store data
href we already covered this in the
research category but we wanted to
mention it here because href will also
be viewed as one of the best tools for
analyzing competitors
communication
starting and building a successful
business require better communication
within your team we must ensure that our
task has been clearly communicated to
the team so that we will be able to
perform the work as we intended thus one
needs a tool to accomplish that so now
let's check out some of the best tools
for communication
slack the app is a chat room that brings
together all of your team's
Communication in one place meaning there
is a no longer a need to use email Skype
or multi-chat room apps slack can be
used with both work and personal
accounts and it can benefit businesses
in several different ways
Microsoft teams it is also similar to
slack but it offers unlimited app
integration and unlimited chat messages
there are free plans for both but you
can upgrade if your business need aren't
met here what you have learned so far
initially we discussed research then
tools to build and host the website next
we discussed content creation and
graphic designing tools after that we
discuss tools that will help in the
promotion and then the email marketing
tools after that we discussed analysis
and optimization tools
next we discussed user behavior and
competitor analysis tools and finally we
discuss the communication tools so here
we wrap up basics in digital marketing
if you like this video consider
subscribing to our Channel and hit the
Bell icon to never miss any updates if
you have any question put down in the
comment section our experts will be
happy to answer your questions stay
tuned with simply learn till we meet
again thanks for watching
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
foreign
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here